yeah there you go
tomorrow
hey everyone
um
oh thank you thank you this uh this is
the house Judiciary Committee and we're
holding hearings on uh several uh bills
I'm first going to ask everyone to rise
and I'm going to recognize uh
representative Devine to lead us in the
Pledge of Allegiance
of the United States
thank you
so ladies and gentlemen uh we have a
number of bills uh that we're going to
be holding hearings on today we had a
full day of hearings yesterday in which
we had a great number of witnesses
testified with various views on the
issues
um before us many of which are similar
or the same as the issues on bills today
it was a very although people had strong
disagreements it was a very respectful
and informative uh uh exercise
throughout the day and although it was a
long day it was very informative and I
would ask police that we have the same
manner of proceeding today that is in
people we understand that people have
different views and we expect you to
express them and express them uh
um vigorously but we also expect that it
will be conducted in in a respectful
manner so with that
um I'm going to first uh
turn to uh House Bill 346 FN and I'm
going to recognize representative Glenn
cordelli the prime sponsor of the bill
thank you Mr chairman and honorable
colleagues off the Record Glenn cordelli
representing Tuftonboro Wolfeboro and
Ossipee in the beautiful Lakes Region
usually I would be here at another
committee talking about the education of
children but today I take a step back to
talk about the lives of children
this is a very simple Bill a very simple
concept that a baby born alive should
have medical attention even if they are
born alive as the result of a failed
abortion
does a woman's right to choose an
abortion extend to a point beyond that
of birth
what about a baby born alive as the
result of a failed abortion
once that child is born and is separated
from the mother
is that child protected by the
Constitution
in California we have seen a law passed
recently that provides that no person
shall be subject to civil civil or
criminal penalties
for an alleged pregnancy outcome
including miscarriage still birth
abortion or perinatal death
perinatal is defined by the national
Center of health statistics as the
period between 28 weeks of gestation and
seven days after birth
perinatal
the argument is that this doesn't happen
in New Hampshire but how do we know
we don't capture any statistics
the abortion survivors Network says that
only 10 states states keep track of
abortion statistics
we saw in 1981 in a medical excuse me in
a Philadelphia Inquirer article that the
survival of a baby after abortion was
referred to as a dreaded complication
in that article it quoted Doctor Who was
then director of abortion surveillance
for the CDC as estimating that between
400 to 500 abortion live births occurred
each year in the United States
and according to the family research
Council we are one of 12 states with no
protection for children born alive as a
result of an abortion I just want to
take a moment um I I don't know if you
each have a copy of a highlighted
version of the bill but I just wanted to
point out several key things in that
highlighted version to you
on the first page on line 13 we have the
definition of born alive
uh on line 26 we Define reproductive
Health Care Facility
in statute that means a place other than
within or on the grounds of a hospital
where abortions are offered or performed
then on line 28
we have
a section related to the protection of
children
and most importantly
on the second page lines 8 through 12.
this is where the criminal penalties are
defined there would be a penalty only
only if a health care provider withholds
medical treatment
and performs an overt act with the
intention intention of causing or
hastening the death of an unborn child
that is the only case the only time
where there would be penalties against
the health care provider we've heard
stories in the past about
um
Health Care Providers being charged if
there is a fatal
abnormally with the the baby and the
baby cannot be resuscitated or is going
to die and wouldn't it be more Humane to
let the baby remain with the mother for
whatever time that baby has
yes
yes and the doctor in that case is not
withholding or causing or hastening the
death of a child
so that argument does not hold with this
bill that is before you so I ask you
um that
the question today
for all of us is whether we value the
lives of children born alive
whether they have constitutional
protections
thank you very much
thank you representative Cordell your
questions for representative pordelli
yes representative
no thank you
stop taking questions all right all
right then next I'll uh
call upon uh representative Katie uh
pattern please
and now and next after uh that will be
representative Gene Knott Janine Knott
thank you Mr chairman and thank you to
to the committee for the record I am
Katie pedernal representing Carol
District Six the towns of tufnemborough
and Wolfeboro
I am here to testify as a co-sponsor on
the born alive infant protection act
just to give you a little bit of
background I have a Bachelor of Science
in nursing and this part doesn't make me
an expert but I did work as a nurse Tech
in a neonatal Intensive Care Unit while
I was a nursing student I can still see
those infants and their parents
as for my personal background all of
which is on public record because I have
used it previously as testimony In This
Very haul
I was adopted as an infant
I released my own daughter for adoption
when I was 21.
my husband and I have four daughters and
two grandchildren I've been there for
the birth of both of my grandchildren
two of my daughters are single mothers
I have spoken with many women about
their painful abortion experiences
I also survived an emergency C-section
in an extremely rare situation where the
pregnancy itself put my life in severe
Danger
I survived
but my son did not
and I would have gladly traded places
with him
I will not be taking questions about my
personal history today but I offer my
experiences as a resource to the
committee regarding any of the ethics
surrounding that particular situation
now to get to this simple bill
let me start with an analogy
if a dog fell through the ice on one of
our beautiful lakes
the rescue of that dog would make local
if not National headlines
everyone involved would be hailed as a
hero
now I didn't research this but I'm
fairly certain that we don't have a law
that requires
EMS Personnel to rescue a dog in the
event that one falls through the ice
most of us would agree it's the right
thing to do
but we are here today to talk about
whether a child
accidentally born alive
accidentally born alive during a
procedure
performed with the express intent of
killing that child
whether or not that child has a
fundamental right to life
we are going to talk about why or how
that child has a right to life after an
attempt to kill it
now I've listened to all the testimony
on the last version of this bill House
Bill 233 from 2021 so I familiarize
myself with some of the arguments
this bill is not meant to interfere with
the complex and painful decisions that
parents must make when they have a child
born with complications that might make
it inhumane to attempt life-sustaining
treatment
this bill does not intend to disallow
parents to decide how their child should
live out the extent of his natural life
however long or short that life might be
this law does not intend to imply that a
woman must keep her child if it is born
alive as a side effect
of an attempted abortion
New Hampshire has a safe haven law
allowing for the relinquishment of a
child without a court order for up to
seven days of age
adoption is also an option and no the
woman never has to see the child ever
again if she doesn't want to
this bill does not have the intention of
Prosecuting providers who make the
challenging decision of deciding that it
wouldn't be in the child's best interest
to attempt life-sustaining procedures
this bill is only intended to allow an
infant
accidentally born alive
because of a failed attempt to kill it
to have the fundamental right to life
thank you
thank you I'm next going to call on
representative Jeannie notter please
thank you
thank you Mr chair and good morning
members of the committee
this is my 13th year here
I made a promise to defend and stand up
for innocent human life
and I feel sorry for them because I'm
not the best speaker
do the best I can
in the words of Dr Seuss a person is a
person no matter how small
the fetal Life protection act cover only
covers children old enough to live on
their own at her about six months of
given the chance
delivery is always a safer option for
the mother and saves the child's life
we should focus on the child who is
totally innocent is intentionally killed
and has a life expectancy of some
duration
the fetal Life protection act agrees
with all the four countries and most
countries banned abortions after 12 or
15 weeks
no other medical procedure causes the
death of another human being
have you heard of Kermit Gosnell
he ran that disgusting horrible filthy
Clinic that was not safe for women and
definitely not safe for the the babies
that he killed
if a baby is born alive after an
abortion it is cruel and inhumane not to
try and save that child
Gosnell may have severed the spines of
hundreds of born Alive babies with
scissors
one employee testified that she
witnessed Gosnell snipped the necks of
more than 30 babies and that he
sometimes gave her just the feet of a
fetus to place in formaldehyde
one employee testified that the baby
a baby still alive after being aborted
screamed one night and that the baby's
eyes and mouth were not yet completely
formed but that it was still alive
the baby was so big that Gosnell joked
that this baby's going to walk me home
one of the babies was reportedly moving
and breathing for 20 minutes before an
employee cut the spinal cord
I'm just highlighting things so I don't
keep you too long
I'm going to give you the names of four
or five survivors of abortion one of
them I mentioned yesterday Janet Jensen
who I've met and interviewed I used to
be a freelance writer I still I still do
interviews
she survived a saline abortion so what
is that it's a saline solution that has
things in it that I can't pronounce I
can accept potassium chloride and saline
of course
which is injected into the mother's
uterus and into the baby the saline
solution poisons the baby I'm going to
say her instead of him and her because
of Gianna burning her inside and out
burning off the outer layer of her skin
the baby suffers in these conditions for
over an hour until she dies and the
mother must deliver her dead child after
about one day
Gianna Jensen survived her mother's
late-term abortion because
somebody took pity on her and called an
ambulance
Melissa Odin survived a saline abortion
as well
she says something's wrong when women's
empowerment is based on ending another
human being's life
Claire cutwell
survived an abortion that killed her
twin brother so her mother didn't know
that she was pregnant with twins they
only aborted one of the babies but the
mother kept feeling kicking
and she ended up having the baby and the
baby was adopted
raised in a loving family
and then the last one was I a Priestly
was born after an incomplete abortion so
he was born without his arm oh and then
there was one more the same story but
what's interesting was that they didn't
they didn't uh hate their their birth
mothers they were able to forgive them
because of a given life because all life
is precious
and I'm going to leave these packets of
information with you for further study
for your um exact session and I I have
to get back to my committee so I'm not
going to take questions thank you
thank you representative daughter
representative uh sellers next
thank you Mr chair thank you committee
members
representative sellers Grafton 18 and I
mentioned it yesterday I'll just do it
once today I represent Alexandria
Bristol Bridgewater Hebron Groton
Dorchester orange the town of Grafton
Canaan and Enfield
I just want to point out a couple things
we're going to we're going to hear a lot
of testimony today
pros and cons both ways
you know and we all understand we don't
want anybody trampling on our rights and
what we're able to do and what we can't
do but here we are you know
2023 and we have to have some of these
laws and and even including this one
here
and let me just State up front I I
support this law I do
but this large you know
it's it's a shame it's an absolute shame
that we absolutely need this I can't
believe
as a civilization as a society we have
to put a law in place to protect a child
an infant
that for somehow came out of the womb
and is now breathing
what are we doing
why would we kill that child that infant
we're killing off our heritage
I don't understand why we would
absolutely do this I really don't and I
mean I I really respect the people on
both sides of the issue here but this is
to me it's ludicrous I mean it does not
make sense at all
and I just want to point out here on
first page line at 29.
very bottom
says it shall be you know
shall be treated in any other natural it
shall be treated as any AD no excuse me
shall be treated as any other natural
person under the laws
okay
the infant's alive
why wouldn't it be treated as any other
person under the law again
it's a shame we have to have this I
can't believe this I really can't it's
it's just humble it's beyond me it's
baffled
and I'm sure it's beyond some of you as
well
the infants alive
he or she is alive
but this last thing here is on page two
here uh line four
um
shall be entitled to no less protection
a remedy under the state's criminal laws
just like us just like you and me
we would we would not we should never
ever expect any different from an infant
part of life
all right it wasn't or anything else
thank you
[Music]
thank you questions for this Witness
uh thank you very much sir thank you
um next I'm going to call on uh Danielle
Pimentel and the next person after that
I forgot to do that before will be
Christine uh archa
thank you
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee my name is Danielle
Pimentel and I serve as policy Council
on Americans United for life which is a
non-profit national law and policy
nonprofit organization that specializes
in abortion end of life issues and
bioethics law and today I urge the
committee to support HB 346 for two
reasons first it is critical to
increasing the survival rates and
providing Comfort Care to Born alive
infant survivors and two it is critical
that is a critical supplement pardon me
to Federal Protection for born alive
infants
to my first Point Medical intervention
is critical to increasing the survival
rates and alleviating the suffering of
um of born alive infant survivors
advancements in medical technology have
allowed medical professionals to save
prematurely born children at younger
gestational ages we even heard yesterday
testimony from someone that said that
they knew a baby that was born at 19
weeks and it's now a fully healthy young
adult
um pre-born children as young as 21
weeks gestation have been able to
survive outside the womb and reports
from the CDC show that there are still
as many as 10 000 abortions in the U.S
that occur at or after 21 weeks
gestation
however a peri-viable infant is a
critically ill patient due to the
developmental immaturity and needs
credit critical Medical Care
so the bill protects these infants all
infants were alive regardless of their
gestational age at the time of birth and
medical pioneering teams are working and
have been working for years to increase
the survival rates for extremely
prematured babies
and pre-viable infants born alive have
the same human dignity that we all do
and deserve comfort and care which they
would receive under this bill
medical professionals can provide
perinatal palliative care to these young
patients which focuses on maximizing the
quality of life and comfort for the
newborns with a variety of different
conditions considered to be life
limiting
and while there isn't a standardized
abortion reporting
system in the U.S the reports that are
available still show it is not a myth
that there are infants born alive
following an abortion procedure for
example one CDC report found that over a
12-year period at least 143 babies
survived the abortion procedure before
ultimately passing away
but the CDC notes that it's possible
this number is actually underestimated
another study found that of the 20 241
pre-born children aborted for having a
fetal anomaly between 20 and 24 weeks
gestational age
122 infants survived the procedure
research organizations or another
research organization the Charlotte
loser Institute has gathered information
from the States from voluntary State
abortion reports and it found that 35
infants were born alive in Arizona in
Florida in Minnesota and in Texas in
2020 and 2021
eight babies were born alive in Florida
in 2022.
in this regard infants are surviving
attempted abortions and they are in
critical need of medical intervention to
increase their chances of survival
and to provide comfort care which this
bill would ensure
the last point I'll make very briefly is
that hb346 supplements the federal born
alive infant protection acts providing
necessary and Common Sense protections
for born alive infants
as we all know in 2002 the Congress U.S
Congress passed the born alive infant
protection act
um clarifying that federal law
recognizes that infants born alive at
any stage of development
um or the law recognizes that these
infants as persons
however while the law acknowledges the
that all born alive events are equal
have equal standing regardless of their
circumstances of their birth the law
does not ensure that these infants will
receive a life-saving protection
and this bill however does that and it's
still necessary to require an
affirmative action by a position to
ensure that an infant born alive after
an abortion receive the same level of
medical care as any other infant would
then HB 346 is more comprehensive than
the federal protections and fills in the
gaps by extending protections for all
born alive infants
um for these reasons I strongly urge the
committee to support this bill and I'm
happy to answer any questions questions
for this witness representative Oregon
thank you very much so uh Americans
United for life is a well-known um Pro
pro-life group I'll call it are you is
this a homegrown Bill and you're just
coming up to support the sponsors or is
this something that your organization
had a role in drafting
yes our organization
um focuses on policy throughout the
states and so I'm policy Council and my
focus is the Northeast and so we support
pro-life bills across the states
um and want to see life-affirming
measures enacted
other questions follow-up you're
probably the first person asked if some
how how long after a person is born are
they an infant I mean obviously this
uh
I mean this even I could theoretically
be called the Born To Life infant
because I was born alive but uh
obviously is there a time frame
that at least you would Vision this bill
applying to
well I'm not a medical professional so I
don't know the actual definition of when
a baby
baby but most of the time that is I
would assume generally within the first
year of their birth
other other questions
yes representative greeson thank you Mr
chair and thank you for your testimony
this morning understanding that uh a
physician or a medical personnel is
attempting to provide the medical care
for an infant born alive
uh
to what extent must the care continue uh
if if there are attempts and it dies do
they try to resuscitate it if they're
able to resuscitate it and it dies again
they resuscitate it again how long are
they required to continue to perform
this life-saving or attempted
life-saving care before then they can
just say okay the baby now passes away
right well if we look at the bill
and I'm going to turn to it so I can
look at it with you
um
okay
so the bill States obviously that that
any infant born alive shall be treated
as any other natural person under the
laws and at the same time
um any of the laws including any part of
me any of the laws on the state wish to
punish a remedy harm to Natural persons
including love referring to another
Etc and so even though the law doesn't
say specifically how far that would
extend
um I mean it it the law is following
what's already in place for other
infants and so with Physicians um how
this would probably apply is that they
would do within their reasonable medical
judgment to
um you know give this baby care medical
treatment along the medical treatment
standards and if that baby dies and
there's a chance of resuscitating then
they have their own reasonable medical
judgment to do so
um however the law is not going to
require them to continue to try to
resuscitate a baby if that's not you
know something that they think would be
able to actually resuscitate them right
further questions for this win
seeing none thank you very much uh
Christine our show and then next will be
uh Nancy glint
hello my name is Dr Christine Arsenal
um I am a pediatrician and mother of
three children and I'm speaking today on
behalf of myself and the New Hampshire
chapter of the American Academy of
Pediatrics
I am here to oppose house bill 346. I
want to start out by saying
despite what we have heard so far this
bill is not about abortion
the people who this bill would affect
our families faced with a tragedy that I
think any parent any expectant parent
has considered
and felt fortunate not to have to endure
which is experiencing
the delivery of a baby with a fetal a
fatal condition
for several years I worked in a level
two NICU and attended the delivery of
numerous newborns any time there was
considered to be some sort of risk at
every delivery that I attended
the team and I followed protocols to
support the newborn as it transitioned
to life outside of the uterus this is
what doctors and nurses do in almost
every circumstance
rarely as we've sort of heard some of
the supporters mention expectant parents
will learn that their fetus has a
medical condition that will not allow it
to live independently
an example of this which I believe was
mentioned is anencephaly when the fetus
brain does not develop
in these um tragic cases when the family
learns of these diagnoses they will meet
with a palliative care team and their OB
GYN and receive extensive counseling on
their options
some of these families choose to carry
their pregnancy to term deliver their
baby and spend some time with the infant
to peacefully and privately grieve
before the baby passes away
now we have heard some of the supporters
of the bill
say that this law doesn't apply to these
families
the problem is the way it's written it
does
so
I
cannot imagine
having to whisk these babies away to
perform chest compressions insert
breathing tubes and transfer them to a
institution with a higher level of care
because frankly if if the penalty were a
felony which is what this bill proposes
that that would be what we had to do as
providers unless we wanted to face
prison time
these conversations and these cases are
so nuanced and having a law requiring
that every single baby be resuscitated
puts providers
in an impossible and families in an
impossible position
if parents of a newborn desire their
baby to be resuscitated the medical team
will never question that choice and will
always uphold that choice however
in the rare tragic circumstances when
parents make a decision to allow their
baby to die peacefully in their arms
rather than live a brief Life marred by
aggressive Interventional procedures we
owe them that
I urge you to vote inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 346. thank you
questions for this witness yes yes
representative
if the spell were to be amended to
exclude some of these situations such as
you know a baby being born you know with
a TBI and suffering you know severe CP
and is never going to have
a potential quality of life or something
of that nature but it offered
protections for
say
a failed abortion attempt at home of
somebody that delivered a baby at 26
weeks but potentially would be viable
and be able to be
given care would that be something that
you would able to to support would you
potentially be willing to work together
to make sure that we're protecting the
families that want to
be able to hold their babies that that
have these fatal fetal anomalies but to
still protect the life of babies that
are viable
I think it's interesting because we can
hear that on that point we're all on the
same page I think
um
that babies with fatal anomalies should
parents should be allowed to peacefully
agree
um
that never happens unless there is an
extensive discussion beforehand with a
palliative care team and the family and
multiple medical providers if an EMT
were to show up at situations such as
you describe our default is resuscitate
that's our default and there are
protocols and we can do it in our sleep
because that's our default they're
um
and it's just impossible to write
legislation that considers every
individual
case
and that's why these
that's why medical providers ethical
boards why we exist you know so that we
can
go over these problems and Tackle them
on an individual basis so no I don't
think it's possible to create
legislation that can address every
single
case
questions
uh yes representative Perez
thank you
I have a couple of questions it's my
understanding in some of the earlier
testimony that one of the big
protections of this bill would be a
failed abortion at 23 weeks
so you have our law allows abortion for
any reason up to 24 weeks so you have a
failed abortion
at 24 weeks I'm assuming these abortions
are going to take place they can't take
place that I've learned yesterday at
um Planned Parenthood so you have a
perfectly
healthy
child being aborted at 23 weeks and that
abortion is failed
and the baby is born alive
I believe this bill is to protect that
so is there anywhere in your practice
that would allow you to
hasten the death
of a child of a failed abortion who was
perfectly healthy
no doctor would ever hasten the death of
a child
okay so we're talking about so if
there's a failed abortion the I am I am
not a an abortion provider right I
believe that these questions are meant
to distract from the people that the
bill would actually harm
I think it was made very clear that
holding your baby when they have only a
little time but I think this bill it's
my understanding is to protect the
failed abortion of a 23-week that could
survive I know we do not allow euphemism
in this state is that correct
so I think this is to protect the child
form do you not agree I
reading this bill
I think of the families who it will
affect
and that those are the families whose
infant
has a fatal fetal diagnosis
that is who it will truly affect
I do not see this as an abortion bill I
see this as a bill that will
harm families who as I said are in a
situation that any of us who can had
nightmares about and were so fortunate
not to have to endure so that's that's
how I see this bill is that it affects
those families I do not see this as
being about abortion
thank you thank you
other questions for this witness yes I
do have one I I mean I I understand what
you're sort of positing the situation
of
a couple or a woman who who doesn't
really want to have an abortion and the
and the
um there's a there's some kind of a
fatal fetal abnormality and when the
woman you know with a couple wants to be
able to have time to comfort and sort of
grieve as opposed to trying you know
perhaps hopelessly maybe a lot maybe
most of them yeah but I guess what the
thing I'm not
sure your addressing is what about the
situation of the woman who wants to have
an abortion she does not want this child
and at 23 weeks an abortion is attempted
and the the you know for some reason
that attempt fails so the child is now
born alive and that person is not saying
to the doctors I want to grieve with
this child I want to you know I I what
that person is saying is I had a legal
right to abortion at 23 weeks and I
asked you to provide to do it and you
failed I don't want this child now what
does the doctor do in that situation
that is
a very theoretical situation
and these are real cases that I'm
familiar with I am not an abortion
provider
this bill
has real harm and I don't know that that
would be a real benefit
other questions for this week
seeing none thank you
next I'm going to call on Nancy Glenn
and the next witness after that will be
Devin chafee
thank you chairman and members of the
House Judiciary Committee for hearing my
story my name is Nancy Glenn and I live
in Sutton New Hampshire I oppose HB 346
and I hope that you will all take my
personal experience into consideration
we go back seven years ago in June of
2015. I was in the hospital because of
complications in my pregnancy and I was
being prepped for an emergency C-section
I am brought into the operating room
with my husband by my side alongside us
were three nurses
as well as in Maternal Fetal Medicine
doctor four nurses for the NICU two
anesthesiologists one OB GYN a
neonatologist from the NICU and then
there are two more people that were
there as well that I wasn't exactly sure
what their role was
if you add all of those people together
you get 14 people not counting my
husband and I
it was a crowded space and it was an
extremely serious situation
C-sections are quick and within a half
hour my beautiful son Sawyer was born
the nurses and doctors immediately
started to work on him
he was having trouble breathing and they
were checking all of his other vital
signs about an hour later there was
still a struggle to keep sort of
incubated
he was so tiny he only weighs 11.6
ounces when he was born
the nurses and doctors continued and the
neonatologist came to me and my husband
and said
we can't keep the tube in
I start screaming at the doctor asking
him what do we do now
I had a son that was also born premature
earlier his older brother Hunter who's
now 11.
and I kind of had a general idea of them
being able to do some of these medical
procedures to be able to help support
the baby
my emotions were an all-time high and
the doctor froze and wasn't sure how to
respond
my husband recognized what the doctor
was trying to say and he very calmly
asked give us our son keep him
comfortable give us our son
the doctor and the other providers
understood and they respected our ask
and they brought Sawyer to us it was the
first time I got to see him
Sawyer was then placed on my chest with
my husband's arms wrapped around him
he was so beautiful
we spent every last moment together as a
family we spent the time memorizing his
face telling him how much we loved him
if I closed my eyes and if I listened
really close I can still hear those
little sweet sweet breasts and the sound
of them are still right there in my
brain
I kissed him on the forehead and then he
was gone
those myths with him are the only memory
I have of him and I cannot begin to
describe to you what those moments have
done for my emotional and mental healing
especially as a mom I was also on
Medicaid for my pregnancy and I lost
coverage before I could get any proper
grief counseling
I am forever grateful that the medical
providers listen to me and my husband
and ensured that we had that time to
spend with Sawyer and make that sweet
memory that helps me get through every
single day
a wise Pastor once told me that the
greatest pain one could ever experience
is the loss of a child
that losing a child takes you to the
deepest darkest pits of hell and you
either come back stronger and more
Fierce than ever or you say in those
deep dark pits and allow it to consume
you
I know that the memories that I was able
to have with Sawyer ultimately have made
me stronger and more fierce
strong and fierce to care for his older
brother Hunter
who also has a disability
strong and fierce enough to be an active
member of my community
strong and fierce enough to share this
story with you all today a story that
exposes my vulnerability and reopens the
Eternal wound of the missing piece of my
family every single time I have to tell
it
but I continue to do so in hopes that
other families who experience this
tremendous loss have a chance to hold
their loved one as they pass
I share in hopes that the medical
professionals who are trained to do no
harm will not face charges because they
recognize how important these last few
moments are
I strongly urge you to oppose HB 346 and
to see for what it truly is
to reference I did walk in earlier and I
did hear that the intent of this bill is
to not take this right away
from families like mine that that's the
intent but the way it is written it will
and it will cause harm to families
I am one of many who has lost a child
and will lose a child in the future
every parent should have the opportunity
to have those moments and make those
memories with their baby so they too can
be strong and fierce for their families
their communities and themselves
I thank you very much as legislators for
everything that you all do thank you
questions for this Witness
yes representative Stapleton
thank you for taking my question I'm so
very sorry for your most difficult life
experience
and um can appreciate the grief and the
sorrow accompanying that
but it sounds like from your testimony
did I hear you say 14 in attendance of a
number of medical people doctors and
nurses
it sounds like they were trying to do
everything they possibly could to save
the life of your son
that would wouldn't that be different
from someone who gave up and just
ordered
the baby terminated you didn't do that
the doctors didn't do that you all were
trying to make the best out of a
difficult situation that's a lot
different from what this bill is talking
about isn't it
unfortunately representative the way it
is written it is not is too vague
I have I have read the bill I have
looked at it I also do work in
organizing and policy change I have
looked at it and the way that is written
because of the way it's written and how
vague it is it does leave out the pain
and suffering of families like mine
so I would say that I understand that
you all are pointing to this as being an
abortion Bill something that is related
to that but I can tell you that it is
poorly written if that is what is is
solely about
thank you other questions for this week
saying none thank you very much I'm
going to call on Devin chafee uh next
and then that and the witness after that
will be uh Michael Michelle
thank you chairman Lynn and other
honorable members of this committee for
the record my name is Devin chafee and
I'm the executive director of the ACLU
of New Hampshire and I am here today to
urge you to vote in expedient to
legislate on HB 364.
I want to start by saying that I really
greatly appreciate the opportunity to be
before you today and to engage you on
this issue because I think it is just so
important that the conversation that we
are having here today be rooted in the
reality
not hypotheticals but in the reality of
the impossible difficult medical
decisions that parents and families have
to make in consultation with their
medical providers
you have already heard some stories here
today and I know you will hear more
about this reality and I know that many
of us many of us have either personally
experienced or we know someone who
personally has experienced
very difficult circumstances in
pregnancy such as a extremely early
labor or fatal fetal diagnosis or even
those who have experienced a high
pregnancy a high sorry a high threat a
High um risk pregnancy like I had with
my twins where the threat of one of
these horrible outcomes
is very very present in the minds of
expecting parents and I know that all of
us have compassion for the parents and
families who are in these situations and
for the difficult situations that they
are in and the decisions that they have
to make with their doctors
no one wants to be in this position
and the bottom line is that regardless
of the intent of this bill HB 346
impacts such impossible decisions where
an infant has only hours or days to live
and a family must decide how to spend
the little time they have left with
their child
it could deny parents the ability to
choose the type of Compassionate Care
that works for their family and their
faith in these situations and it would
allow them as we would allow them to do
at any other point right in a child's
life
anybody who has had to make the
impossible decision to take a loved one
off of life support
understands the excruciating pain of
these decisions understands that these
types of decisions are not one size fits
all
and if a child were dying at the age of
one or five or even six months we would
entirely trust the parents in
consultation with their doctors to make
the best decision regarding
Compassionate Care for their child
but HB 346 adds restrictions on the
adopter's ability to provide a standard
of care according to the parents wishes
for newborns under the threat of a class
a felony
if this be if this bill becomes law
doctors will be forced to administer
futile and painful treatment to extend
the life of an infant for just minutes
or hours against the wishes of the
parents
the bill explicitly requires doctors to
apply Medical Care to quote preserve the
life and health of the born alive infant
unquote
now we know that there are and will be
cases where medical procedures could
give an infant a few minutes or an extra
hour or a day to live but it would take
the infant out of the arms of its
families and cause more pain and grief
and I know you have heard today
testimony that begs this question as to
whether or not this bill is in fact
necessary to prevent infanticide
or to make sure that babies are not born
alive and then somehow left to die
but the answer to that question is quite
simply no
of course not
of course not it is not necessary
infanticide is already illegal under
state and federal law harming anyone
including a newborn is illegal
quite frankly to suggest otherwise it's
inflammatory and it is insulting to
Medical providers some of whom are here
today and who are working so hard to
provide quality care to their patients
no one is killing infants with impunity
it is not happening
now there was one example that was given
here today by a previous individual who
testified talking about Kermit Gosnell
who ran a horrible criminal Enterprise
in Philadelphia
and we can all agree that it is correct
that he is serving a life sentence in
prison for murder as he should be
no one's debating that there are
existing laws that prohibit infanticide
and other types of murder and the jury
that punished him for his appalling
crimes we can all agree with them
I'm just going to end by simply saying
that there is an issue there is a reason
why when this issue goes to voters
actually goes to the people as it did in
Montana last November voters defeat
these types of measures
HB 346 would harm families already
struggling in tragic situations
and I want to just point out that the
supporters of this provision you cannot
have it both ways either this bill goes
further than existing laws and does
actually have restrictions on doctors
providers and parents
or it simply codifies existing prohibit
prohibitions on infanticide in which
case it's unnecessary because those
things are already prohibited under
federal and state law and are already
being enforced
and I'll just end by saying
we all know how hard end of life
decisions are please do not make these
Private health care decisions that
should be between a family and their
provider even more difficult
for these reasons I respectfully urge
the members of this committee to vote in
expedient to legislate on HB 346 thank
you questions for this Witness
representative Staples
thank you for taking my question
that was a very moving argument that you
make
let's go back to the bill
on page two line nine
the health care provider is the one
on the hook for this if some if if
there's a violation of law
but he must have the intention of
causing or hastening the infant's death
now in some of the testimonies we've
heard here
we see medical people striving to
preserve the life
of the child born even if there are
fetal anomalies and abnormalities
isn't that a lot different than an
intentional causing or hastening of an
infant's death to terminate its life
on a request and even
but we do distinctly draw the difference
and this is not a case-by-case example
or exception but rather addressing the
problem
of a bad actor or a bad action
to terminate the life
of that child whether it's a normal life
or even if it's a fetally
abnormal uh
anomaly
um we're talking about the intentional
causing or hastening of that death
there's a distinct difference is there
not
thank you representative Stapleton for
that question I guess where I'm getting
confused is the killing of an infant
infanticide murder is already illegal
under New Hampshire and federal law and
and I'm not at all clear as to what
these circumstances are that are
actually happening in reality where
infants are being killed but somehow are
not covered by existing law that
prohibits and fantasize and so that this
is where I don't understand and this is
where I am concerned that we are talking
about hypotheticals instead of really
considering the reality of the
individuals and the families in these
difficult circumstances and how this law
might impact them I also want to say
that that by targeting Physicians so
clearly in this legislation not just
Physicians but really any Hospital
employee
with a class a felony for providing the
care that they see as most fit
we're potentially setting up medical
providers against one another
and really encouraging them it's not
requiring and forcing them to provide
treatment that could be futile and I
think we have heard extensive testimony
already here today about the potential
negative effects that that could have on
real families who are really
experiencing these um these horrific
circumstances in their lives
other questions for this week
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
I'm sorry so um
next uh we have uh
Michael I'm not sure if it's Michael or
Michelle uh Michelle Mike okay Michelle
and next after that will be
representative uh Matt Simons
thank you
good morning committee members uh thank
you for hearing my testimony
my name is Michael Michelle I am a
resident of Dover and I'm speaking in
opposition of HP 346.
HP 346 could restrict options for
families like mine who are grieving the
loss of their child denied them the
ability to choose Compassionate Care
that's best for them
I want to share one man's story give one
man's perspective because I don't see
men speaking out enough about this
my wife and I divorced years after this
happened so I'll not speak for her views
today just about what happened to both
of us just over 30 years ago now
my wife and I were very excited we found
out that she was pregnant we had no
reason to be concerned so like most
people in our situation we started
planning and preparing
she went for her checkups we began
preparing the baby's room getting
Furniture picking out names Etc
later in the pregnancy we started
pushing your OB for an ultrasound really
just so we could find out the sex
the ultrasound was done around 30 weeks
or so when we got home from the
appointment
it was a phone message from her OB to
call right away found out the baby had
spina bifida their doctor had already
set up an appointment for my wife
this is on Friday and at that time there
was very little information online
so we spent the weekend at the local
library researching spina bifida which
was a condition with a spinal column
doesn't form properly and as a result
nerves don't connect properly to the
rest of the body
still trying to wrap our head around
this news not life-threatening but
serious
we went to the ultrasound clinic on
Monday the doctor spoke to us afterwards
and told us that she could confirm the
spina bifida
but that was not really the big problem
she went on to describe a heart
condition tetralogy of Fallon which was
life-threatened
this started a parade of clinics and
hospital visits where we clinical
hospital visits we where we learned much
more baby had numerous challenges beyond
the Spina Bifida and the heart condition
missing kidney missing anus missing
connective tissue between halves of the
brain water on the brain other
conditions
numerous systems have problems most of
which would require surgery soon after
birth many surgeons
our best case scenario became four or
five surgeries in the first few weeks of
life
followed by many additional high risk
surgeries
the odds were very very bad
but not zero
while the baby was in utero we could not
get a clear enough picture to know
whether or not his conditions were
definitely fatal
each individual condition had decent
odds but the collection of conditions
made the prognosis very complicated
we were thankfully at a state-of-the-art
hospital dealing with the best doctors
in the world and these types of things
but we just couldn't know given the
state of Technology at the time
Connor was born two months later
once he was delivered the doctors were
better able to assess his condition and
we found out that there was no treatment
and he would drive die very soon
at first we could not hold him because
his spinal Sac was exposed and any
interaction ran the risk of infecting
his spinal fluid
but when we learned that his conditions
were terminal the doctors transitioned
to Comfort Care
that was the best thing we could do for
him
no one else can tell me
what was better than that
the alternative would have been a series
of surgeries to keep him alive a little
longer
while never being held by his parents
might have survived the first surgery
died in the second survived the second
died in the third we don't know
but he was going to die and so they
chose not to put him through them
this would have been cruel
he didn't deserve cruelty
owners survived for three days he was in
unbearable pain the entire time
likely from the time his nervous system
first formed in utero
the doctors had him on morphine from
birth
adult doses by the time he died
what gives another person the right to
tell my wife or I the right thing to do
in this situation
no State walk until a grieving couple
that can't hold their child until he
passes because every intervention must
be tried
even if doctors know it'll be futile
people like myself my wife the doctors
and nurses we worked with were all
trying to do what is right
in an unthinkable situation
this bill is not about abortion
it is about families like mine
who are in heartbreaking complex
situations when we talk about fatal
fetal and that anomalies
you can't classify these things
Connor had a set of problems any one of
them individually might have been
treatable
together they weren't
and so you can't legislate that that I
can understand
families who planned on bringing home
their baby and in the blink of an eye
face the worst possible situation
that's what we lived with
any woman or couple going through these
situations deserve support and empathy
the choices made that were made were our
choices cannot should not be made or
judged by a government who thinks they
know what's right
when you deliberate this bill I hope you
remember my story and Connor's story
and do what's right for people like
myself and New Hampshire families
if this Bill had been passed before
Conor had been born
we would have had to go through these
surgeries and have him die on an
operating table
and he would not have been held by his
parents
that's cruel
thank you questions for this Witness
representative
thank you for the taking my question I'm
so very sorry for the difficult
experiences you and your wife and your
family have had it's hard to listen to
these things
are you've related it so very well
um it is emotional it impacts us
what I did notice in your written
submission
the words the doctors transitioned to
Comfort Care
fortunately the medical profession has
done extremely well in providing
palliative care
in these situations as well as for older
and elderly people facing their final
hours
it sounds as though they did everything
they could within a reasonable
way
but then
let the inevitable of nature take over
and enabled you to have moments
with your with your child
the medical
people who aided you and performed
were not near any type of a crime or a
wrongdoing they were doing the best they
could for you
and again I have to draw you to that
line line of page two
the provider
did not intentionally cause or hasten
the abnormality brought life to its end
unfortunately
but the doctors didn't hasten that
they didn't intentionally terminate nor
did you give any order to do so
this bill is a fart
a far removal from the sad circumstances
that you endured
and I'm sorry for your loss in that case
thank you for your testimony uh so not
providing surgeries to him hastened his
death he died after three days
and he might have lived through the
first surgery to close the spinal column
you probably wouldn't have lived through
the second
odds kept going down so he would have
died on the table but he would have
lived longer than three days so by not
performing surgery they did hasten his
death
but they didn't intentionally hasten
or terminate
the choice
was yours to make
but there's a difference and that's what
the law is focused on the difference I
can't speak not the emotional trauma and
the unfortunate circumstances that this
occurred
other questions for this week
seeing none thank you very much sir
thank you uh representative Matt Simon
and after that uh representative uh
Catherine from Bruno O'Brien
thank you so much Mr chair honorable
members of the committee for the record
my name is representative Matt Simon I
represent Grafton district one Littleton
Lisbon Lyman Sugar Hill bath and Monroe
I'm here today in support of the bill as
a co-sponsor of the bill
um I do have to get to a committee so I
appreciate you moving me up in in the
timetable here
um after listening to some of the
testimony I just wanted to point out a
few points on this particular bill for
the committee's consideration the
substance of the bill indicates that
children who are infants who have
survived to the point of birth are to be
treated no differently than anybody else
at any other age
um a few years back my my mother was
diagnosed with cancer it was speeding
um within a few course of a few weeks it
had taken over her intestines and we
lost her very rapidly
um
during the course of that the doctors
met with us and they said here's what we
can do what do you want to do and we had
conversations about that and eventually
the doctor came back and said listen
there's just nothing else we can do
we've done everything that we've tried
to do and and there's nothing more that
we can do other than keep her
you know keep her comfortable
and um so
that was the decision that we decided to
make
um even though they were not going to
continue to try medical procedures to
save her life that was in no way
indicated that the doctors were somehow
hastening her death in that circumstance
my point being that the bill is meant to
mirror in this age what happens in the
medical profession at every age and at
every age there is leeway within for the
medical profession to make these
difficult decisions it is not a
one-size-fits-all even there sometimes
they have to make the difficult decision
to not pursue further medical care so I
just want the committee to take that
into consideration
um and to point out what representative
Stapleton has been pointing out uh
regularly
um at what other point in our lives
would a medical professional be allowed
to intentionally withhold Medical Care
or intentionally hasten the death of any
of us
when does that when does that exist at
any other point in development and to to
just address the one of the concerns
that was spoken before
um well first off let me just say um
we've had some doctors and I'm hoping
that doctors if this is the case can
testify to this later for you but uh
indicating that no medical professional
would ever do anything like this and I
would just submit to the committee that
no medical professional is qualified to
speak to what every other Medical
Professional would or would not do
um that's not something that's within
their purview to to make as a claim so I
would encourage the committee to keep
that
um take that into consideration as well
um but having said that uh once again
I'm happy to take any questions that
anybody might have on the uh
representative
there's a few things that I've heard sad
but don't match what's in the bill and
I'm wondering if you're willing to work
together to amend the bill for example
it was just asked well by the
representative over here this this
doesn't
um
you gave permission for that this wasn't
the Doctor's choice but that the bill
does actually explicitly say that a
directive or other instruction to
withhold treatment from a borderline
alive infant shall not be a defense yes
so
that's what I'm hearing is part of the
big concern here is that should an
infant be born alive but has a fetal
fetal anomaly or had a traumatic birth
and has another anomaly that is there
for
incompatible with any sort of quality of
life
would you be willing to provide
exceptions for that
um so 2.5 million thank you for the
question representative um I would
answer on the whole if it is a problem
yes I believe that the co-sponsors and
sponsor are willing to have a
conversation of what that would look
like
um to address that particular process
problem I would also just urge the
committee members to study and determine
whether or not those circumstances would
be treated any differently at any other
stage in life I recognize that a very
particular point in our lifespan is
being addressed in this bill but there
are also other times within our lives
when we could run into a very similar
situation and what does the medical
Fields do in that particular situation
do they have any leeway to make you know
medical decisions my argument would be
yes they do have the ability to do that
so they would still have the ability to
do that here
um as at least as long as I'm reading
this bill correctly that is the intent
but however if you decide that it isn't
going to actually work that way we're
willing certainly willing to have a
conversation it is not our intent
to
take a child from a parent's arms right
after birth and not give them that time
because they have to be rushed off to do
a treatment that isn't isn't going to do
them any material good
um that's not the intent
other questions for this week
yes representative Devine
thank you for taking my question
um I've heard a lot of talk about you
know Physicians Do no harm they take an
oath for that there's a presumption
going on that is suggesting that doctors
are automatically
um in in a case of abortion just a child
that survives
an abortion that they're lying on a
table and that a physician is then now
somehow terminating the death from that
point
um are there statistics in New Hampshire
I heard
um other testimony that there were
statistics in other states but in New
Hampshire is that happening on a regular
basis or is that just something that's
hypothetical
um we keep notes no statistics on
abortion in the state of New Hampshire
whatsoever
um I believe that once again we wouldn't
be coming with this particular Bill if
there was not concern
um that and particularly in abortion
situations
um this kind of situation might arrive
it does arise and does happen we
wouldn't be worried about it if we
didn't have testimony from people that
said that they've observed this witness
that's gone through this
um and so that's the purpose for
bringing the bill but as far as
statistics are concerned we don't we
don't keep any statistics
did that answer your question yes it did
thank you other questions for this
Witness
seeing none thank you very much and if I
may um Mr chair just briefly um I'm
making myself in trouble for this one
but if it's not an abortion bill
the everybody I've gone to a lot of
these everybody who cares about abortion
on both sides is in the room so um just
a another point but thank you
representative uh Catherine fruitholm
O'Brien which and the next witness will
be Elizabeth uh Eaton
thank you very much I hope everyone can
hear me these microphones are tricky
I'm going to say the quiet part out loud
I'm just going to address the elephant
in the room and that's why I came here
today
an infant born alive who grows up and
becomes an adult
after they have survived abortion is
very inconvenient to the abortion
narrative about what abortion really is
I'm thinking of someone like Paula
LePage
from Milton New Hampshire she survived
abortion she has a scar across her face
and she has a limp and if as an adult
you ask her why do you have that large
scar why do you have that limp and she
was to tell you I survived abortion my
mother had an abortion procedure and it
didn't work that was in the late 50s
that she had that in Maine
and she was born and she was very much
wanted it was poverty that caused her
mother to seek seek the abortion she
thought she had no choice after Apollo
was born she was very happy about that
she was very happy
yeah
since then abortion procedures have
become far more lethal and effective so
we don't have to deal with the
inconvenience of people walking around
with missing limbs after surviving
abortion
if we did we would see abortion for what
it really is
I was diagnosed with a very rare genetic
issue when I was pregnant with my last
child it affects people of French
Canadian descent it's similar to Tay
Sachs
there's no chance that the child will
survive after about three years of age
with that disease if my if the situation
was that my husband also had it and the
child was born with it well
that didn't happen thankfully but
if it had there's no chance the child
would survive that's a that's a
situation incompatible with life but
after the child is born if that child
was diagnosed with it at that point
would they say to me
your child your infant here that you're
holding has this disease and will not
live past the age of three there's
absolutely no chance it's never happened
before in the history of the world
would you like to kill that child have a
post-bought a birth abortion or
something like that
do you think that would be Humane what
kind of society would that be is that
the one we want to live in
you know you everyone knows what I'm
saying is true
everyone knows that it would be very
inconvenient for this narrative to have
people walking around missing arms and
legs because they survived abortion or
with skin burns if they still use that
kind of procedure
are there any questions that's all I
really had to say questions for this
Witness
saying none thank you thank you
Elizabeth's eaten
um and after Miss Eaton will be uh
Danielle
Albus tries I think and I apologize if
I'm pronouncing that incorrect
missy good morning uh thank you chairman
Lynn and honorable committee members my
name is Elizabeth Eaton I work at the
office of professional licensure and
certification as an attorney uh board
Council for the various boards uh and
councils I'm here representing the
Midwifery Council which is made up of
New Hampshire certified midwives one OB
GYN and one pediatrician
they prepared some testimony based on
lengthy discussion when they considered
this bill and I'm here to read the
testimony I can take some questions
based on the discussion that I witnessed
that New Hampshire Midwifery Council
opposes this bill
there are circumstances in which a
pre-viable fetus or paraviable fetus is
born with a heartbeat but for whom
resuscitation efforts would be futile
the proposed legislation criminalizes
the clinical judgment and care of
licensed health care providers who
appropriately pivot from feudal heroic
resuscitation efforts to providing
condolence and palliative care to
traumatized parents and tiny babies
the council is concerned with who
decides the intention of the health care
provider in that circumstance
that closes their testimony right
questions for this week
yes representative Smith thank you for
your testimony do you have written
copies of that for the uh committee I do
not have it right now but I could
provide some thank you very much other
questions to this week
foreign
thank you very much thank you
Danielle
um
Albus tries I hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly and the next witness will
after that will be all uh Omar Ahern
please
thank you honorable members of the
committee
I have the words I'd like to say that
I'll read
um but then just sitting here listening
to all the discussion if I can just
indulge me with a comment or two after
my written words thank you
my name is Dr Daniela bushes I'm here to
oppose HB 346 I'm an OB GYN and have the
privilege to help women and their
families navigate low and high risk
pregnancies
like all dedicated Health Care Providers
I take seriously my oath to take all
medically appropriate and reasonable
actions to preserve the life and health
of a newborn
to be clear infants born are already
protected under New Hampshire's criminal
statutes any infant born no matter the
circumstance currently receives what is
within the standard of care for the
situation
I'm here to describe how detrimental HB
346 is to families who are already
struggling with coming to terms that
their baby will not survive on its own
most of my work involves normal
pregnancies and joyous births
unfortunately as we have heard there are
pregnancies that are identified through
the course of prenatal care to be
incompatible with life outside the
uterus and when I say incompatible with
life outside the uterus I mean a fatal
fetal anomaly like when the fetus has
not developed a brain or if very early
labor occurs
when a fatal fetal diagnosis is made we
offer information compassion and choice
many women and their families choose to
continue the pregnancy knowing that the
fetus may die inside the uterus some
will choose induction of Labor or wait
for spontaneous labor these babies will
die after birth
the goal for these women and families is
to have the opportunity to meet their
baby hold their baby and continue the
grieving process
for these babies as well as other babies
born too early with no chance of
survival there are long discussions with
the hospice team to formulate a plan for
comfort care after the birth
women and families want whatever time
they have with their baby to be peaceful
this is what these grieving families
deserve the choice that these families
make as we've heard is devastating but
their personal with their personal
decisions and it's the job of the team
of trusted Healthcare professionals to
explain all the facts we cannot make
this decision for them
what is so problematic about this bill
is that it removes this difficult
decision-making out of the hands of the
family and it will force neonatologists
or pediatricians to take these babies
who have no chance of survival and
subject them to invasive procedures
invasive procedures like breathing tubes
IV access through the umbilical cord and
required separation from the family
based on HB 346 if a provider does not
force these procedures on a baby that
has no chance of survival they're at
risk of being charged with a class a
felony
please allow New Hampshire families to
make these end-of-life neonatal
decisions in consultation with their
Medical Teams based on evidence-based
medicine without the intrusion of the
New Hampshire government to dictate how
they spend their final moments together
please trust women and families and
their doctors to make these incredibly
difficult decisions together and vote
inexpedient to legislate on HB 346 just
two points I'd specifically like to make
I think as the physician having the lens
to read this bill one is that I've heard
a lot about the intent of the bill
there's intent and there's reality as I
sit and look at this bill it is vague
and it is problematic and it will harm
the families that you heard have heard
from today about these Comfort Care
decisions
we've referenced as far as under the
criminal penalties as I read directly
from the bill any health care provider
who withholds medical treatment from a
born alive infant with the intention of
causing or hastening the infant's death
as I read this as a physician
not
giving these invasive procedures is
hastening the death so it's just vague
and it's not straightforward as far as a
physician or again any health care
provider which encompasses a lot of
providers not doing these invasive
procedures
is hastening the death we will feel like
we have to take that baby from these
families who want this time or there's a
class a felony these are really grave
consequences to providers who are all
really just trying to do the best thing
for our patients and family so I just
wanted to make sure that as a physician
lens reading this that I try to make
that clear that by not doing those
things we do feel like we would be
hastening the death thank you for your
time questions for this witness uh yes
representative Perez
thank you for your testimony as a
healthcare professional
how do we protect how do you see we
protect
the 22 week the 23 week
child
that has been aborted alive how do we
protect
them the healthy
22 23 18 weeks we they survive at 18
weeks now
of a failed abortion how do we protect
them
and you could say that no doctor would
not try to
but it's the same as saying an intent
and a reality but what I'd like to
Circle back to is this bill and this
bill the way it's written
will not be straightforward to implement
and so again we are here to really talk
about or I would like to just keep
focusing back on this bill as far as the
vagueness of the language and the harm
that it could bring to New Hampshire
families thank you
other questions for this witness yes
representative
do you think that if the bill were to be
amended to say
um to give an exception for in the case
of in the reasonable medical Judgment of
a physician that
the baby was born with a fatal fetal
anomaly or an anomaly
significantly impacting the quality of
life
um that this would
allow mothers the opportunity to
hold their babies as in the in the cases
that we're talking about that are having
to make painful decisions but would
still protect
a baby that was born alive and was
healthy as a result of a failed abortion
I think there's no language that we
could come up with from both sides of
the aisle that could touch upon these
very complicated personal decisions and
ultimately I go back to the fact that
any infant born currently receives what
is within the standard of care for that
situation to let Physicians providers of
obstetric newborn care any care just
have
that trusted relationship
um so I don't think there's any language
that would be able to cover all the
nuances of all these complex situations
other questions for this witness so I
guess well I'm sorry representative char
thanks Mr chairman and and thanks for
your testimony
um are you aware of any provisions I I
know I'm not going to ask you about the
legal aspects but from a medical
standpoint from your Hippocratic Oath
standards of care Etc that provide a
different course of action for an abort
an aborted fetus versus an any other
fetus that you or not fetus but but an
infant
um uh
that would that would cause you to act
differently
um as a as a clinician in terms of the
course of care that that you would
render
again that's a very complex decision and
so much depends on what the clinical
care is that's happening what
information we know about that Mom that
fetus that gestational age these are
just questions that are really uh almost
impossible uh to answer but ultimately
we'll go back to as Physicians and
health care providers we're going to do
everything we can to save a newborn that
is We Believe can survive
representative
what if it was amended to say within the
standard of care because that is the
standard that you guys use
again I think this
this bill or I don't I just don't think
there's any addendum to the bill that
would be able to cover all the things
that ultimately uh are hard to
protect
our families and and newborns
so I I other I'm sorry other questions
so I guess I wonder if I could ask this
question and you talked about the
standard of care a number of times and
so I what I'm kind of wondering is this
suppose you have the situation
of uh of a woman who comes in and to
have an abortion at let's say 18 or 20
weeks or whatever the woman wants the
abortion and I want to make it clear I'm
not trying to cast any let's assume the
woman has a very good read there's some
some reason for having the abortion that
we would all say is a good reason
so if she comes in It's let's say the
baby's 20 weeks wants to have the
abortion
that the medical people attempt to
perform the abortion and for whatever
reason the abortion fails and now the
child has been delivered and Will
Survive but the woman still says you
know I I wanted to have this abortion
and I still want the abortion
but the doctor knows that the child can
survive
what what is the doctor's obligation
under the standard of care these are
very hypothetical situations so having
not been in those situations I just
can't speak to those there is no
standard of care for that one situation
so these are hypothetical situations
that I don't uh
think I can answer
and the only other question I have is
you as you read the language of the bill
you read part of it you said the part
about the Doctor Who
uh with holes medical treatment from a
born alive infant with the intention of
causing causing or hastening to death
but you didn't read the last part which
says and who materially
causes or Hastings to death and
presumably the word material has to have
some meaning so that would presumably
mean it has to be something more than
just a few minutes or a day or something
like that what do you say I don't know
what that word means material as a
physician again with the lens reading
this bill how I read that whole sentence
is that if I don't Pro if or myself I'm
not a new auditologist or pediatrician
but the providers there who are
responsible for the care of that newborn
if that invasive care whatever you
define as the invasive care isn't
provided then that provider is hastening
or causing the death of the newborn
other questions for this Witness
sorry representative page
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question I am still struggling with
translating our legal words to the
medical profession struggled with it
yesterday and I'm struggling with it
today
but I am wondering and
sometimes I don't trust lawyers
the words that the way they can use
situations for their training right in
their context of their training and I'm
wondering I should say I don't trust
them but I can see that their training
may lead
to a situation that is kind of counter
to your training so I'm wondering if
somewhere in now that you know if this
was to become if somewhere in your
knowledge of these words
about what they mean to you as a
practicing physician whether you're
materially causing an Omission that
material causes materially causes or
Hastings to death
does that
interfere with the standard of care in
some way in the back of your mind
perhaps what it interfere as you're sort
of thinking about this and trying to
deliver medical treatment under a
standard of care does it almost
undermine it in a way yes if this bill
were to pass then
there would be very
impossible for us to not
feel that we had to ultimately yes it
would undermine our care and that
trusted relationship and and for what we
would want to do for our families
other questions for this wish thank you
very much
um next is uh Omer earn and after that
will be Brian Lewis
thank you
thank you and thank you Mr chairman I
don't do well with technology
uh
good morning
members of the committee
my name is Omer Ahern Jr
of Wentworth Grafton County New
Hampshire
I am a father of four
and I was present at each one of the
births of my four children
I am a grandfather of eight
I am a Roman Catholic
I am also
an attorney of 44 plus years with a
major part of my practice over those
years being a family law attorney
I urge you
members of the committee
to support
house bill
346 Dash FN
as a reasonable
common
sense legislation
required
in this day and age
I'm here this morning to urge you
to save the lives
of individual and innocent living human
beings
that among other things
this legislation intends to do
intends to accomplish
because there are people
even evidently medical personnel
who believe that some children born
alive are not necessarily entitled to be
cared for
we have
to try
always to save and protect lives
please
do the right thing
the reasonable and Common Sense thing in
this day and age
and please support
House Bill three four six dash FN
to protect the lives of
these special living children
as all other living children
are to be cared for
life
matters
life is sacred
thank you very much questions for this
week
seeing none thank you very much sir
thank you
next is Brian Lewis and after that will
be the Reverend s
T island or S.H Holland and you know
what ladies and gentlemen I'm gonna I
see we have I see the time and I see we
have a lot of other Witnesses In
fairness to everyone I'm going to ask
everyone to please limit your time to
three minutes if you would please sir
thank you thank you I'm Brian Lewis from
Alexandria I'm reading written testimony
by Melissa Oden also from Grafton 18.
in support of house bill 346.
she writes
on behalf of the abortion survivors
Network
abbreviated ASM the more than 640
abortion survivors who have connected
with us and tens of thousands of
abortion survivors we know exist we
applaud representative Glenn cordelli
representative Katie herdonell and their
colleagues and proudly support House
Bill 346 the New Hampshire born alive
infant protection act
this well-formed legislation has earned
our full support as it contains the
vital elements of a strong born alive
bill
under this legislation Warren alive
infants would be guaranteed the same
health care and medical protection as
any other infant this requirement would
be enforced for the inclusion of legal
penalties specified in the bill
additionally a clear and accurate
definition of born live infant is
provided ultimately his legislation
aligns with a common sense of granite
Staters and Americans across the country
we know the meaning of a born alive
infant it means the potential for a long
and wonderful life but only if these
infants are protected
as the only organization in the world
supporting abortion survivors and their
families we have come into contact with
hundreds of individuals born during or
following a failed abortion
while records of abortion survivors in
the United States are either missing or
woefully incomplete ASN has been able to
estimate by extrapolating from Canadian
rates the actual number and frequency of
abortion survivors and born alive
abortions in the United States
our Research indicates that 0.21 of
abortions result in a live birth this
means that for every one thousand
abortions approximately two infants
survive
based on the large number of abortions
performed Nationwide
an average of
1734 failed abortions result in a live
birth every year
this occurrence is not as rare as many
try to claim each Survivor is a
testimony not only of the occurrence of
failed abortions but of the value of
every born alive infant
the New Hampshire born alive infant
protection act will save countless lives
lives like mine in 1977 my birth mother
had a Salient infusion abortion forced
upon her by my grandmother
this procedure involved injecting a
toxic salt solution into the amniotic
fluid meant to protect my body to scald
and poison me to death despite all
expectations I was born alive
even after being miraculously born alive
I was left to die outside the womb
however I was rescued by a nurse who
disobeyed orders to lamia side and
rushed me to the NICU my medical records
note that an abortion was performed and
but failed
at ASN stories like mine
are not so rare
many abortion survivors have been left
uncared for even after their initial
survival
whether an infant receives life-saving
care should not depend on who is working
that day
ASN is committed to serving and
protecting the survivors of abortion at
any age let us work together to ensure
that infants are protected in a common
sense way
as the first and most fundamental right
life should never be denied no matter
how young an individual is or how unique
the circumstances of their birth
survivors deserve the same care and
treatment as everyone else
we are proud to support this legislation
with representative Glenn cordelli and
representative Kate pedernal and their
colleagues
thank you questions for this Witness
I'm not in a position to field question
sir this is not my testimony this is
written by all right Witnesses and also
it is not desire to take questions all
right thank you very much
um
do you have you have written copies of
the testimony that you want to hand in
take this
so you can why don't you leave yeah why
don't you just come up and leave that
with us and we'll make we'll take care
of the copies
all right
um
next I'm going to call on uh Ian Hewitt
please
oh well I'm sorry I'm sorry no I'm I'm
sorry no I'm sorry I got ahead of myself
um you are Reverend Holland is that
correct I'm sorry yes please go ahead
and E and you will be next I'm sorry
good morning
um honorable members of the House
Judiciary Committee my name is Reverend
Sam Holland I live in Center Harbor in
the middle of the state I serve as the
pastor and teacher of Plymouth
Congregational United Church of Christ
and also chair the justice and witness
Ministry of the United Church of Christ
in the state
as a formative part of my training for
becoming a pastor I volunteered at a
trauma level one hospital as a Chaplain
I ask you to vote in opposition of house
bill 346.
as a citizen I'm troubled that there is
a bill before you that could criminalize
doctors as we are a country and state in
need of doctors
in Ministry often in hospital settings
I've accompanied people in moments of
deep celebration as well as moments of
deep grief
hard and painful moments
I've seen many people in their last
moments
and those moments do not just belong to
the individuals they belong to the
families
of course I always try my best to care
for people who are experiencing
emotional spiritual and mental pain
sometimes I can only sit and be with
people who are struggling
Guardians never
want to cause their children pain
unfortunately sometimes parents need to
make decisions alongside care providers
parents need to be able to count on care
providers to give them the best medical
advice
House Bill 346 is not necessary and
could have devastating consequences on
families who are grieving the loss of a
newborn
due to an early labor labor because of a
fatal fetal diagnosis
these are situations that are impossible
to change the outcome of
Health Care Providers face steep
consequences if they are withholding
care even if they are providing
passionate Compassionate Care
hospice care
in this situation the parent should be
able to decide how the infant's moments
will be spent
care providers should be able able to
offer compassion to the family that's
what they signed up for
this bill could take away the parents
right to decide how they would spend the
last moments with their newborn
religiously
Faithfully spiritually
this would mean taking away important
Sacrament and ritual
it would not be right to deny families
the opportunity to baptize their child
a child who would be actively dying
it would be an infringement on their
religious beliefs
this bill will deny Comfort to those who
will already be traumatized
I hope that you will reject this
dangerous and unsympathetic Bill and
vote and expedition to legislate on
House Bill 346. thank you thank you
questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you next is uh Ian
Hewitt please
thank you
and after that the next witness will be
Chris Rouse
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee can you hear me okay
thank you Ian Hewitt general counsel at
Cornerstone we are not taking a position
on this bill this year but I wanted to
make myself available to answer any
legal questions about it the text of
Representative cordelli's Bill
originated as a floor excuse me a
committee Amendment brought by Senator
Regina bird cell in the Senate Judiciary
Committee in the last session to the
last sessions for an alive the text of
that amendment was developed in
consultation with law professors who are
subject matter experts in this area and
volunteered their time to redraft the
previous foreign alive Bill and it was
redrafted specifically to avoid the main
criticism that was heard against this
bill in the house in the last session
which concerns stories like the story of
baby Sawyer who you heard today where
people were concerned that the bill at
that time would require feudal treatment
be administered to a baby about to die
if the baby be pulled from its mother's
arms to receive this feudal in its
current form this bill only prohibits
actually causing or hastening the death
of the infant and intentionally and
materially causing or Hasting the
infant's death I've done criminal trial
practice on both sides prosecution and
defense and then a trial court clerk as
well and I expect this fact is already
familiar to most of you but not only in
a criminal prosecution does the
government need to prove the overall
case Beyond A Reasonable Doubt the
government must prove each element of
the offense Beyond A Reasonable Doubt so
in any prosecution under this bill the
defense attorney would remind the jury
remember the state's burden is to prove
that Dr Johnson materially caused or
hastened the infant's death that Dr
Johnson did so intentionally and if you
have any doubt Reasonable Doubt is to
either element of that offense you must
acquit Dr Johnson the judge would then
issue instructions to the jury saying if
you have Reasonable Doubt as to any
element of this offense caused or haste
it intentionally material you must
acquit the accused doctor so I'll just
conclude by saying you know following
the discussions on this bill I have been
I'm not surprised to hear people say
that this bill is unnecessary or is
insulting to doctors I think some
lawyers probably feel that way about
some of the regulations that regulate
lawyers specifically but I have been
probably somewhat surprised at the
number of people saying that it might be
part of a appropriate Medical Practice
to ever do anything that this bill
prescribes I think that should probably
send up red flags for this committee and
I hope the committee will continue to
take important testimony about that line
of argument thank you and I'd be happy
to answer any legal questions about the
bill questions for this Witness
yes representative Stapleton
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
if we were to enumerate multiple
exceptions or situations
um like we have talked about and heard
here
aren't we actually conflicting
the law with regard to Criminal Intent I
mean it
it doesn't send anybody it's apples and
oranges is that basically could you
repeat your question representative if
if we were to enumerate by Amendment
the various situations exceptions
that some of which were discussed here
are we not
uh a far a basically a Chasm between
those situations which are personal and
life intent from the Criminal Intent
I believe you're asking about
enumerating some specific situations
potentially in the bill I would say that
that would depend on exactly what was
enumerated if for example the bill said
something like
it will be a complete defense under this
subsection If the child had a condition
incompatible with life that would really
not change the intent of the bill at all
and potentially could give some comfort
to someone who might vote for the bill
although I really don't think it have
any effect if you had an exception that
said something like this protection will
not apply in the case of a child who has
a life-altering disability in that case
we might have to get involved in
opposition to the bill then you could
potentially have for the first time a
state statute saying that a criminal
homicide is authorized if a child has a
particularly life-altering condition so
it would depend on exactly what was
enumerated
other questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much Chris
Rouse and then the next uh
witness will be Maris Tower
oh it's all here so I apologize you can
pick that up if you watch that it makes
it easier on the back
Price is Right uh yeah my name is uh Dr
Chris Ross I'm a unitologist I live in
Auburn New Hampshire and I work in New
Hampshire as well I just want to provide
my thoughts on this and hopefully answer
some of your own questions uh as best I
can so uh first of all I just I just
want to be
you know I do resuscitations for babies
that's my job I do it every day I've
done it for many years I
I'm passionate about that and I hope I
do a good job with that
I just want to want to talk about like
what goes into a resuscitation first of
all you know at standard of care for uh
for providers to follow a neonatal
resuscitation program guidelines which
is proved by American Pediatrics which
uh basically goes through a whole set of
evidence-based interventions you do
based on how the the baby is in front of
you so you know it requires uh possibly
giving positive pressure ventilation
intubating the baby giving chest
compressions if they need it placing
emergent IVs umbilical lines giving
emergent medications like epinephrine
which is like adrenaline uh and then
ultimately you know if they need
transport to a higher level of care
providing that so you know all of those
interventions as everybody is like so
well described I think on both sides
like there are there's they're not
benign you know uh they they're risks
associated with those giving positive
pressure
um giving innovate you know innovating a
baby uh
thorax I mean I've seen esophagus
esophagus I guess those get punctured by
ET tubes chest compressions just like
with adults they can break babies ribs
uh and then in terms of like depending
on the gestational age of the baby you
know their the skin is so so tender uh
and fragile it tears really easily so
just all the tape that goes into that
and securing the tube securing IV sites
uh can be can be traumatic too so all
you know all of that is absolutely
necessary
um when you resuscitate a baby uh who
like obviously has a future and uh and
um
you know and and uh and a good good
chance of survival uh of a low risk of
mortality and morbidity
um and I think like everybody has said
like of course we don't want to do that
for babies that uh or you know have a
have an anomaly or a defect that's
uh not consistent with life so I just
want to put that out there I think
everybody's like similar on the same
page of that I do have like a few
concerns just based on the on the way
the bill is written
and I just wanted to make a couple other
comments too you know as a neonatologist
like I I honestly just reading this I am
most concerned about the part about
withholding treatment with the intention
of causing or Hasting an infant's death
uh you know again I'm a neonatal ICU
doctor
um we can do a lot to keep babies alive
um you know the the the example that
people brought up was you know the baby
without a brain the anus and
anencephalic baby
um you can keep that baby alive and keep
that baby alive for for a month I mean
keep keep baby alive longer for that uh
if they're on a ventilator
um
you know if they say in the hospital
potentially uh if they have all their
food all their feeds given through a
G-tube or a feeding tube
so uh you know if you withdraw care uh
you know I would also argue that the
intention is to to shorten that baby's
life and I mean we can argue it uh
lawyers can certainly argue it
um we can argue within the medical
profession between providers and Health
Care Systems uh but I just I would ask
you
just to put yourself in our shoes
if we're going to risk a lawsuit against
ourselves
and
to a point where you know when I apply
for credentials at a hospital through a
State Medical Board I have to put down
every time I've been sued
um the details of that suit if it was
successful or not
and that impacts like my ability to be
employed so you know what myself would
my Hospital would they ever risk that
um
you know how do you how do you define
intention I mean that was a great point
that was previously brought up I mean I
know how I Define it I know how you
probably you may Define it other people
may Define it how's the law you're going
to Define it how are they going to argue
in front of Court am I going to win that
argument am I going to roll the dice on
that
um
you know I I have kids I have a family
like I said I live in Auburn New
Hampshire I mean this I mean that
affects that so uh
yeah you know again
we appreciate your test you're kind of
gone over the three yeah
I don't want to cut you off it's not bad
I just asked you to sum up if you would
please that's all thank you any
questions
questions for the switch yes
representative Perez
if you have a baby that
is surviving
in neonatal
and the parent says to you I don't want
to do this anymore
does that not put you in the same
predicament of
withdrawing care
is an intentional way of
hastening the death of a child I mean I
worked intensive care not neonatal care
but I know if the family
wanted someone taken off a respirator
because they could no longer survive the
family's wishes
were
listened to
not being in neonatal
where where are you is that not
hastening a death as well
I I agree with you I think like it would
hasten the infant's death by taking I'm
sorry it would hasten the offense death
by taking them off off a respirator off
a ventilator
but you don't do it
if you think the child has a possibility
of surviving or correct
uh I think that's hard too because uh it
really depends on what the baby's
gestational age is and I know premature
gets brought up a lot here
um
but it depends on you know what the
babies you know when we look at a baby
that is premature for example and say at
the edge of viability a lot of things go
into that like we're trying to like just
kneel down a gestational age uh it also
has to go in with like what their
estimated birth weight is uh what their
blood flow is like in their biblical
artery in their brain how well they're
growing over the past several weeks all
those things go into that so if if you
have a baby that comes out that has a
you know let's just go on National
guidelines like a 22 week or 10 chance
of living
um at in most places it depends on where
you deliver
and you say okay you know to the parents
they have a 10 chance of living
your chance of cerebral palsy is 75
percent
you know
you are still giving that that family
the decision to how how much of a
resuscitation they want that's that's
standard of care no matter where you go
so
um
I guess that would be my argument with
you I would say that we're not with you
but the argument would be uh even babies
born with a heart heart rate that may
have a very small chance of living uh
there is absolutely debate and uh
perennial preference involved in that
other questions for this week
yes thank you for that
I think one of the things that we're
missing in this bill and I keep bringing
it up is trying to protect the
um child that is born as a
missed
abortion and
um
and I know that that is very very rare
but it's my understanding and I would
think you'd agree that if you had a
child arrive who ended up in the NICU at
23 23 and a half weeks and only ended up
in the NICU because of perhaps some
complication of the um
missed abortion
it would not be up to it would be up to
the doctors to determine the survival of
that child
yeah I think for myself it it wouldn't
matter the abortion aspect of it like
once the baby's born the baby's like
basically is is treated the same as any
other baby uh I would say I would just
caution on the reason 23 week 22-week
babies go to the NICU those babies are
gonna be in the NICU for three three
months and they're going to be on a
ventilator for a period of time they're
going to need blood pressure medications
um there's a lot of interventions that
go into that for example their lungs
don't even have the alveoli the air sacs
at the end developed at that point so
you're trying to ventilate through hard
tubes bronchioles because they don't
even have the air sacs developed that
takes a lot of uh you know a lot of
pressure and a lot of invasive
respiratory management so I just I just
caution like you know 22 23 week baby is
not uh there's not really a healthy one
thank you other questions to this
Witness
representative Stapleton
thank you for taking my question
the discussion brings one question to
mine would a an amendment be useful
that provides
exception for
not being obligated to to extraordinary
means to preserve the lice
of a child that has a terminal
um
diagnosis of prognosis
I mean I I see what you're saying like I
personally just my own perspective I
don't I don't think it's necessary
because that is what we what we do right
now
this isn't like something I've been like
you know waiting for and hoping for will
somebody make this change so that we can
like do our jobs better like for me it's
I'm doing the same job you know or I'm
not doing the same job but if the bill
bill comes into gets passed they will be
doing it differently but right now I
think in the medical profession you know
everybody's like
not happy but uh
there's a there's a system for for
working within that that's good for
providers and families thank you
yes
I asked that in the context of some
moral beliefs that
were not obligated to
use extraordinary means
to protect the life that's going to be
terminal or is terminal
and that is not opposed to what doctors
do you try to do the best you can
but there are some circumstances that
you cannot overcome
and there's going to be a termination of
life
so the moral code would say that we let
the natural death occur
and the choices not to use extraordinary
means beyond the capability of keeping
that life going
other I'm sorry go ahead do you have
something so we want to say doctor
please
yeah I I definitely hear what you're
saying
um and I I think like make cerebral
cerebrally I like understand that and
agree with that it's uh it's just how
things get written out and then
translated and then acted on that um
there's just a lot a lot of gray area
for that for those professionals other
questions for this Witness
representative page sorry thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my question
I just want to clarify that I heard you
correctly and if I didn't correct me
um my understanding is what you
indicated is that currently
you practice the medical standard of
care
that if this bill were to become a law
that might interfere or at least cause
in your mind
some additional questioning
about what the law says or what you
think the law might say or what a lawyer
might say versus what
you as the medical professional might
deliver to that care and therefore
perhaps undermine
the good work that you're doing right
now is that fair that's correct
other questions to this Witness
seeing none thank you very much next is
Maris Holland and the witness after that
will be Emily zazano
hello committee members my name is Mayor
stolen I'm a resident physician in OB
GYN I live in Lebanon
um
when representative cordelli introduced
this bill he said this is a simple
concept I think everyone's testimony
today can attest to the fact that this
is not simple this is exceedingly
complex and there are many iterations of
different situations hypothetical
situations complex medical diagnoses
rare medical diagnoses and situations
that perhaps no one in this room has
even thought about that could apply and
be affected by the language in this bill
the way the bill is written doesn't have
to do with how Medical Care actually
works it's based on myths or
misunderstandings of what happens in the
medical field
I don't think this bill is necessary I
think that doctors already have the
obligation to provide appropriate
Medical Care
it
um
it makes my heartbreak to hear someone
bring up someone like hermit Gosnell who
is a indicted murderer and compare the
medical providers in this room to that
person
I would never bring up someone who had
murdered a physician who was an
anti-abortion extremist and compare that
to the other people who are speaking in
this room
representative Simon is right that I
can't speak to every Medical
Professional and I can't speak to things
that have happened in the past or myths
or or even real stories that people have
come forward for abortion
um
uh anti-abortion um speakers but I can
tell you what I see currently as a
position
practicing in New Hampshire these
hypothetical situations that you speak
of I have never seen
I have seen many of the situations that
are being testified against here stories
like Sawyer
um stories like this gentleman here
who's um whose child had spina bifida I
see those stories
frequently and the language in this bill
would undermine medical professionals
ability to do their job safely we
already live in a litigious Society
where we worry about the legal
implications
um for what we do as an OB GYN we have
the highest malpractice suits in any any
profession
the way that this is written is vague we
have talked all day all morning about
the intent of this bill I'm still not
really sure what the intent is I've
heard the the supporters of this bill
try to clarify multiple times what the
intent is because it sounds like the
intent is not to
um speak against
um you know small premature infants who
were born with fetal anomalies but how
do I know how do I Define their intent
and yet you're suggesting that
Physicians be charged with a class a
felony based on on Whose ability to
determine what are its intent is who is
better prepared to
to classify a situation and the medical
appropriateness of that situation than
someone who went to medical school and
someone who has trained postgraduate to
treat these situations
this bill has inflammatory language
based in misinformation from a medical
perspective the bill is unnecessary and
ludicrous it's not how Medical Care
works and most importantly it's
unintended consequences and vagueness
will cause suffering to families that
have spoken today politicians should not
be making laws that are dictating
Medical Treatments
we should be performing the usual
standard medical medical standard of
care I strongly encourage you to oppose
this legislation questions for this week
representative Morgan
oh did I go first
um and I I had to skip out to for
another hearing for an hour but um
something is not to find your bills and
is an infant so is there any
criteria to say who's an infinite who's
not I mean certainly
I was born alive I fit that definition
everybody in the room does but I don't
think they're trying to protect
my right to life or so-called right to
life with this bill if I
if I had a terminal illness I think I've
been living will which says they
shouldn't take extraordinary means and
um this is obviously requiring
at least some people some you know very
young people have been born alive to be
subjected to extraordinary means even if
their parents or their Guardians um
Advocates have would prefer otherwise so
like is there uh where is there a cutoff
point or any clear cutoff point or like
who's an infant and then he's just a
very young baby
I would defer to the pediatrician in the
room but I think of an infant as a child
under the age of six months
thank you other questions representative
I've heard many testify today that
Physicians practice within the standard
of care and it seems that
the intent of this bill was to make
those who are not practicing within the
standard of care liable if this was
amended to States somehow
about acting within the standard of care
that you wouldn't be liable for that
um would that be something that you'd be
amenable to those laws already exist we
already practice within the standard of
care because that's what the Board of
Medicine suggests I don't think there's
any Amendment or any change to the
language in this bill that could make it
work
other questions yes representative Perez
it's my understanding that the previous
physician that spoke said that he might
not treat
if there was a 10 or less chance of
survival this shows me that
everyone has a different
I was in the intensive care for 42 years
everybody has different
interpretations of standard of care
um so I think to say that we you know
this is has too many hypotheticals I've
seen them
I would like to believe like in every
profession
everybody
is perfect and follows the guidelines
okay unfortunately
we have all seen that that does not
exist
what can we do
to
make sure people positions operate
within the standard of prayer not sue
them when they didn't
but how can we stop them from not do you
understand what I'm saying I do I think
it's a valid question I don't think it
has anything to do with this bill I
don't think this pill should should
affect that I think that that's a larger
existential question about how we do
licensing for different professions how
do we keep anyone from doing the job
that they're supposed to do
yes
but we're not talking we're talking
about the life
of a child
so we're not talking about
you know whatever happens whatever
we're talking about the life of a child
that has been born so it is not an
unborn child never seen that happen that
doesn't happen
not in The Accidental way that we're
talking about here
other questions for this week
yes representative
thank you for taking my question
um I'm going to boil it down to a little
more basic
what's the purpose of law
purpose of law is not to address the
people are doing good
but rather the few
that are doing bad
we have to come to the reality that
even within the medical profession as
good as all the people are
there's always going to be a few bad
apples
the news recently had a case in
Claremont doctor overstepped
um good good behavior boundaries in a
criminal sense and is going to face a
criminals penalty for that
this law is not to address all you
people are doing a terrific job in a
medical profession
gets to address the one or two
bad apples that may violate the
standards of care the standards of good
behavior the standards of society
we're trying to protect
that unborn child from those few that
would violate those standards
do you see happen to see that that's a
possibility with this bill
I I see what your question is I I don't
um
I
I think that the unintended consequences
of this bill are huge and I think that
um
that the circumstances under which you
are suggesting are already covered by
national National and state laws that
prohibit infanticide
thank you other questions so this
Witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you very much Emily zuzano and next will
be Allison Taylor
good morning chairman Lynn and honorable
committee members
it is good to see you again my name is
Emily zagrano and I ask you to oppose HB
this bill will will interfere with
Compassionate Care enforce medical
interventions that will not affect
survival
I am a doctor a mother of two living
children and as I shared yesterday I am
a woman who had two abortions due to
complications during a pregnancy with
twins
the first was due to uterine rupture
the second abortion was due to a high
risk of hemorrhage again
and miscarriage before viability born
too early for medical interventions to
save her life
if it had been different and she was
born before viability
then let me hold her
let me love her
let her feel my warmth and hear my voice
let her father touch her skin and stroke
her hair
he never got to feel her kit from the
womb like I did
do not force her into an incubator and
medical procedures with lines and tubes
and scalpels
ventilators and monitors and sterile
gloves
let her time be with us her family
and let us decide how that time is spent
let us build memories of loving her
not watching her suffer
families in complex unexpected and often
heartbreaking situations like ours
deserve support empathy and options
we should be able to make difficult
decisions with our doctors including
comfort care for babies who will not
survive regardless of medical
interventions
as a mom this needs to be allowed
this needs to be legal
this is not an appropriate place for
political interference
these are impossible decisions to be
made by parents medical experts the
people in that room
with all due respect it is not a
decision for the people in the
legislative committee room
as a doctor
I urge you
do not force doctors to deny family's
Compassionate Care
don't threaten them with years of
imprisonment to do something that goes
against their best medical judgment
against all the facts in front of them
I ask you to consider the Hippocratic
Oath which implores first Do no harm
a state mandate for medical
interventions that will not change
survival
outcomes is the definition of harm
it denies families the opportunity to
hold their baby before they pass and
piles up unnecessary expensive medical
bills for futile care
I have attended bereavement groups for
pregnancy and infant loss so many
families have tokens of their beloved
babies
Footprints locks of hair family photos
there was a woman who makes beautiful
baby clothes for infants as small as
half a pound in order for families to be
able to dress their loved ones before
saying goodbye
there is a wonderful device
two sentences please thank you thank you
three sorry there are systems in place
that support families in these
unimaginable heartbreaking situations
this bill does not give room for
palliative care do not create a system
that makes this terrible time worse no
law can be written to thread the needle
of these complex situations
please reject HP 346 thank you for your
time thank you questions for this
Witness
representative Stapleton
thank you for taking my question
you cited
a very sacred oath
Do no harm
Do no harm a very sacred oath thanks and
it's a good thing we have that oath and
it must be followed and by and large
medical people follow it
to the letter in the spirit
what do we do
when someone violates that sacred oath
we have to have an answer in that
situation and thankfully we already do
there are current laws that help keep us
safe there are medical boards and
codes of Ethics that Physicians and
other medical providers must answer to
if they are violating those that oath
there is a process that penalizes it
studies it evaluates it reflects on
standard of care and it holds people
responsible to maintaining their
professional oath
this law is not needed to keep
people in check and make sure that they
are doing well by their patients this
law causes harm
thank you other questions for this
Witness
saying none thank you uh next I'm going
to call on uh the Reverend uh Allison
Palin
Alison Palin
I don't see Mr Taylor here the next
witness then will be former
representative Phyllis Woods
and witness after that will be Laura Abe
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee and Phyllis woods from Dover
uh as a former member of the House
Judiciary Committee I introduce and
sponsored this identical Bill 20 years
ago and I think the same bill has
perhaps come at least once a session
since then
the intent of the bill is really very
clear
we're trying to provide for the dignity
and the decency and the compassion to
care for a very young infant that is
born alive that has the today the
tenacity to live either if they
um were the result of an intentional
abortion or perhaps a a a miscarriage or
a spontaneous natural abortion
I think that after the child is outside
of the womb the woman has had the
abortion if that is the was the intent
and we have a moral imperative at that
point to care for the other patient
which is the infant there is nothing in
this bill that I saw that would require
somebody to whisk that child away and
resuscitate it or do extraordinary means
it's very very clear that we're talking
about medically appropriate and
reasonable care we had many many
testimonies of women and men who had
been at the birth of one of these
children where the child had just either
been thrown in the trash or left on a
stainless steel sink to move and to try
to breathe until they died
what we what we're trying to do in
passing along is to not only add to the
moral imperative and the compassion of
the health care people to to care for
that child and to give it very simple
Comfort Care to keep it warm perhaps wet
the lips are hydrated not do any kind of
extraordinary means that would not be
reasonable
we always
um know that
the
the law requires that if we see any kind
of neglect or abuse of a child that has
to be reported I don't think anyone has
a problem with criminal portion of this
we know that abuse or neglect or a
deliberate attempts to hurt a child is
is a Criminal Intent so I urge you to
please please consider passing this very
reasonable compassionate law
thank you representative would you uh
right on the three-minute Mark we
appreciate that question for
representative Woods
yes
representative and then representative
Devon
yeah thank you Mr chair and thank you
for your testimony um we were told
earlier of scenarios in other states
where where some of the things that I
think you're speaking of have happened
um particularly in Pennsylvania and my
understanding is that that provider was
prosecuted and successfully
um
for those Acts being a former State Rep
I'm wondering if you could answer do you
know of anything in our current statutes
that would prevent that prosecution
currently in New Hampshire for the
things outlined
no um you know uh
we we all have seen and probably heard
of Gosnell and other uh egregious
child murderers actually who took
proactive action and I think we we must
have laws that uh would you know that's
that really into intentional killing or
harming of a child
I'm not sure if your question is if
anybody has been prosecuted I'm not
aware of that I don't I I really would
like to believe that that is not
happening I'm sorry maybe I wasn't clear
about my my question was really whether
you're aware of anything in current New
Hampshire statute that would have made
the prosecution as it came out in in
Pennsylvania not possible in New
Hampshire
no
not aware of that would would have made
that impossible I think that if that was
reported and known we certainly would
have laws that would have prosecuted
that kind of behavior a representative
Divine good question
okay
thank you thank you Mr chair uh thank
you for taking my question
um I'm I'm looking at the um chapter
132a and
the current law
States
that temporary care and control of a
child in a hospital or Safe Haven I'm
sorry
I'm trying to hear you I'm sorry well
I'm trying to I'm trying to get my head
around why we need this legislation when
we already have something in place that
does protect the child and the child
does go into
Protective Services or care
I don't think that we necessarily need I
as I said we uh the current I don't
think anybody has a problem with
Criminal Intent if somebody is taking
proactive action to do harm to the child
I think what this is is we've heard that
doctors want to do no harm that they
believe that what we're really doing is
taking care of the child and giving that
comfort care I think this would say
for example yesterday I had an
obstetrical nurse that was accompanying
me she couldn't make it today she said
that she was told that if she paid any
attention to a child that was born
as a result of an abortion uh that if
she tried to baptize in her care for it
or do it would pay any attention to
whatsoever it would have been the last
day that she would work the intent was
to take care of only the person that had
the abortion
um I think what this is is would give in
besides a moral imperative or what we
hope would be a conscience a decision
for the health care Personnel to take
care of the child it would give them the
legal authority to do so and it would be
would incentivize them to give at least
Comfort Care not extraordinary care just
to preserve the human dignity and
respect of the individual
other questions for this Witness
yes representative Greece
not on
foreign
there we go alrighty
thank you for taking our questions by
the way uh despite the technical
difficulties
you said that this bill has been
presented
20 years ago
you you sponsored the bill
how
now your microphone's broken sorry about
that I broke your mic
yeah yeah
the yes I think this has also been
sponsored and presented on the federal
level multiple times also the arguments
for and the arguments against probably
haven't changed in 20 years so how is
this current bill
different and subsequently better than
any other bill that's been presented so
far
that has not passed so that this bill
should be passed because I'm hearing the
same Arguments for and against
how is this better
I don't know if it is substantly
different in the wording I think it has
been uh streamlined it is
even though apparently it is under the
intent is unclear to some people it
seems crystal clear to the rest of us
that we are simply asking for a child to
be treated with a dignity and respect
um you know the same kind of care that
would be given if in fact someone had
spontaneously aborted the you know had a
spontaneous abortion or a miscarriage in
that instant the the uh the parents or
the the mother would have some interest
in wanting to perhaps take extraordinary
means but that by no means is is the
case for a child that had not been
wanted by the mother you can liken it to
the end of life care if in fact someone
has advanced directives and they don't
want any extra ordinary care then
they've taken some proactive action but
in the case of like a spontaneous
abortion the natural abortion or a
miscarriage the the parents at that
point have some say as to whether or not
they want extraordinary care and in many
instances it it doesn't make any sense
it probably doesn't make any sense
because this calls for appropriate care
and appropriate intervention if a child
is like less than a pound but is gasping
for breath or is moving and showing
signs of life with a heartbeat what this
bill would say is not only do you have a
moral imperative but now you have a
legal imperative to give it just the
very basic comfort care and to not not
subjected to Nicole collect and
that sort of thing
other questions for this week
seeing none thank you very much thank
you Mr chair next I'm going to call on
Laura Abel and then it will be the
Reverend Allison um or
Palin I'm sorry Reverend Allison Taylor
thank you
good morning
members excuse me I'm I'm crazy nervous
here so my name is Laura Abel I live
here can I ask you to get a little
closer to the microphone it's really
different I live in Matt I'm the name of
Laura Abel I live in Madison New
Hampshire and I'm here in opposition to
House Bill 346. I'm testifying on this
bill today because I know what it means
to have a wanted pregnancy to have
expected to bring my newborn home and to
experience
the devastating loss after the birth of
my child
I know firsthand how this bill would
have impacted my family and me and I do
not want anyone to have to give up the
last moments you have with your child
my story is from 1988 in Nashua New
Hampshire I was 23 plus weeks pregnant
my husband and I were very excited to
become parents
I went to the doctor on Tuesday because
I was having some cramps the doctor
thought I had a urinary tract infection
and I was sent home to be on bed rest
for two weeks
my water broke that evening in the video
store a little dated but
that's what it was we called the doctor
who immediately told me to come to the
Maternity Ward and I was admitted right
away
the next day they did an ultrasound
determining I had lost a lot of amniotic
fluid we were scared and confused we
didn't know what losing amniotic fluid
meant the doctor told doctors told us I
would be in a hospital until delivery
each evening I had contractions they
gave me antibiotics which stopped the
contractions because they knew the
chances for her survival would be higher
with more time
on Sunday morning I had a bloody show I
was told this meant my labor had begun
in a way that could not be stopped
they started preparing my husband and I
are the worst case scenario it was
possible that my daughter would be born
with her eyes to fused shut which they
explained to me met her lungs would be
underdeveloped and incapable of
sustaining her life
we held on to Hope though that we would
still be able to bring our child home
a few hours later my contraction started
to lessen and I was given the drug
pitocin to reintroduce the contractions
Allison Joanne was born a few hours
later
weighing one pound and six ounces
when she was born
we saw her eyes were still fused shut
we knew that meant we only had a small
amount of time with her
the staff cleaned fade and measured her
they swaddled her in a blanket and gave
her to my husband and me to hold
the staff took also took pictures of
Allison and we took some as well
her heart stopped beating at
approximately 40 minutes after her birth
we were so grateful to be able to hold
hug and protect our precious little
daughter for the time she had
Allison is buried in Nashua
no family should sacrifice any moment
with their child my husband and I for my
husband and I we were given only 40
minutes with our daughter
the doctors and staff there supported us
in being able to hold and care for her
exactly as we wanted to
no family should have that opportunity
taken away from them no doctor should be
forced to act any differently than
supporting grieving families in those
moments
thank you for allowing me to share my
story today I ask again that you vote
against House Bill 346 please do not put
any families like mine in a harder
position than it already is to have this
type of loss thank you questions for
this Witness
seeing none thank you next is the
Reverend Allison
aylin and next after that will be
Kathleen Wembley well
wemling I think
thank you
my name is Reverend Allison Palm I'm a
Unitarian Universalist Minister serving
the Unitarian Universalist Church of
Nashua as well as a resident of Nashua
and as a faith leader I'm here to speak
in opposition to house bill 346.
I know from hearing the conversation
this morning that there's lots of talk
around this bill and abortion I have
also heard today a lot about what the
intent of this bill might be
I don't believe either of those are
helpful instead I want to share my
thoughts on this bill from a pastoral
perspective
and from the perspective of impact
rather than intent
as a pastor and in my time working in
the hospital as a Chaplain I have seen
the vast difference between care that is
seeking to extend life and care that is
seeking to offer a comfortable death for
those with a terminal diagnosis
I have seen the Deep value of hospice
care which ceases any efforts to prolong
life and instead focuses on the comfort
of the patient as they are dying and the
needs of their family and loved ones as
they are saying goodbye
House Bill 346 essentially makes it
illegal for families to make choices
around the kind of care their baby gets
in the last moments of that baby's life
you have heard stories of families today
in this heartbreaking position of having
to say goodbye to a baby that they have
barely known
and it can be even more traumatizing to
have their baby taken away for those
last minutes or hours in an effort to
extend a life that is already lost
what families need is support to say
goodbye the ability to have their faith
leader come in and bless the baby if
they choose and the opportunity to be
with that baby in the little time that
they have
I urge you to oppose House Bill 346 and
the ways in which this bill would only
serve to bring more harm and Trauma to
grieving families thank you questions to
this Witness
thank you uh Kathleen doomling uh
will be next and after that will be
Jason Hennessey
hello my name is Dr Kathleen demling I'm
sorry I pronounced your name wrong you
were very close
my name is Dr Kathleen demling I'm a
psychiatrist and today I'm representing
myself in the New Hampshire Psychiatric
Society in speaking against House Bill
346 which threatens the ability of
medical providers to perform
evidence-based care that is ethical and
goes against patients and families
wishes
we've heard stories today where fetal
anomalies have no medical answers
when these severe problems are
identified mid-pregnancy parents are
counseled on their options which are
generally to induce an abortion or to
deliver and meet their baby the choices
made with the understanding that no
medical interventions exists that could
meaningfully extend their baby's life
and that the baby will only survive for
hours or maybe minutes after delivery
families choosing delivery are choosing
to meet their babies and this can be
very important to process their grief
infant loss is incredibly traumatic It's
associated with the development of PTSD
research has shown that the risk of
developing PTSD is significantly higher
among families who felt unsupported by
their medical team at the time of the
loss
to force a doctor or nurse to go against
parents wishes to hold their infant who
has minutes to live to take the baby to
another space to perform invasive care
that's been deemed futile it's more than
being unsupportive it's cruel and it
strips parents of an opportunity to
process their grief
and it's traumatizing to all parties
involved
in summary this bill threatens the
abilities of doctors and nurses to
provide Compassionate Care and conflicts
with the ethos of Do no harm
there are situations where forcing
higher levels of Medical Care would
contribute to the suffering of the
infant and their family
withholding invasive painful procedures
when there's no evidence that they would
be beneficial is not done with the main
purpose of hastening death but to avoid
pain and suffering and to allow parents
to share their child's last moments with
them in their arms
at the same time
starting Comfort Care is a choice made
by the medical professional and so I
fear with the wording in this bill that
this Choice could be interpreted as
intent
and therefore could be considered
intentionally hastening death depending
on the motivations of The Interpreter
thank you thank you questions for this
Witness
seeing none thank you
next will be Jason Hennessey and uh
the witness after that will be
uh
McKenna
thank you Mr chairman and honorable
members of house Judiciary my name is
Jason Hennessey I'm here to represent uh
the many pro-life people in New
Hampshire from New Hampshire and we're
part of New Hampshire right to life
we stand here to support HP 346
so the reason we support that is that we
it we support it primarily because we
want to protect born children
most people almost everybody agrees on
this
uh
and in particular we are concerned with
those infants that actually survive
abortions
because in their in the abortion room
you have at least two people who have
expressed intent to harm that child
and it is uh the state has an interest
in protecting
the the right to life of every every one
of its citizens and so for that reason
we support
uh we support this this legislation
right you've heard a cup you've heard
Gosnell referenced a couple of times how
that couldn't happen here uh he he was
convicted primarily because he actively
killed the children
but we're concerned about what about a
child that's born from an abortion and
is left there to starve or dehydrate
or something like that that is that's
our primary concern
uh you've heard that this is a
theoretical concern
well it's murky here in New Hampshire we
don't have statistics the people who
would know don't usually talk uh in in
definites but they they don't like to
give statistics of what they know
from what I've heard
and uh according to the family research
Council they surveyed eight states that
keep statistics on infants born alive
after after abortion and they found 245
cases
but that is a vast vast underestimate
because there's only eight states that
keep them
and and it and we have we don't know
anything about the other states
some of them grow up some of them are
like Melissa Odin and and you even heard
a gentleman earlier who who read a
statement from the abortion survivors
Network so there's enough of them to
form a network
so there's obvi this is obviously not a
theoretical case
uh I've heard it said earlier that we
should be depending on federal law but
the problem with federal law is that
it's very finicky in terms of
enforcement it depends on the
administration that's there and anybody
here I'm sure can come up with all sorts
of cases where something was illegal
under one Administration and then the
next Administration decided not to
enforce that
so we need something here in New
Hampshire to make sure that the right to
life is preserved here in New Hampshire
yesterday this committee heard two bills
to roll back the feedlife protection act
that protects unborn children at at six
months
and this would illegal this would
legalize abortion through birth
if if you're planning on supporting that
I would ask you to really consider
supporting this bill because if if that
is rolled back you could have seven or
eight month uh abortions where this
child could really survive and really
have a good chance of thriving
afterwards
in terms of a political reaction in
terms of the political reality reality
for those who disagree uh with this uh
with the bill as it is I didn't hear any
testimony opposing protecting survivors
of abortion
I heard I heard about it more with the
wanted children and and tragic tragic
circumstances
so I'd ask it if the committee would be
interested in supporting a bill that was
restricted to just abortion survivors if
that would create more consensus thank
you thank you questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much sir
oh I'm sorry representative Divine sorry
are there any current cases of babies
being born say within the last two years
of infants being born after an abortion
that have survived and can you speak to
any any instances of that in this state
so thank you for your question
representative uh there's no abortion
statistics we don't know uh we don't
know what happens and as far as it's
very murky so to my knowledge the answer
is no but I don't know that we would
know if it did happen
I I have a question do you think that
the reason that there are no statistics
is that neither side wants it because if
the if the pro-choice side had the
statistics it might show how how
unintrusive the current law is and on
the other side if the pro-life people
had it it might show how unintrusive the
present law is and it's in neither
side's interest to say that because it
undercuts both sides arguments do you
think that might be true so that is a
very interesting proposition Mr chairman
uh I can speak for the pro-life side and
only for the pro-life side that we've
been fighting for a statistics bill for
at least 15 years probably longer with
people who've been around longer than I
have know about that
um before that but we have been fighting
vigorously for this uh for one reason or
another it just comes up that people
find problems with it
okay thank you all right other questions
for this Witness
thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman thank you um uh uh I hope I'm
pronouncing this correctly should Fidel
McKenna fidelma McKenna it's difficult
fidelma McKenna thank you hi my name is
fidelma McKenna I'm a certified nurse
Midwife and I'm asking you to oppose
this bill I just wanted I think my
colleagues in the medical professions
the Pediatrics the pediatricians the
psychology psychiatric psychiatrist the
OB gyns have done an amazing job of
making my points so I just want to speak
from my committee members on the
bereavement committee at my labor and
delivery floor where we work so hard to
support families during the loss of a
pregnancy at 16 weeks at 18 weeks all
the way up we work so hard to support
the recovery of our patients to
defend the life of the neonate but I
just want to let you know that this bill
the way it's written doesn't work and it
would absolutely impede our ability to
help transition the baby and the parents
in a kind and compassionate way and I
don't think I'll do a great job of
getting into the weeds of the
hypothetical stuff but I was just like a
citizen who is here who does this work
on a daily basis this bill doesn't work
because we're getting into
babies who survived abortion but any
born alive infant including but not
limited to one born alive so this wraps
up all the babies that we take care of
we wouldn't be able to support them in a
way and I think that one thing that
represents Stapleton has said a couple
times is well you're not hastening care
you're not hastening sorry you're not
hastening the death you're just
providing Compassionate Care but I think
what we've heard before other medical
professionals say is we're terrified
that providing the like compassionate
loving support of the family
transitioning would be inter sorry would
be interpreted as hastening the death
and we just want to be able to do our
job so please oppose this law it doesn't
work on the in the reality on the ground
thank you questions for this Witness
yes representative Perez
is it lawsuits that you all are afraid
of oh no absolutely not it's more the
exact moment when that family is
grieving when we're paralyzed with wait
a minute what are we allowed to do when
that mother or father or parent has
asked to be given their baby and we want
to care for them and support them and
allow them to process that moment we're
worried that the ambiguity in this bill
will cause us to pause and paralyze and
not provide the excellent compassionate
loving care we know how to do
other questions for this wave
seeing none thank you uh Jamie Wilder
or Jama Wilder I think it's
I'm not sure but Wilder is the last name
anyway
hi there yes it's Jama Wilder okay
so I actually unexpectedly came in um to
sign in and I saw this bill was still
going and I was compelled to come in and
speak on it I am um I've lived in New
Hampshire for 42 years I'm a mother of
five children and I'm also a birth Doula
part-time obviously a lot changed since
covid but I also consider life very very
very important I have had two
miscarriages myself and I have had
postpartum with two of my children and
so I can speak to many of the things
that were said today
something in my life
um happened last April where my father
went into cardiac arrest at my house and
in that moment I had the decision to try
to save his life or wait for someone
else to show up
he was 70 years old and my my son and I
went into chest compressions and breaths
and we kept him alive until help was
able to arrive for the next several
hours
um he was brought to the hospital and
they did everything they could to keep
him alive
he
um had brain damage from the lack of
oxygen that went to his brain and they
gave us the option at that moment to
basically take him off of the medicine
that was keeping him alive
and we came in we said goodbye all of
the stories that you heard today were
false
falsified in the fact that they would
not allow a family to have that moment
with their child what this bill is doing
is it is saving babies that are being
born that are unwanted that are there
that the parents are saying that they
want their baby to be murdered and the
argument that is always put forth is
that when you're aborting a child it's
not really a life
but once that child comes out of the
womb and is breathing on its own or has
is viable to be saved they are saying
let the baby go they don't need any help
well each of you have to look at
yourselves and say if I went into
cardiac arrest right now would I want a
doctor to decide whether or not my life
was worth saving or my loved one or my
child's because if you can't say that a
life is a life and it's important to
save and to fight for that life
then why when we give parents the option
at two years old to say well this
child's going to cost me a lot medical
bills so we might as well just let them
die now
you're seeing our society in the
wickedness in it and the perverseness
that they're even talking about a
assisted suicides and bills coming up
I have so much appreciation for life and
the sad thing is that the doctors that
are standing up I don't know if they do
the abortions themselves I don't know if
they've held a teeny tiny baby in their
hands and said this life isn't worth it
but all this bill is doing is asking
immoral people that do not want to fight
to give life a chance
no maybe you're getting you're really at
the end of your time so I'd ask you to
sum up if you would please
they were asking
for a chance to make immoral people
moral and to have those doctors be
standing up and and having to
look at the oath that they took that
they do care about life
and I I support this bill and I pray and
I ask each of you to look at imagine
what a tiny baby in your hands breathing
would be
and and think about the fact that you're
fighting to save that child
thank you thank you questions for this
Witness
seeing none thank you very much man
thank you thank you right I don't I
don't have any other pink cards is there
anyone else who wishes to testify on
House Bill 346.
um Mr chair if I may I'll bring a pink
card up to you as soon as I'm done okay
honorable members of the committee thank
you for hearing my testimony today I
didn't plan to speak today
but testimony that I heard compelled me
to do so
I'm the Reverend Heidi Carrington Heath
speaking today on my own behalf I'm an
ordained Christian minister and a former
labor delivery NICU and postpartum
chaplain
want to invite you with me into a late
night hospital room for a moment
a young mom and dad are in the
postpartum Wing having just given birth
to a long-awaited baby
he is 23 weeks old
he has a fatal fetal anomaly that was
not previously detected and did not live
but for some two brief moments after he
was born
his parents have asked me to baptize him
with his tender fleeting name
they want to hold him
they want to pray
and they want to say goodbye
they are traumatized and exhausted they
want only in this moment to have a holy
and a tender ending
this is one of many stories I could tell
you about parents in profound and
soul-crushing grief over deeply wanted
babies with two short lives every one of
those stories is sacred and
heartbreaking
to deny these families these essential
moments would be inhumane
every physician and every medical team I
worked with went above and beyond to
save the life of every infant they cared
for without exception but it is
essential that we are clear that this
bill does not only apply to a limited
set of medical circumstances the
language is Broad
intentional or not
that is the case
we have a moral and an ethical
responsibility to offer the best care to
infants and parents I don't think any of
us would deny that sometimes that care
means allowing parents the Time to Say
Goodbye that they don't want to say
not to do so would be harmful
I don't believe for a moment one of us
in this room wants to end the life of a
baby prematurely that is inflammatory
rhetoric that is not helpful to this
conversation but as someone who has been
in many hospital rooms with babies who
simply could not survive I am
heartbroken that these incredibly Brave
voices that we heard today had to tell
these stories in public so families
would not be further harmed in the
hardest moment of their lives while the
intention of this bill may be narrow the
language is dangerously vague and
dangerously broad I'm really worried
that this bill can have cruel and
potentially dangerous consequences
I'm not taking any questions today but I
would ask you to vote itl on House Bill
346. thank you thank you very much
anyone else wish to testify on House
Bill 346.
see none I'm going to close the hearing
I know we're about an hour and a half
over uh over time but uh I'm gonna move
on and open the hearing on House Bill
562.
requiring informed consent prior to
receiving an abortion procedure and
given that it's
sort of the lunch hour if there are
people uh on the committee that wish to
uh wish to uh be excused for a short
time to take lunch that's fine
um I'll uh there'll be some of us
that'll hang in here for a while and
maybe do it in shifts uh but it's some
people wish to do that please uh
please feel free to do that so I'm going
to first uh recognize uh representative
testerman uh the prime sponsor of the
bill thank you uh
my name is Dave testerman I'm a a rep
from Franklin uh I'm a father of four
a I have 11 grandchildren actually 12.
uh and yeah
I've never been through this kind of of
operation of an abortion before
the easy thing about this particular one
is it's not asking you to provide some
sort of service to a person who is going
to have an abortion it's not asking you
to to talk about like in the last build
some of the issues about what happens
you know during an abortion all I'm
asking for is to provide a piece of
information to a to a person who is
going to have an abortion it's a
relatively long detailed kind of uh
information uh and it's the sort of
thing you would expect to hear
I mean what you would hear from a a I'm
going to have
whatever operation
in a long a bit of information that they
would give you over that period of time
and that's all
uh even though I mean I'm an engineer
I can't tell you what all this
information is it makes sense I can't
tell you what it is so like I'm not
going to answer those kind of questions
what I'm here to answer is should we
give a person who is going to have an
abortion
a full
and complete issue
for a full and complete group of data to
make a decision that you're going to
have to make either shortly or in the
near future
so with that uh
I'm open to any questions but again I
can't tell you whether or not a
particular kind of information that was
being prevented presented here is is you
know right wrong it's what the experts
say is right uh
all right
questions for representative testerman
I guess I do have a question
representative I'm wondering um
as I look through the bill
um
I I guess I I
my basic question is is do we
do you have some
evidence or some you know some some
documentation or some evidence that you
can point to suggesting that
there's a real problem with
you know a substantial number of women
who are having abortions not
not giving consent that they're that you
know we we need to be concerned that a
lot of women are are sort of being
forced to have an abortion against their
against their will
no my my understanding isn't that
they're being forced to give in a uh
an opinion about whether or not they
want to have an abortion against their
will
my question is and the reason we've got
this is strictly are the people there
will
properly
informed as to what they're they're
talking about in a way of an abortion
whether it's an abortion on drugs a
physical abortion uh and just you know
do you have that do you have the
information that is necessary
have you seen this information before
but I I'm not uh I'm not I I have no
indication that there may be a problem
without it thank you other questions for
this Witness oh
yes uh thank you representative
it's my understanding and correct me if
I'm wrong with this bill is clarifying
when you're having surgery for example
you have to listen to the pros and cons
they won't just you can't just say I
don't want to hear that
it's my understanding when you're having
an abortion and if someone's here from
Planned Parenthood they could correct me
but it's my understanding that you're
allowed to say I don't want to know
it's
I believe what I'm understanding from
this bill is that
it is requiring you to have that
information
much like as if you were having a major
medical procedure
is that correct
I understand that's correct
right other questions for this workers
yes representative
should we
consent
but
I'm sorry I just didn't hear you
should we be dictating informed consent
content
in effect it is informed consent
so I I don't know whether it's proper to
end to to tell somebody you know that
they have to listen to this
but I believe they should
other questions for this wedding
seeing none thank you very much
representative thank you
uh representative uh
I'm sorry representative sellers yes
representative sellers
good afternoon thank you chair and thank
you committee members actually I'm
starting to feel like I'm on the
Judiciary Committee I've been here for
the last day and a half
I I read through this bill and I was
looking at it and yes I am a co-signer
of the bill as well
and um
what's wrong with consent I mean just
you know what we're trying to do is
making sure the
person
going for the abortion
has comprehensive knowledge
of exactly where they are and what stage
they're in and knowing exactly what
they're going to be
what's going to actually happen to them
I don't see any problem with that
so it's consent it also don't say do you
know and and there's making sure the
doctors are going step one two three
four five and six that's all they're
doing they're asking for it
so I I don't really see any problem with
a bill like this
it's consent I think it's comprehensive
and make it sure it's inclusive again if
we if we pass a bill and they say well
you know we missed this or we should add
that well that's what we had amendments
for so
that's it
questions for this one yes
representative
are you aware of any other Medical
procedure which requires 24 hours
Advanced informed consent
a blood procedure
are you aware of any other medical
procedure that requires 24 hours
Advanced informed consent no I'm not
thank you
other questions for this Witness
yes representative Greece
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative are you aware of any
medical procedures that do not require
informed consent no I am not
other questions for this Witness
thank you very much uh representative
one other sir what oh I'm sorry was
there another question here oh yes
representative very often now when
people go in for pre-operative
um evaluations prior to major surgeries
it is that time or at least it was that
time when they sign read and sign their
form percent consent which is done
usually prior unless an emergency basis
to 24 hours before the procedure
that's my understanding if it's changed
I apologize
so is that a statement or a question I
guess thank you so so I guess maybe I
have a question just to sort of follow
up on representative's question
um
this would propose I I have no doubt
that you know in when surgical
procedures of one kind or medical
procedures of one kind or another are
undertaken the medical people require
consent this would put consent for this
particular type of procedure in statute
and I guess what I'm wondering is
let's take something that's completely
sort of what I would characterize as
voluntary
the cosmetic surgery
do you know which is it strikes me as
the the risk of having that or not
having that is in terms of what you what
benefit you get out of it is is far less
important if you will then at least in
most cases than than the risks on one
side or another of abortion uh do we
have a statute that says before you can
perform cosmetic surgery the doctor has
to get consent
um in the way that this bill talks about
consent
if uh representative I'm not sure if we
have a statue on that I have not looked
up any other statues on consent
however this consent is very specific
for abortions that's my understanding
and it's very comprehensive to make sure
the woman that's getting the abortion is
very clear where she's at and what's
going on and what's going to happen in
her abortion
all right other questions for this week
yes representative
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question uh
somebody else may have already asked
this question
but I may have been distracted so uh my
question is
uh is it necessary already
for a person having a uh an abortion to
give
uh
consent
informed consent
I didn't hear the last part is it
necessary already for a person getting
an abortion that to give informed
consent well that's a good question
because you know one of the things that
we don't do here and again is brought up
a couple times today is that we don't
track abortions we don't count them we
don't know how many and I don't work for
Planned Parenthood or a couple other
outlets that might actually perform
abortions so I don't really know what
they have and what they give out for
documentation
other question answer that
other questions for this Witness
uh yes representative divine
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um on page
I guess three of the proposed Bill
lines 18 through 21
talked about
get having an ultrasound and an
ultrasound usually takes time to set up
can it be
um you know it could take a week or
something like that before you get an
actual
um appointment for that ultrasound is
this a mandatory part of this bill that
that has is it a requirement of informed
consent for the individual that is going
for an abortion
so my understanding from some testimony
we heard yesterday is that ultrasounds
are available right then and there you
know at the clinic so just to verify
that how all the infant is so
I don't know if it would take a week or
not it doesn't sound like if well I'm
just wondering I'm wondering you know is
is this a delay tactic for the abortion
and written in the bill and that's what
I'm wondering I understand what you're
saying though and I don't have an answer
to that and I hope that's not the case
thank you yes representative Morgan
um thank you very much thank you very
much representative and you may or may
not
be able to answer this but um there's a
lot of very very detailed wording in
this
build which is fine and a lot of it
turns up an identical or nearly
identical form in other states bills
have been used in other states in some
cases past so
um
some definitely it's a fair so the first
question is it fair to inform that you
and representative curteling or Peter
didn't craft this all yourself and like
do you
are you prepared to tell us what the
source of the model legislation was
are you asking me about model uh this
appears to be model legislation that's
been passed in other states so like who
I who I cannot answer that right thank
you all right other questions for this
Witness
see none thank you uh thank you thank
you committee thank you I call in former
representative uh Phyllis Woods followed
by Danielle Pimentel
representative Woods
don't think she's here all right uh
Danielle Pimentel followed by Omer
good afternoon again
Mr chairman and members of the committee
my name is Danielle Pimentel with
Americans United for life and
hb562 safeguards women's informed
consent and ensures that women
understand the real alternative to
abortion which is why I urge your
support I want to first start out though
and address some of the questions that
you all had raised just um during the
previous testimony
um representative Lanza you had a
question about whether we should dictate
informed consent
and so I just wanted to address that in
in Dobbs the Supreme Court overruled Roe
Wade and Casey or Planned Parenthood
versus Casey and the Court held that
states May regulate abortion for
legitimate reasons and that a law
regulating abortion
um is entitled to a strong presumption
of validity so in this regard New
Hampshire has
broad powers to pass informed consent
protections which ensure that a woman's
decision to abort her child
um unborn child is informed involuntary
also to address
um Mr chairman your question about do we
have any data or statistics with course
abortions or people the need for
informed consent in that regard and I
spoke to this a little bit yesterday and
I'm going to turn to some of my
testimony I submitted written testimony
on all these bills but
um
women seeking abortion are often are
there are high rates of women seeking
abortion that are subject to intimate
partner violence and or reproductive
control and so let me just turn to that
so I can reference some of these sources
here
you just
allow me to do that
um an intimate partner violence that
could be anything from you know sexual
emotional physical abuse anything like
that and for women seeking an abortion
the prevalence of ipv which is the
acronym for that is nearly three times
greater than women continuing a
pregnancy and for Reproductive control
which is when a partner or family member
or could be a sex trafficker tries to
assert control of a woman's reproductive
Choice
um one in four I think a quarter I mean
as many as a quarter woman of
reproductive age attending for sexual
and reproductive Health Services have
given a history of suffering
reproductive control so because of the
prevalence of ipv and because the
prevalence of reproductive control in
women seeking abortions
informed consent safeguards can help
ensure that women are having the
information to voluntarily make these
decisions for themselves to have an
abortion or to not have an abortion and
not be influenced by intimate partner
violence or reproductive control so I'm
just I guess I'm curious how is this how
is this going to help that in other
words a woman
you know under your scenario a woman is
kind of
threatened or forced by her partner to
get an abortion
um and
so she goes and we have let's assume
this law is in effect
um so the
the how is that you know she's told you
better agree to this abortion so she
goes in by her intimate partner whatever
and this this bill is in effect is this
is she now going to just because because
a doctor has read off these things to
her she's going to say oh well I don't
have to worry about my boyfriend beating
the hell out of me if I don't get the
abortion because I'm signing all these
things isn't she just going to sign them
anyway
well in this film particularly it offers
or part of the bill requires that um the
woman be informed of benefits to her so
that could be benefits while she's
pregnant that the state offers or
prenatal care are part of postnatal care
things like that and so when women are
have
um more information about the other
Alternatives that they have the actual
resources they have to help them that
support social and familiar support from
just Community around them and other
Alternatives like from Pregnancy
Resource Centers things like that they
have a better I mean they may have if
they want to continue that pregnancy
then they have the information to know
they will be supported even if they
don't have that support from their
partner that they have the support
whether that's from the state or other
people in the community that can help
them care for their child or have an
option to give their child up for
adoption so this informed consent
process would allow women to understand
the resources available to them and
therefore they're able to make decisions
knowing
um that they have options for their baby
if they want to give birth to their baby
that maybe the baby would not be in the
same situation that they're in with
unfortunately a partner who is abusing
them in some form all right all right
thank you other questions for this
Witness
correct
oh I'm sorry oh representative Andrews
I'm sorry
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you for
taking my question
okay before I have a surgical procedure
please be out with me
I have to sign the consent form
is having an abortion a surgical
procedure and why doesn't a consent poem
have to be signed
yes so it depends on the stage of
pregnancy that woman or like the
gestational age of the baby I should say
so for the first 10 weeks
um of a woman's pregnancy generally the
abortion procedure would be a chemical
abortion and so that's a two-pill
regimen
um however there could be some surgery
um there could be surgery implied in
that if the let's say the chemical
abortion didn't fully work and there was
a baby that needed to be expelled there
could have to be actual surgical
intervention
um after 10 weeks though it generally is
a surgical procedure
um either it's through kind of like a
vacuum procedure I I don't know the full
term of that or a DNE
um something like that where there is
actual surgery
um or we classify that as a surgical
procedure I should say
um and so for those reasons and also
with chemical abortions because of the
risk that women face with chemical
abortion
um the risk of sepsis infection again
not having the baby fully expelled there
is
um
necessity for informed consent to to
make them aware of these risks so that
they know fully going into these
procedures whether it's a chemical
abortion or a surgical abortion the
impacts that could have on their own
health
other questions to this Witness
saying none thank you very much and if I
could just I'm sorry briefly just one
other thing another representative had a
question about whether the bill requires
an ultrasound it does not the build
simply says that provides informed
consent to a woman
um to know whether or essentially the
bill states that a woman will receive
um a paperwork that says that she has
the option to have an ultrasound and she
is signing off on whether she wants an
ultrasound or not
um and also saying that she refuses to
look at if she does get an ultrasound
she's refusing to look at the pictures
or she wants to select the pictures of
the bill in and of itself does not
require an ultrasound all right thank
you uh Kayla Montgomery and next will be
uh Josie Pinto Kayla Montgomery
good afternoon my name is Kayla
I'm the vice president of public affairs
for Planned Parenthood of Northern New
England
we oppose house bill 562. it adds
significant barriers to abortion care
and it is a wash with misinformation and
frankly shaming language so there's a
few concerns with this bill I will get
into them
um the first uh the definition section
of medical emergency
it provides the definition that is not
medically accurate in particular it
carves out physiological or emotional
conditions without any input or support
from New Hampshire's medical community
also right below that in section B2 it
appears to call into question who can
provide an abortion in New Hampshire
without any Clarity or any scientific or
medical
justification
and then if you look at section B2 which
is really just mostly all of page two it
contains a list of medically inaccurate
risks associated with medical with
medication abortion
so I want to be really perfectly clear
there is absolutely no evidence that
it's possible to counteract the effects
of mephrystone as and as suggesting this
to patients is frankly just bad medicine
Planned Parenthood of Northern New
England a New Hampshire abortion
providers always provide trusted
medically accurate information to
patients and moreover by mandating that
Healthcare Providers give patients
misleading and potentially dangerous
information this bill undermines the
patient provider relationship and the
entire informed consent process
uh page three talks about
um mandating that patient's weight 24
hours after providing informed consent
before getting their abortion again
there's no medical justification for
this requirement it will only cause
further delays for patients and
providers
it is standard medical practice that
when a patient schedules their
appointment
there is a mandatory consultation and
that's included where the provider makes
the page make sure that the patient
understands all of the information about
the process that the patient understands
and is educated on their options
and also there is a private screening to
make sure that the patient is not being
coerced in any way there's absolutely no
exceptions to this protocol if a patient
comes in and they don't speak English we
provide translation services there's no
exceptions here that is a part of every
single abortion procedure mandatory
consent
so this bill would undermine the
informed consent process by mandating
that the provider give inaccurate
information to their patients and then
also it forces them to delay care for 24
hours so this requirement interferes
with the provided patient relationship
and it creates unnecessary delays for
women seeking time-sensitive care
and finally uh if you look at page four
the bill requires DHHS to post
information on their website and offer a
24-hour phone line without a lot of
details frankly
um nowhere in this section does it
explain how the information will be
compiled monitored updated distributed
or paid for by so uh overall this bill
is full of medically inaccurate
stigmatizing and frankly confusing
language
Granite Cedars seeking abortion care
already receive complete and accurate
information from trains providers
regarding their abortion care and we
would urge this committee to itl House
Bill fives all right questions for this
week
yes uh representative Perez
so when are individuals coming into
playing Parenthood given all this
information
so a person does not just come in off
the street a person makes an appointment
generally online or they call our health
center
during that first initial process the
beginning conversation happens the
conversation about what's going to occur
during the process maybe some talk about
maybe you'll see protesters what to do
in that event if you're coming into a
health center so those conversations
begin and then once the um once the
procedure once the appointment happens
that conversation happens before the
abortion and those questions are
repeated around do you understand what's
happening all of those questions are
repeated throughout the procedure as
well just to really ensure yeah
can I just ask you to hang on just like
one second I'm going to recognize
representative Manos because I
understand that some of her constituents
maybe in the gap
thank you Mr chair
um strata middle school is here today
fourth graders and I'm very happy to
welcome them and to say hello
could I just ask if they have any
questions
I was just wondering whether perhaps you
have any questions that you would want
to ask us
what I couldn't hear you
yes it absolutely is I'm uh I'm a
freshman so this is the first time I've
been here and I'm having a lot of fun
I do I do
well one of our jobs is to hear people's
opinions on the bills that we're
considering it's a very Democratic
process with a small D so anyone can
come and give us their opinion on what
we're working on and it's a lot of fun
to hear people talk about their views on
the bills we're considering
thank you
well thank thank you thank you so much
for coming
hang on just one second and I found
right that's for sure I know
I have a follow-up please when they're
out
all right
um yes I I'm sorry you you please
continue your your answer to the
question
yes representative Burris I'm sorry I
still don't understand so I go online
and I make an appointment
does someone call me and go through all
this or does it happen when I walk into
the clinic
so it could be a couple times someone
will call and talk to them about their
upcoming appointment make sure that
they're still wanting to come
um talk about what sort of what they can
expect if it is a uh if it is an
abortion in our health center talk about
maybe how much time they need that they
can bring a support person you know
basic things like that
um and then once they're there the
conversation around
um the private screening to do the to
make sure there's no coercion that type
of thing happens
other question
yes follow up I'm sorry so I call for an
appointment someone calls me back I'm
going to assume that and tells me I have
to be there at such and such a time like
every other appointment that we go on in
our lives but the actual consultation
about exactly the procedure
um
and all of that does not occur in my
understanding until the appointment and
also at that time
are any other options given to the
person and if you do a private
consultation about a possibility of uh
you know they're being coerced
they're not given time I mean so then
it's either decide now or don't decide I
mean I do there's no time
process all this before you make the
decision yeah so as I mentioned
um absolutely all options are given to
the patient and we're not talking about
once this isn't you know a rut is this
is something that's rushed this is
patient-centered Care at any point the
person can change their mind there is no
every patient's going to be different
and that's why these questions are going
to be repeated multiple times to make
sure that the patient is still feeling
comfortable in their decision
if they decide that they want to come
back next week if they decide you know
what I have a consultation I had you
know I I'm not comfortable I want to
maybe give it a few more days
that's fine it's every situation is
going to be different and we are going
to work with that patient to make sure
that every patient has what they need to
feel comfortable and if it's not a
decision that they want to make at that
moment that's fine
other question for this Witness
yes representative
sorry
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your testimony you said that the the
information on page two regarding the
pepperstone and uh progesterone is
medically inaccurate information
I don't think that the sponsors of this
bill intended to provide medically and
accurate information
although if there's a possibility of it
being inaccurate then obviously it would
need to be corrected
that aside would you please explain
uh how a chemical abortion takes place
what what is Buffett Stone uh and the
relationship with progesterone and why
this would have even been introduced if
there wasn't some basis in reality
can you just explain where this might
have come from sure so medication
abortions Two drugs
used together
um so the what I am understanding from
this bill
is that it is
trying to say that you can reverse a
medication abortion that is what I
believe this bill is trying to indicate
there is no uh there is no basis and
facts for that there's no
the FDA has not said that that is a
situation there's been no that does not
happen so suggesting otherwise is just
simply
um Bad Medicine
other questions
yes representative Church
thank you Mr chair and and thank you for
your testimony as well um
in in terms of informed consent I know
Planned Parenthood provides uh uh
abortion services and many other
services
isn't the primary or uh purpose for
giving informed consent both sort of
standard of care and to address medical
legal issues and uh short of having this
law
um what would be your your your
expectations of your staff in terms of
that
nothing would if this is standard
medical guidelines this is something
that we are a health care provider we
follow all standard medical guidelines
and all medical ethics so informed
consent is just simply a part of the
process and not just once but throughout
can I just do a quick follow-up yeah um
in in terms of your medical liability
um it would would you have would you
feel that there are concerns if this
were not being given um in terms of
consequences to the organization
absolutely we fought like like I said we
follow all standard Medicals and
guidelines we are a Health Care
Organization that operates within the
law of the State of New Hampshire we are
licensed medical professionals and we
would never do anything to jeopardize
that because that means our patients
could not rely on us for care anymore we
would never jeopardize that
other questions for this Witness
yes representative Stapleton
thank you for taking my question
going back to the uh progesterone
um and I don't know whether this is
valid or not but uh PubMed
made a made a statement in the study of
the use of progesterone to counteract
the Memphis Stone
case reports four of six women who took
Memphis Stone were able to carry their
pregnancies to term after receiving
intramuscular progesterone 200
milligrams now I don't know if PubMed is
a valid source or respected Source or
not
um but would you care to comment on that
particular case report
yeah I would just repeat that there has
been
no documentation that you can reverse
the medication abortion than anything
else I would consider drug science
other questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you thank you
I'm going to call next on Josie uh pinto
and after that the next one will be
Maris Holland
good afternoon Representatives I'm here
again to represent the views of the
reproductive Freedom fund of New
Hampshire and I'm here to urge you all
to oppose HB 562.
every day my job is to help patients
access abortion care that is often not
an easy thing for many of them to do
between the cost of the procedure the
need to take time off from work or
school arrange child care and
transportation there are many barriers
that exist for patients looking to
access abortion care
let's be clear this bill only serves as
one more barrier that would absolutely
lead to increased difficulty for
patients looking to access abortion this
bill would push abortion Out Of Reach
for many
I have experience working in a clinic
that provides abortion and in that role
I helped to counsel patients around the
options available to them I can
personally attest that this process is
completely rooted in informed consent
making sure the patient is aware of all
their options so that they are able to
make the best decision possible for them
there is no need for someone to take 24
hours to make their decision once they
have come in for their initial
appointment
patients that show up to their
appointments know what decision they are
making and if they decide against an
abortion we are there to provide them
the support and resources they need
if they have questions ahead of time
typically those are addressed through
the initial intake call when they
schedule their appointment
if a patient wants to take their time to
think about it then clinics absolutely
understand that and respect their wishes
this is all to say there is absolutely
no need to mandate a 24-hour waiting
period because patients can determine
for themselves when they should get care
as with many of these bills I ask you
all to trust patients trust providers
let us not interfere with their ability
to make these incredibly personal
decisions but let's instead provide them
with a compassionate fact-based
information and care they deserve
regardless of what they choose I urge
you all to vote against HB 562 thank you
thank you questions for this Witness
representative Gleason thank you Mr
chair and thank you for your testimony I
this is genuinely I do not know how much
does an abortion cost roughly 500 though
if gestational limit is higher it goes
up from there but on average 500.
further questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you you know what I
realized I've
I think I overlooked uh Omer Hearn it
was uh to testify next and then uh
Marist uh Tolland I will get to you as
the very next wish thank you so uh Mr
Ahern please
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee
again my name is Omer Ahern Jr I'm from
Wentworth New Hampshire
and I am in support of House Bill 562
Dash FN
we're talking about
human life
the most precious thing
that we have
our country was based upon the concept
of life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
every day we're all faced with
uh
situations where
we're asked to sign a consent form
and you know we're we're adults
what we're talking about I believe with
regard to house bill
562-aff then
the reality of all this is that we are
discussing some very unique
special circumstances
as they apply to a second
life
and I just believe no matter what the
cost
to to protect life
we need to be able to do that
because life is invaluable
and to require
the mother to
get the necessary information again in
my line of work I've seen situations
where people are not given information
they are coerced
they are misled
and all where I believe all we're trying
to do here especially
in the way our society has changed so
much over the last 40 years
we really need to make sure that these
folks these women and many of them are
very young but that they're getting the
proper information so that they can make
the right decision
knowledge is so important
and in my mind in these special sets of
circumstances
it is better to err on the side of
caution
to protect life
again I ask you to support
the passage of House Bill
562 FN all right questions questions to
this Witness
thank you thank you very much next is
Maris Tolland and then after Miss
Tolland will be Jason Tennyson
good afternoon my name is actually
Janelle Hobson Dr Tolland had to go back
to the hospital
um and she has asked me to read her
testimony all right okay thank you
the purpose of this legislation is not
to provide informed consent which
already happens in the medical offices
by the way the purpose is to make it
challenging or impossible for patients
to access abortion services
this bill belittles the decision-making
power in individual autonomy of your
neighbors
who are you to understand or dictate how
others make decisions the government's
job is not to give timelines for
personal choices
what's more this bill is mandating that
I lie to my patients
a randomized controlled trial was
performed in 2020 in order to estimate
the efficacy and safety of
persist Stone
um antagonization with progesterone
progesterone sorry about that that is to
say looking at this non-fda approved
therapy to stop abortion process
that is mentioned in this film
the study was unsuccessful at estimating
the efficacy of progesterone for halting
the abortion process due to safety
concerns when the medication abortion
was only half completed
the study had to stop early because
several patients undergoing this
experimental therapy
underwent severe Hemorrhage requiring
ambulance transportation to an emergency
department
ACOG does not recommend this
experimental practice stating that and I
quote claims of medication abortion
reversal are not supported by the body
of scientific evidence and this approach
is not recommended end quote
mandating Health Care Providers to give
patients information about an unproven
and experimental therapy is a disturbing
intrusion into the relationship between
Physicians and their patients we should
all be concerned when politicians
recommend treatment options over the
advice of medical profession
professionals
thank you questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you Jason Hennessey
and next will be Sandra de encore
Jason Hennessey
do not see
Jason Hennessy so I'm going to then call
on Sandra then on court please
please
foreign
thank you very much thank you
hi thank you good afternoon honorable
chair and committee members
I've submitted written testimony to you
uh I plan to focus my oral testimony on
a similar topics based on your questions
today I think I may speak a little bit
differently than I had planned uh so
thank you for the opportunity to submit
written and oral testimony in opposition
to House Bill 562 I'm Sandra de nancor
I'm a licensed registered nurse in the
state of New Hampshire and I'm the
executive director of the lovering
health center in Greenland
as you know or may know Joan G Levering
Health Center has over 42 years of
experience providing high quality health
care that includes abortion care we have
many
many concerns about this bill including
the stigmatizing focus the potential
burdens of mandating a waiting period
the requirement that the Department of
Health and Human Services produced
literature thus designed to reinforce
common anti-choice strategies and the
attempt to legislate the provision of
information by health care providers
that does not in the best interest of
their patients
I'd like to be clear that house bill 562
does not introduce the concept of
informed consent in abortion care
medical ethics Board of Medicine and
common standards of practice already
require informed consent prior to
abortion procedures whether they are
medication abortions or procedurals or
surgical abortions
medically accurate patient-centered
informed consent is already an essential
element of delivering abortion care in
New Hampshire including at the lovering
health center House Bill 562 is an
overreaching attempt to interfere with
the delivery of accurate evidence-based
abortion care
so for those who may not know medication
abortion is used for over half of the
patients seeking abortion care in our
country that's also true in New
Hampshire medication abortions are
provided following safe effective
protocols using one or two medications
in the two medication protocol
mifipristone is administered first the
second medication misoprostol is taken 6
to 24 hours following methopristone
there is also an evidence-based
guideline for the use of mesoprostol
only
and though that involves time to
multiple doses of misoprossal it's
really critical for you to understand
that it is accurate when we say there is
no body of evidence to support the use
of progesterone after the administration
of mythopristone
to affect the viability of a pregnancy
after method Personnel Administration
meaning there's no evidence that after a
patient takes methopristone the first
step in a medication abortion that
supplemental progesterone adding
progesterone to their body will impact
the viability of a pregnancy if in fact
it is continuing
our bodies when they are pregnant
naturally produce progesterone to
support the pregnancy
a patient seeking an abortion has
adequate progesterone in their body
to protect and grow that pregnancy if
they didn't their pregnancy would not be
viable at the time of the abortion I
hope that makes sense to you the way
that I'm explaining it
so there is no evidence that if a
patient remains pregnant after taking
this from that misfa pristine that there
is in fact an impact by adding
progesterone in fact there's potential
there for harm and the studies that have
been done have demonstrated over and
over that there is not enough evidence
to support this recommendation all right
so you're kind of over your time okay
sum up please yes so I would like to say
that the Levering Health Center if there
are questions about informed consent in
the process of delivering Health Center
I would welcome the opportunity to
address those thank you thank you
questions for this Witness
I guess thank you chair and thank you
for your testimony you used the
expression stigmatizing focus and I'm
wondering what you mean by that
I'd be happy to speak to that thank you
for your question
I think there is an assumption that or I
would say what I hear often is the
assumption that the fact that we exist
abortion providers and medical
professionals providing abortion care
exist and that patients call us already
having decided that they may be seeking
abortion care means that somehow we're
coercing them into that decision which I
find offensive honestly and I think it's
stigmatizing to patients
when they are presented with information
that wholeheartedly reinforces the fact
that they must or should consider
information beyond the risks benefits
and realistic medical guidance that we
provide associated with abortion care so
I'm speaking about mandating that we be
directing patients to consider
information about fetal development the
size of a fetus the physical the wording
in this bill the physical
characteristics of the fetus etc etc
that information is publicly available
already anyone any patient who wanted to
seek that information could find it
publicly already and consider it and we
would be happy to to
provide references to those resources if
that was the information a patient
wanted
so I find it stigmatizing
to imply that a patient is not informed
when they come to our office unless they
receive information that reflects
information designed to reverse their
decision or influence the reversal of a
decision to have an abortion other
questions for this Witness
yes uh whoops uh representative Perez
thank you
I heard what Planned Parenthood does
what I'm trying to find out if I am an
18 year old girl who finds myself
pregnant
um and I go online to make an
appointment
um is it a medical professional that's
going to call me back before my
appointment and say
you know these are your options you can
have a medical you can have a
non-medical but there are other options
out there if you decide to not have the
abortion is that all done and is it a
medical professional that is giving me
that information prior to me walking in
the door
uh yes so uh for the lovering health
center
patients did not make appointments
online they're always made directly in
conversation with patients they're not
ever made in conversation with a second
party for instance a parent a partner
anyone else so
we have a process we have a mandatory
education session for every single
patient receiving abortion care prior to
their abortion if a patient does not
attend that or cannot attend that that
would be the only circumstance where we
would provide same-day education and
abortion care we may our protocol is
that we have a one hour session
dedicated for every single abortion
patient that we require them to attend
by Telehealth or in person their choice
where they receive extensive education
about options
an assessment with them about their
Readiness to make the decision that
they're making we confirm privately with
them that they are not being coerced
into making this decision by anybody or
feeling coerced By Us in any way and
then we provide all of the medical
information about the procedure itself
the risks the benefits and at the end of
that there is a time frame the
appointment for the abortion is not that
same day typically
so there is an opportunity for folks to
reflect and change their minds and we
confirm that and the language system the
bill asks for it to be certified and I
would say that every single abortion
patient that comes to our Clinic has
assigned informed consent in their
medical record that includes all of the
elements that I just discussed including
coercion including risk benefits and
safety and all of the elements of their
procedure
are there other options as well yes the
first line of our consent form explains
you have the right to make to continue
your pregnancy and that if you choose to
continue your pregnancy options are
parenting or adoption Etc so that
language is in our consent form other
questions so this way representative
thank you very much and
I hope I'm not asking a question you
can't answer but I'm sure you're in
contact with your colleagues at similar
Health Centers Nationwide
um
but one of the in uh
back on the fourth page available on
about a geographically indexed materials
about the uh you know the options um
they specifically mentioned adoption
agencies but it should presumably
include all the options so they include
clinics such as yours which do provide
services throughout pregnancy so you
don't just provide a pregnancy but you
also provide a Services you know for for
women who are
carrying their pregnancies to terms or
you know if you're if they've been
included or excluded from the so-called
geographically indexed material which is
presumably been made available in other
states because this exact same bill has
been introduced and even passed in some
other states so even though the
co-sponsor wasn't quite sure where it
came from it's clearly a model legis
bill that came from somewhere and it's
being introduced Nationwide and thanks
yeah it's my understanding is that this
resource at the Department of Health and
Human Services are on their website does
not exist and this is mandatory increase
uh this is mandating creation of that
resource and my reading of the language
of the bill is that it does not require
that we be included in that resource I
can't speak to what's happening in other
states
thank you any other questions for this
week
all right next I have uh Courtney Reed I
hope I'm
Courtney Reed yes
thank you chairman and members of the
committee uh I'm here again today on
behalf of the ACLU of New Hampshire to
encourage committee members to oppose HB
562 and Trust patients decisions
HP 562 as we've heard in other testimony
would require all patients seeking
abortions to wait 24 hours before any
medical intervention
the proposed legislation also contains
misinformation regarding medication
abortion and shames patients by making
assumptions about their decision-making
capabilities
I'll start by noting that waiting
periods prevent individuals from
obtaining abortions it adds an
unnecessary barrier for patients for no
reason based in science or medicine
moreover forcing patients to attend
multiple appointments bring added costs
Beyond just an initial co-pay or the
cost of an abortion patients will need
to arrange to take extra time off work
potentially jeopardizing jobs they can't
afford to lose find additional child
care and scrape together money for
travel and lodging costs generated by
the mandatory delay and any difficulties
in scheduling a second appointment May
push an abortion out later into
pregnancy
as such mandated delays have
demonstrated to increase medical risks
many of the patients who don't manage to
overcome obstacles imposed by mandatory
delay laws are forced to seek later
abortions for example a waiting period
that was installed in Mississippi showed
that the proportion of abortions
performed after the first trimester
increased by 39 percent
medical groups like The ACOG stand in
opposition to waiting periods for this
reason
moreover mandatory delays
disproportionately hurt minors for many
reasons young people tend to have
abortions later than adults many
teenagers have irregular menstrual
cycles and take longer to recognize the
signs of pregnancy
we should not add another barrier to
their ability to access abortion
mandated delays to mean pregnant
individuals
mandated delays for abortions imply that
patients who are seeking this procedure
or medication abortion and should do so
have done so without an adequate
reflection and are incapable of making
reasoned moral decisions regarding their
health and their future
to be transparent it's cruel to tell
victims of rape or incest are those with
fetuses incompatible with life that they
need 24 hours to reconsider
there are no other regulations for other
procedures like this mandatory waiting
period
and I'll just finish by noting that a
vast majority of granite Staters support
safe and legal abortion
72 percent of gold Granite stators
identified as being pro-choice in 2022
and so as this polling makes clear
Granite Staters don't appreciate acts of
government overreach and intervention
into their private Health Care decisions
so I'd like to urge the committee to
vote itl on this Bill thank you
questions for this Witness
representative Greece
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your testimony I know the Acoustics in
this room are are bad but I was pretty
certain I just heard recently that
abortion providers typically do not
provide same-day procedures that they'll
have a an appointment and they'll have
it might even be Telehealth uh where
they can go through and explain the
procedures and all that kind of stuff
and then they'll have an appointment
that would come in so are they not then
themselves a barrier to access to
abortions that the 24-hour uh waiting
period is
really already happening anyway that
you're not actually adding any
additional time to what is already in
place
yeah thank you for your question I don't
want to speak on behalf of the medical
community but
um as I've said uh associations like the
ecog have encouraged uh eliminating
barriers to access to timely and safe
abortions and so I'll just leave with
that remark all right other questions to
this Witness
yes representative Perez yes you stated
72 of
um
individuals in New Hampshire are
pro-choice can you just tell me where
you got that where you obtained that
information from uh yeah that is from
the Saint Anselm uh polling
it's my understanding that Saint
Anselm's polling was not if they were
pro-choice but if they were in favor of
either pro-choice or
in favor of our present fetal Life
protection act so um it's my
understanding that it's not necessarily
that they are pro-choice
uh could I respond to that
I would think from my understanding
looking at the polling there are a
several different prompts that uh the
respondents answered and I believe
that's one of them but I can send you
what I was looking at
thank you other questions for this
Witness
right right I have one additional card
from Patty uh Mullen Ms Mullen Eddie
Muller
all right
oh well you've won yeah you can give it
to him that's fine yep absolutely
thank you
good afternoon
honorable committee members and thank
you for taking the time to hear my
testimony
my name is Patty Mullen I'm a resident
of Sunapee New Hampshire well can I just
ask do you think you'd get a little bit
closer to the Mike I'm a president or
son of P New Hampshire I moved from New
York 40 years ago and never looked back
I love my state
I am here to oppose House Bill 6 562.
and I will explain why my mother had
four daughters
my sister Deirdre 18 months later she
gave birth to me
and seven years later she gave birth to
my twin sisters
my father was an alcoholic and a wife
abuser and he was also a travel and
salesman
three months after the Twins were born
my mother discovered that my father
married other woman while he was
traveling and at their birth he was a
three-time bigamist
at that point the few years after that
we found ourselves on welfare
we were homeless at one point and living
in the projects
mom remarried when I was 11. she married
a New York City fireman
and he had a shield
in New York firemen and policemen do not
call their badges badges they called
them Shields and there is a reason for
that
I do not say his name I refer to him at
all times as the evil one
he bought us a house
and he moved the five of us into a home
all of my other family aunts and uncles
thought what a wonderful man marrying my
mother and taking on her four daughters
the four of us spent the rest of our
childhoods being raped beaten
mentally
spiritually
intellectually abused
Kelly was raped at seven
and on occasion we would call the police
but he had a shield
and so we never had any safety
my sister Deirdre died from suicide this
past July
she was a brilliant woman
who raised three brilliant children
while she was raising them she managed
to go to Fordham University and get her
MSW with a 4.0 average
her children are Rhodes Scholars
Fulbright Scholars London School of
Business but she is gone
she started having memory issues at 62.
it turned out diatra had multiple
traumatic brain injuries
and the dementia was wrapped I'm you're
kind of over your time and I and I okay
so I'm gonna say that the reason why I
lived in fear when I found out I was
pregnant at 16 I told my sister Deirdre
I was two weeks late
when I was finally able to get an
abortion in New York it was before Roe v
Wade
I was 10 weeks pregnant
during that period there is nobody in
this room who could imagine the fear
that I lived in because that man would
have beat me to death
and I am not exaggerating the only
reason I am here the only reason I have
a beautiful young woman the only reason
I have one sister left
is because I had an abortion at 16. I
had bodily autonomy and it saved my life
literally
thank you for hearing my testimony thank
you ma'am questions for this Witness
seeing none right I don't have any other
cards is there anyone else who yes
thank you
Mr Hennessy I think you were not here
when I called uh when I called your name
but let's you can go ahead and testify
but my apologies Mr chair I had to
attend to some human needs and um
I I'm really impressed by you guys who
are able to stay here for so many hours
um
so my name is Jason Hennessey I'm here
to testify on behalf of New Hampshire
right to life New Hampshire's largest
pro-life organization
and
I'm here to testify in favor of HP 562.
according to the Journal of uh an
article published in the Journal of
Americans uh Physicians and surgeons
it was found that nearly three quarters
of women with the history of abortion
surveyed surveyed
uh felt pressure to terminate their
pregnancies
in that same survey about 60 percent
decided to abort in order to make others
happy
so I have the question to ask you guys
here if you're a pro-choice
don't you want the mother to have uh all
the information she needs to make her
choice
that's all that this bill would do
uh this this bill would give the mother
information on Services if she does in
case she doesn't know about them that
she could obtain
it would be based on the latest science
and developed by our Department of
Health and Human Services and it would
give patients access to the most
possible info and give them a little bit
of time to think about it before uh
doing this and and I know that there are
Ministries out there that help women to
heal from past abortions there's many
who regret it and this would give people
an opportunity to reflect on that and
that's my testimony thank you Mr chair
thank you uh questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much sir and
I
well yes no I know uh Miss Woods uh you
I know you have a card and then so
please we want to hear from you
thank you Mr chair and my apologies for
being out of the room at the time he
called my name
my name is Phyllis woods from Dover and
again we're looking at one of those
perennial bills that has been to my
knowledge at least over the last 20
years that we have been trying to get
through but a lot has changed
we all see ads today on TV for drugs
that after stating the benefits they
talk about a list of potential side
effects and risks that make it seem very
dangerous to take the drugs if we really
care about women why would we want to
deny someone facing an unplanned or
unexpected pregnancy who is
contemplating taking the chemical
abortion pill full disclosure and
information on the extent of the
expected possible side effects of these
drugs do we not want to empower women to
make informed Decisions by providing
them with critical information and
knowledge so they can make wise and
prudent decisions regarding their
pregnancy now we know there are a lot of
side effects of taking the abortion pill
of the chemical abortion pill and
recently of four National medical
associations and four doctors
experiencing caring for pregnant and
post-abortion women have filed a brief
in federal court that pushes back on the
Food and Drug administration's arguments
against withdrawing or suspending its
approval of chemical abortion drugs that
harm women and girls by illegally
approving dangerous chemical abortion
drugs the FDA Port women and girls In
Harm's Way and these doctors represent
those who are seeking to protect women
from the documented dangers of chemical
abortions we know that
um
we've heard several cases where there
have been
unintended consequences not only
physical but even to death we've heard
of a 19 year old in Canada who died of
septic shock after thing is we do have
this abortion reversal pill and if women
could know about that they could Avail
themselves there have been documented
for 4 000 plus babies that have actually
been born after one took the abortion
reversal pill after taking the first
pill
so there is a potential there for women
to be able to change their mind one of
the women that I spoke to recently just
left being on the abortion reversal pill
hotline where she's worked for several
years and has talked to hundreds of
women thousands and actually just as
some babies we've heard this morning do
survive on surgical abortion there have
been at least a couple of documented
cases where after taking both the first
and second chemical abortion pill the
babies did survive and went on to live
healthy lives so please support this
bill and just give necessary and
available information to women on what
the potential side effects are of these
drugs thank you Mr chair thank you
questions to this Witness
seeing none thank you all right is there
anyone else who wishes to testify on on
this bill house bill 562.
thank you I'm Brian Lewis from
Alexandria speaking on my own behalf
an earlier speaker one of the Bill's
sponsors was asked if he knew of any
other surgical procedures that required
24-hour informed consent and he did not
and I gave the topic some thought
and I don't either on the other hand I
don't know of any other surgical
procedures that are intended to
terminate life
given that this is so radically
different I don't think that 24-hour
Advanced consent is such an onerous
thing I support the bill all right
questions for this Witness
thank you very much anyone else who
wishes to testify
yes
thank you
chairman Lynn um I'm representative
Robert wary from Hudson I'm not a doctor
or nurse but I have 40 years in the
pharmaceutical biotech and medical
device Industries I have a master's in
pharmaceutical quality from the
University of strathclyde in Glasgow
Scotland as well as a master in
Regulatory Affairs for pharmaceutical
biotechnology medical device industries
from Northeastern University in Boston
I've overseen and worked with and
audited multiple contract research
organizations to understand whether
these companies are meeting compliance
requirements for informed consent and
that's the topic to which I wish to wish
to speak briefly today
scores are hundreds of clinical trials
are ongoing to study the safety and
efficacy of pharmaceuticals biological
products and medical devices almost all
of these Studies have an initial
screening visit during which inclusion
and exclusion criteria are explored and
typically the informed process consent
process is begun for those passing this
screening step
the informed consent process is often
repeated in subsequent visits as ongoing
cumulative study data is updated and to
confirm that the patient understands the
current risk benefit ratio so I say all
this to provide to the committee the
fact that 24-hour informed consent has
substantial precedent
in hundreds and hundreds of clinical
trials for
decades ever since the good clinical
practices were implemented by the FDA
and other agencies
so it has substantial precedent that is
the focus of my testimony today thank
you all right questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much is there
anyone else who wishes to testify on
House Bill 562.
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on how to build 562. and given
the hour and the fact that uh some of my
colleagues have wisely uh taken the
lunch recess and I'm going to do that
myself now but I'm going to open the
hearing on House Bill 591
prohibiting abortion after detection of
fetal heartbeat and I'm going to ask my
colleague representative Wallace if he
will uh
chair the hearing while for the brief
period of time that I'm going to do one
thank you
representative Testament
the floor is yours
thank you uh I'm not even sure what time
it is anymore uh
I come to you with a bill fairly simple
uh
591.
last year there was a bill that got
itself all bound up together it finally
passed it had to do with whether or not
we needed a a
ultrasound in the case to determine is
it 24 weeks is it 24 what whatever
and it it caused a lot of problems and
even today in the last couple of days
you can hear some discussions on it that
yeah if a ultrasound
causes a lot of concern on some people's
cases
I I thought about it and uh during the
off session
and I decided I was going to enter a
bill that maybe would simplify things it
basically says
if you can hear the heartbeat
that's enough
a person with a stethoscope that's got
it wired no need to worry about whether
it's a big an ultrasound machine or
whatever it is so that's all this bill
does is say the same thing as the one
previously had said that if you if you
want to have an abortion
and you can't hear the heartbeat
go ahead
if you can hear the heartbeat you have
to have you have to have some other
procedures it's a fairly simple bill
there's all sorts of yeah it takes a
page in half to say what essentially I
just said uh now
thank you
thank you any questions for
representative Testament
saying none thank you good
We Now call Representative sellers
uh good afternoon thank you chair thank
you committee members for hearing me out
again uh representative marcelo's
Grafton 18. uh this is the hot beat bill
and I did co-sponsor it
I do support it
I you could take you know right here you
can just
put your hand on your heart
just put you in your yard
if you're beating you're physically
alive
all right and that's all I think this
Bill is saying that that infant within
the womb is physically alive
all right and I use the word infant
because again I said that yesterday in
Latin means in fan infan which means
speechless uh one that's not able to
speak
and that's exactly what an infant is
before it actually
physically comes out of the woman
so it's still in the womb it's an infant
you can call it anything you want but I
think we're just lying to ourselves and
do you need to stop realizing the
deception that's been going on and it's
been going on for a lot of years and it
needs to stop
now
like a lot of men around here that have
wives
I can't tell my wife what to do and if I
do she she'll just look at me and walk
away anyways my point is no woman wants
to be told what to do and I agree as a
guy I don't want to be told what to do
we just went through a pandemic there a
pain down here and we were all told what
to do you know you know we're a mess
don't wear a mask go out can't go out
shop you can't go out I don't think any
one of us liked it
but Society
we have to look at that when it comes to
the woman in abortion in a fetal
heartbeat
just for an example we don't really know
the numbers of how many
abortions we do in New Hampshire
but the estimate that I had gotten
online of course it's online
everything's online this day
is I'm assuming they're actually taking
the numbers from other states and saying
dividing that by how many abortions they
do and look at the number of people we
have here in New Hampshire and they're
coming up with a number which I said
yesterday was about 2200.
2200 a year let's just use that number
for a second
10 years 22 000.
20 years 44 000. and I'd say forty four
thousand plus because by that time
they may be having children as well
we're destroying our next generation
where we wonder why we don't have any
students or our student population is
declining
is this one of the reasons why we have
to ask ourselves really is it one of the
reasons why would our student population
is declining
by allowing the devotion Yeah by
allowing abortions beyond the fetal
heartbeat
we're also destroying our next great
leaders our next great inventors
teachers Architects Statesman woman
bus driver plumber office cleaner
business owner Barista police fire EMT
mother and father
I mean think about it the list goes on
and on
we need to put
we need to come to reality and realize
that
we got to stop doing this and I think at
a fetal heartbeat you know when that
baby's heart starts beating
it's it's more than alive at that point
it's actually formed it's it's it's not
a blob it's not a fetus it's not embryo
it's it's actually you know at that
point
an infant I wear on my collar here right
here is the footprints or the actual
feet not Footprints this is the actual
feet of a 10 week old baby
all right at that point 10 weeks and I
think you've all maybe you've all might
have seen it
the actual it's it's about the size of
my thumb when it's about 10 weeks the
baby is
I think we all inherently know when Life
Starts I think sometimes we just want to
fool ourselves
I would think
the mother would gladly give up her
choice
to an abortion to protect her infant's
life
again I support HB 591
and I hope that the when this goes
forward
the Senate and the governor would
actually support it as well
and I just want to let you I just want
to say for you all here this this
committee it starts with you guys and it
starts with all of us out here as well
but it starts with you because you're
the ones that will take the vote up and
pass us on to the floor
and just think of it it'll be your names
someplace will be etched in history
either yay or nay on this bill
so I hope that you would do the right
thing
and realize life begins at the heartbeat
and I'm going to read one Bible verse
and then I'm finished
this is actually Psalms 139 1360.
it says For You O God created my inner
being you knitted you knit me together
in my mother's womb
I praise you because I am faithfully and
wonderfully made
your works are wonderful I know that
full well
your eyes saw my unformed body
unformed body
all the days
ordained for me were written in your
book before one of them came to be
God knows who we are before we came to
be this is written
almost 3 000 years ago are we going to
believe the stuff we're hearing the last
couple hundred years or less are we
going to believe something that's
written three thousand years ago thank
you
any questions
representative thank you for taking my
question
uh please speak up in the mic so I can
hear thank you oh you can't hear me oh
it's my ears it's not you it's me all
right sorry uh do you have any idea or
uh uh when the fetal heartbeat first
occurs
say that again do you have any idea of
when a fetal heartbeat first occurs so
my understanding it is around it is
around six weeks somewhere it could be
six seven eight weeks maybe up to ten
yes
always oh thank you
any further questions
see none we thank you without a call
thank you Holmes
and up next would be Ruby Furbish
neither one
good afternoon thank you for having me
here today
my name is Ruby Furbish I'm a high
school senior from Plymouth New
Hampshire and I'm president of a
pro-life club called voices for life
I'm here today on behalf of students for
Life action where gen Z and Millennials
like me
engage in the politics of abortion and
influence key elections to restrict and
abolish abortion state by state
together with its sister interview
students for life of America we work to
end abortion the human rights issue of
our time
and provide political legal and
community support for women and their
children born and pre-born
I come before this committee today as a
woman of New Hampshire to urge you to
support HB 591 the common sense bill
that takes early action to protect
pre-born babies once a heartbeat is
detected
in a life or death setting a sign of
life that your medical professionals
look for is a heartbeat
whether on the battlefield or in the
emergency room that standard applies
and yet with such undeniable assurance
that they are in fact alive pre-born
children in New Hampshire face death
daily
our current model fails and that it
allows the same people who would profit
off of the death of a child in the womb
to counsel a pregnant woman on whether
she should get an abortion
in such a delicate moment this allows
for a predatory abortion industry to
disregard her needs in favor of its own
Financial gains
this is a conflict of interest that
serves a billion Dollar corporate entity
and abandons women in a moment of need
a majority of women who have had
abortions in the United States have said
that they felt coerced into getting an
abortion
more access to abortion is not what my
generation demands students for Life
actions new polling found that less than
two out of 10 Millennials want unlimited
abortion through all nine months and
nearly half supported limits on abortion
after a heartbeat is detected
by a margin of 47 to 38 percent
our poll also found that 6 and 10
supported requiring doctors to check for
heartbeat before committing an abortion
we've been collecting signatures on our
digital petition and support for this
life-saving legislation and as a person
who stands for life I ask you today to
support HP 591 because women deserve
better than abortion and the voiceless
victim in every abortion deserves our
protection New Hampshire can and must do
better to protect its women and children
born and unborn
I ask you to vote to protect the lives
of all your constituents including those
in utero thank you for your time
any questions for this Witness
seeing none we thank you
uh we now call Curtis register
and up next will be Courtney Reed
good afternoon honorable members of the
Judiciary Committee my name is Curtis
register I'm a marine veteran a resident
of Durham New Hampshire uh and I speak
for myself though I wear a Planned
Parenthood shirt they don't pay me and I
don't get snacks
uh
I stand in steadfast hard
opposition HP 591
now I've been here for about a day and a
half
and I've heard of charge and passionate
Arguments for both sides of the issue
there's a lot of feelings that are
spewing about on this very real and very
complicated issue
Manger
sadness
and even righteousness
but I hope we can all agree
that feelings
and facts
different
and facts should drive decision making
and facts to drive legislation
and the fact is
that doctors across the globe
have consensus that abortion is a
necessary medical procedure and that
viability is a unique and moving Target
based on that individual pregnancy World
Health Organization American Medical
Association New Hampshire Medical
Society
the fact is the majority of New
Hampshire residents are in favor
of abortion protections Pew research
the fact is that banning abortions does
not save lives it disproportionately
devastates those without means
and those people of color
Amnesty International
human's Rights Watch World Health
Organization Planned Parenthood
you cannot claim to be both for
individual liberty and against bodily
autonomy
bodily autonomy is an essential form of
individual liberty and freedom in
general
the misinformation in callous propaganda
that hates Folks at a patent abortion
and those who support abortion as
Cavalier with human life
or even that they find some manner of
enjoyment
in this very deeply personal decision
is malicious
these accusations or concerns
are disingenuous propaganda
and are wrong
abortion has been protected safe and
legal in this country for almost 50
years and now it's gone
and your constituents are scared
there has been almost a universal
systemic and aggressive attack
on abortion rights across the country
and it continues with bills such as HP
best this bill is misguided and
offensive
at worst it is a naked attempt to
control women via Force birth which are
50 percent of the New Hampshire
demographics
U.S census 2020.
protect individual liberty
protect bodily autonomy protect freedom
show your constituents that you support
life
the lives of the residents that are here
and struggling and needy and begging
vote down HP 591
thank you
thank you any questions for this
awareness
saying none thank you and thank your
sidekick
Courtney Reed please
thank you representative Wallace I've
just passed around some materials
relating to this bill as well as 562 for
the committee to review my apologies
that I didn't hand that out earlier once
again I'm here on behalf of the American
civil liberties Union
to encourage the committee to oppose HB
591 and prevent obscene government
overreach into Granite seder's Private
health care decisions
HP 591 would prohibit abortions after
any embryonic cardiac activity is
detected which is usually at around six
weeks
exemptions include medical procedures
intended to prevent death or serious
risk of substantial and irreversible
impairment of a major bodily function
for performing such an abortion outside
of these extreme guidelines a physician
might be subject to loss of their
medical license or fines of up to three
thousand dollars
HP 591 would ban almost all new
abortions in New Hampshire
this bill would prohibit abortions as
early as six weeks into pregnancy before
most people even know they are pregnant
or have a health care decision to make
with the existing barriers we face this
bill would amount to a near total ban on
abortion for most people in New
Hampshire
this legislation places both medical
providers and their patients at risk
because when there is no clear Universal
definition of the point at which a
pregnant person's life becomes
endangered even when a physician is
certain that an abortion or another
medical Intervention which might pose a
threat to pregnancy is in the best
interest of the patient the risk of
prosecution will incentivize him waiting
to act until the patient's symptoms
become demonstrably life-threatening
the threat of a professional discipline
directly conflicts with a doctor's
ability to effectively treat a patient
needing Medical Care
the vast majority of grandstaters
support safe and legal abortion
so I'd like to conclude by noting that
the New Hampshire legislature should
rather focus on the pressing Health
needs of granite Staters
recent data has shown that New Hampshire
ranks last out of its New England
counterparts in the overall quality of
Health Care measured through cost
accessibility and health outcomes
further Research indicates that if
abortion was found Nationwide the
overall number of maternal deaths would
rise by 24 percent
legislators should recognize the
devastating impact of abortion bans on
health outcomes and vote inexpediate to
ledgerate legislate on this Bill thank
you
does anybody have any questions
seeing none thank you thank you we now
call Sandra Den on kerrer
and then up next will be Marianne
aliegro
Marianne II
just so you're in the queue
thank you hi thank you again
uh so for the record again I'm Sandra de
non-core I'm a registered nurse and the
executive director at the lovering
health center in Greenland
um I'll keep my testimony very short I
did submit it in writing out in the
lobby
um we have 42 years of experience
providing high quality health care that
includes abortion care
591 is Extreme and is out of touch with
the majority of granite seders houseboat
591 introduces a near total abortion ban
presents significantly equal questions
about the ability of medical providers
to care for pregnant patients without
being in violation of the law
we implore you to respect the rights of
bodily autonomy the right to private
medical decision making and the
professional Judgment of doctors caring
for New Hampshire citizens and I will
add that there are significant reasons
why abortions are not provided before
six weeks oh thank you yeah and I will
say there are important reasons why this
becomes a near total abortion ban while
we do receive phone calls from people
who are earlier gestation than six weeks
by estimation
there are important reasons why we don't
provide abortion Services before six
weeks and one is because it's medically
necessary for us to rule out the
possibility of ectopic pregnancy which
if treated as an intrauterine pregnancy
or pregnancy in the uterus could be very
dangerous and so if we're talking about
the detection of feudal heartbeat around
six weeks and we're talking about the
medical necessity to wait until six
weeks to preserve life and the safety of
our patients then we are talking about a
near total abortion ban which I know
most citizens in our state are not in
favor of thank you
any questions with this Witness
nope seeing none thank you
and we now call Marion aliegro
and up next will be
Omar
um thank you Mr chair and members of
members of the committee a little
nervous uh Marion eleg Roma career cell
and molecular biologist from Campton New
Hampshire
I thought I was coming here to represent
a lot of people at home but after
hearing a lot of all of this testimony
today I feel like I'm here to represent
cells
I'd like to ask everyone in the room to
please answer questions silently to
themselves why do we insist on closing
the East Coast beaches during piping
plover and sea turtle nesting and
gestation season
after all we're only talking about
disturbing a bunch of eggs on or under
the sand what's so precious about that
no doubt some of you are thinking that's
a silly question if we destroyed all the
eggs on our beaches there'll be no more
piping plovers or sea turtles and it's
our responsibility to protect them and
you would be right
as a scientist I would like to tell you
something about the Bunches of eggs on
or under our East Coast beaches each egg
contains a bunch of cells each started
with only two cells an egg and a sperm
the little Bunches of cells in each of
these eggs are very busy during
gestation
miraculously dividing and migrating and
joining and signaling
and separating and joining again and
eventually they develop into beautiful
little creatures that we call piping
clovers and sea turtles
as a mother
I'm here now to ask to implore you this
committee to wholeheartedly support I'll
spill
hb591 Dash FN as well as the other
pro-life bills today
by supporting these legislation New
Hampshire can help to protect the
beautiful and miraculous Bunches of
cells who beginning with just two an egg
and of sperm grow divide communicate
join rejoin and develop in their
mother's wombs into our precious little
boys and girls
after all it's our responsibility to
protect them too
I will quote a little here the Lord
spoke to the Prophet Jeremiah in
Jeremiah book one again thousands of
years old and he said
before I formed thee in the bowels of my
mother I knew thee and before thou
camest out of the womb I Sanctified thee
our precious children are specific gifts
from God
not random cell clusters
please don't make New Hampshire a die
before you get a chance to live state
please support these pro-life bills
thank you very much for your time
foreign
please
and then we'll be Caleb Montgomery
thank you Mr acting chairman and thank
you members of the committee
again my name is Omar Ahern Jr from
Wentworth Grafton County New Hampshire
and I think you've got a pretty good
idea where I stand on all of these bills
I live
and operate
in the real world
the world of reality I deal with
people
in all
situations in life
the reality that we are in today
in our great United States of America
is that we are still deciding
what is to happen
to real viable living
infant
infants
human beings
again
life
begins at conception
and it ends at natural death
I'm echoing some of the things that
representative sellers said and that Mrs
Allegro just said
I urge you to support
House Bill
591 FN I support it because it is to
protect life at its very vulnerable
position in its be in its life and it's
growing
so
again I ask you to support house bill
591--f-n
because it gets the great state of New
Hampshire
that much closer to the true
and honest reality
that human life begins at conception and
ends at natural death
please support HB 591 Dash FN has ought
to pass thank you very much
questions
any questions 401
well seeing none thank you thank you and
thank you for all your work folks
Kayla Montgomery
good afternoon again members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Kayla Montgomery representing Planned
Parenthood
speak a little closer there you go
um I I recognize it's been a long two
days
um
long two days and on behalf of Planned
Parenthood I just want to say thank you
all um everyone here has felt seen and
heard with their testimony today and
yesterday and we really appreciate it
um in regards to House Bill 591 we
oppose this bill because it is a near
total ban on abortion when I say near
total
I mean because it bans abortion around
six weeks of pregnancy which is before
many people even know that they are
pregnant so
it removes someone's ability to make a
decision about their pregnancy before
they even know that they have a decision
to make
this bill has been before this committee
many many times before I have testified
in opposition before this committee many
many times before what is different
today of course is that this bill is no
longer unconstitutional
but what is not different today is that
this bill is still deeply deeply
unpopular and is bad public policy and
you should oppose this Bill thank you
any questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you
Danielle Pimentel
thank you Mr chairman or Mr Vice
chairman and members of the committee I
also want to thank you so much for
allowing all of us to give testimony
over these past two days I know it's
been a long two days so thank you for
your endurance and your consideration
um I my name is Daniel Pimentel and I
work with American United for life and I
urge your support of HB 591 for three
reasons and first the bill protects the
health and safety of pregnant women and
pre-born children which is a legitimate
interest for New Hampshire in the Dobbs
decision the Supreme Court stated that
the that states have a legitimate
interest in preserving prenatal life
protecting maternal health and safety
and mitigating fetal pain
however New Hampshire allows abortions
up to 24 weeks gestation and as we all
know there has been legislation put
forth to allow abortion on demand up
until birth
which subjects women and children to
pre-on board children to um threatening
health risks and possibly death and
these include for the women blood clots
hemorrhages incomplete abortions damage
to internal organs
Etc and for pre-born children scientists
have found evidence of unborn children
feeling pain as early as 12 weeks
gestation
so by enacting this bill the legislature
is protecting unborn children while also
greatly reducing the risks women face
when seeking an abortion and as I said
before that is in New Hampshire's
legitimate interest to do so
the second thing I want to mention is
that the common narrative that we often
hear is that abortion or abortion access
is necessary for Women's Health and for
their quality in American society and
that's simply not true
um the data shows that the rate of
abortions is the current rate is nearly
half of what it was in the late 1980s
after Roe v Wade was decided so the
evidence of that is showing that women
are increasingly rejecting abortion
they're recognizing the humanity of
their unborn children and they are
taking advantage of the resources that
are available to them to either carry
the baby and to term or give up their
baby for adoption
Pregnancy Resource Centers
um also play a major part in empowering
women and giving them the resources that
they need to choose life and in New
Hampshire there are many wonderful
Pregnancy Resource Centers that stand
ready to assist women if this bill is
passed and these Pregnancy Resource
Centers offer free resources counseling
and material support
ultimately women deserve better than
abortion they deserve better than to be
subjected to abortion procedures that
threaten their lives that threaten their
their bodies all of that
and this bill recognizes that by
enacting limits that will protect women
as well as promote maternal health and
Fetal life
the last thing I want to mention is we
heard testimony that this is not a
popular thing this kind of legislation
that's not true either after the Supreme
Court overturned Roe v Wade and Planned
Parenthood um bkc there are many states
that have enacted strong pro-life limits
stronger than a heartbeat Bill there are
at least 18 states that have enacted
um life or laws in which they ban
abortion at any gestational age so from
conception and there are at least three
other states that do have bills which
ban abortion after a heartbeat is
detected a fetal heartbeat is detected
and so New Hampshire would be joining
these states and affirming
um their legitimate interest to protect
the state's most vulnerable citizens and
for these reasons I urge the committee
to support HB 5191 and I thank you again
so much for allowing me to testify here
these past few days
any questions for this Witness
seeing none we thank you thank you very
much and I'll call Patty Mullen
hello again
I'm not going to put you through the
story again you've heard it two days in
a row
you know that my life was horrible
um and I'm here to strongly oppose HB
my abortion saved my life
I found out I was pregnant at eight
weeks
and scheduled an abortion my sister
Deirdre who is no longer with us
took me to get it
I had to wait an additional two weeks
after I had the urine test
so by then I was 10 weeks pregnant
my sister tried to protect us
she saved my life when I was 16.
when we found when we found out I was
pregnant Deirdre said to me
Jesus Christ Patty if he finds out
you're pregnant he's going to beat you
to death
I've heard a lot of talk the last two
days about bodily autonomy
and freedom
and protection of The Unborn
nobody was protecting me at 16.
that abortion
kept me from being literally beaten to
death
and since you've all heard this story
you know that it's true
to take away
my bodily autonomy to take away my
daughters Reproductive Rights
to take away our freedom
is horrific
I never experienced bodily autonomy
until I was 16.
I didn't know about freedom
and so as you're all here considering
the fetal heartbeat
think about my heartbeat
at 16. think about my heartbeat
terrified that I would be beaten to
death
think about my heartbeat today with a
daughter
think about my heartbeat with my dead
sister
who's died from his beatings
do not think that everybody has the same
story we don't run off to clinics to
have abortions it is a horrible
difficult decision
but it saved my life
and I urge you so strongly as does the
majority of this country
to not pass or even consider this bill
this bill will not save lives this bill
will destroy lives it will kill women
and it will be an ultimate disaster you
will be seeing hangers used again I
oppose this bill and I thank you for
listening to my story
thank you
we'll Now call Kathy Holmes
you're up
hello
uh Kathy Holmes
and we all agree we're talking about
life
unborn life this committee also handles
the gun bills
well imagine what talking points the
left would have if they could say 63
million babies have been killed by guns
now
uh
I think how lopsided the left's energies
are being spent
they ignore the science of today
and they're stuck 50 years ago when we
really didn't know but now we do
and in all this conversation
I have to ask why aren't we hearing
about the women's
each person's responsibility for their
own body and the choices they make
like my husband says pro-choice before
the ACT not the fact there is no no
weight put on how you got in that
position you you know what the what
could happen
and that then now the problems the
consequences are put on us to be feel
guilty for the consequences
uh and
and I know girls
are misled well uh so
that's another problem but that's not
what we're talking about right now
I think that's
that that covers it
any questions
saying none we thank you Jason Hennessy
thank you Mr acting chair my name is
Jason Hennessey as you've probably heard
a few times over the last two days
president of New Hampshire to life and
I'm here to represent the pro-life
constituents of New Hampshire
we support HB 591
we all support I mean most most people
support bodily autonomy across New
Hampshire where the live for your days
or Live Free or Die state
uh but the question here is is there a
second person and and we have many laws
that involve when you're when your
autonomy comes in contact with somebody
else's autonomy and that's what we're
here to talk about
the second person this unborn child this
unborn child cannot scream for help
cannot run away and cannot hit back
so who is more innocent than that who is
more worthy of our protection as a
society
so the question is who is a person
and what rights do people deserve
so that's the question that we need to
struggle with here is
who is an under for an unborn child
what rights do they deserve
many many of the center of our greatest
uh the greatest atrocities that we can
think of just even in the last century
center around who is a person
and what rights did they get or what
rights were they deprived of
from a practical perspective
New Hampshire is lacking children we're
one of the oldest states in the country
if not the oldest
you know imagine imagine the children
that we need to just even to function
our school enrollments are shrinking who
are going to be our next generation of
leaders
you know some the some of the thousands
of children that lose their lives to
abortion every year those could have
been some of our greatest leaders
and there's many there's many supports
for women
um who find themselves with an unplanned
pregnancy
we have New Hampshire's Safe Haven law
which means nobody is required to raise
a child that you didn't sign up to do
anybody can drop off their child within
the first seven days of life no
questions asked
we also have at least 15 pregnancy
centers
who stand by with counseling parenting
classes mentors and tangible helps like
strollers and diapers
and they're there to come alongside and
to provide help and they do it as far as
I know completely free of charge
I ask you to support HP 591 thank you
any questions for this Witness
representative Morgan
um I just
would you believe of a very small point
but I'll get a question out of there too
you mentioned uh we're actually we are
the second oldest state in the country
or average age is 43.1 the
and we're right ahead of Vermont 43
where I had made 45.0 and but I don't
and I had I was doing another bill about
it but do you feel is that like even we
maybe need more of a solution than just
like forcing women
to give birth to babies they don't want
to go to and um
and uh so
do you think this bill will be helpful
or harmful or helpful for trying to get
women of childbearing age to move here
instead of to some other state
uh thank you for your question
representative uh one one response I'll
have is that the these states that have
probably the most children per capita
are also the states that have very
strong pro-life laws
any further questions for this Witness
singing on we thank you thank you I have
no more pink cards is there anybody else
in the room that would like to speak the
house bill 591 FN
thank you
go ahead Josie
all right as others before me have said
thank you all so much for your
commitment to hearing us all these last
few days really appreciate
the spirit you've all brought
um all right
so
good afternoon I'm testifying in strong
opposition today against HB 591
I hope that it's clear that this ban
would be a near total abortion ban if
passed at six weeks gestation many
pregnant people don't even know that
they're pregnant yet this bill would
absolutely Force the majority if not all
patients to travel out of state for care
that would put an incredible strain on
the organization that I run as we help
these patients pay for all kinds of
increased costs such as travel hotel
rooms in addition to the abortion itself
since the fall of row nearly half of our
country has already banned the right to
abortion leaving patients with no other
option but to travel incredibly far
distances to receive care
for some the hurdles of getting care are
now too high
since June my organization has had to
help patients from 26 other states
access care and I truly cannot imagine
the consequences for abortion Seekers if
abortion funds did not exist
we've heard tragic stories of 12 year
olds being denied care people facing
medical bills upwards of fifteen
thousand dollars being denied insurance
coverage just really tough situations
that no one deserves to find themselves
in
I believe that no one should be forced
to carry a pregnancy to term against
their will
as it can come with extreme medical
consequences as we've heard from others
testifying earlier today
right now the states where abortion is
legal are holding a lot as they work to
accommodate increase increased needs
from those traveling from other states
to access care if New Hampshire is to
also become one of the states that bans
abortion care it will put an unfair
increased burden on the states
surrounding us that have already
affirmed abortion rights this bill as
proposed is Extreme and out of touch
with the majority of granite saters who
support access to abortion we cannot let
this extreme bill pass I urge you all to
vote against HB 591 thank you
are there any questions for this Witness
yes representative Perez
thank you
um
are abortions after 15 weeks do you have
to send them out of state
not 15 weeks because the current law
goes to 24 weeks no no but are they
actually performed here in New Hampshire
yes we typically send patients to
Dartmouth hospital
um but often they do go to Boston
so it depends which is closer to the
patient thank you
any further questions for this this
Witness
thank you for your time thank you
We Now call Clarissa Wankel
hi everyone thank you for giving me the
opportunity to speak today I wasn't sure
if I was going to but my name is
Clarissa Wankel and I'm a first year MSW
student at the University of New
Hampshire and I'm a crisis counselor for
the National Suicide Prevention lifeline
suicide among women of reproductive age
is high it's the second leading cause of
death among women ages 20 to 24 and I
just ask him could you just get a little
closer to the microphone so we can hear
it thank you
suicide is the second leading cause of
death among women ages 20 to 24 and it's
the third leading cause of death among
women ages 25 to 34. when researchers at
UPenn analyzed the data they found a
significant increase in suicide deaths
and states where access to abortion was
restricted by law which translates to
roughly 125 more suicides per year
amongst this population
as a crisis counselor I heal calls from
across the nation and I have noticed the
increase in callers who feel like they
have no choice but to kill themselves
because they do not have access to
abortion
if they fear that they can't get an
abortion their lives will be ruined I've
spoken to women experiencing domestic
violence who are worried their partner
will kill them or their child once they
are born
I've spoken to young women who do not
have the financial resources or family
support to raise a child
and I have heard from women who have
been sexually assaulted and don't know
how to continue on with the trauma of
being forced to carry a child a term
what I'm asking is that you protect the
mental health of young women by striking
down this bill
thank you questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much
I'm persistent
our next Bills but these are all 591 too
I'll use these ones you already went
through oh oh I'm sorry so is there
anyone else wishing to testify on House
Bill 591.
right oh my God all right seeing none um
we are going to recess uh now and we
will take up uh
the uh last bill we have for hearing uh
Southfield 252 at 3 P.M so we're in
recess until 3 pm
foreign
thank you
suitcases of those
good this other day
foreign
it's 3 P.M
um
and I'm going to call the house
Judiciary Committee back to order
uh for the purpose of hearing house bill
652 FN and I would call on the prime
sponsor uh representative uh Catherine
prudhome O'Brien representative O'Brien
thank you very much and now for a
completely different topic right
Okay so
uh the reason that I thought this
legislation was needed was a specific
situation that happened in my community
that happens in other communities and I
wanted to work to fix that
I had a situation I should be begin with
I am a former Library trustee I spent
two terms as a library trustee
and we had a situation where an event
was planned at the library it was
controversial
I made a comment such as
did the trustees talk about this they
should have talked about it and then the
public would have more information
and
I guess that made some people unhappy
that I thought the trustees and the um
the community and the library directors
should should discuss the the matter the
library director she was quite new she
made the decision to create an event on
her own
and there was just a lot of a lot of
confusion and a lot of
um conversation in the community over it
um I have a friend and she's here today
she's she was a library trustee at that
library at the time and she didn't have
information about it and was getting
constituent contacts about it
the library stopped answering their
phone and
we both went over there to find out what
was happening
um I went because my friend had surgery
and couldn't get in the building because
it's not ADA Compliant she had knee
surgery and couldn't get up the steps
without someone behind her to help
we walked into the library and the first
thing that the library director said to
us before we said anything was
I have made the decision to cancel the
event
is that okay that's that's good to know
and then we talked about the event a
little bit
um and any person in most most libraries
in this state have a policy that any
person in the community is welcome to
come in and talk to the library
Personnel the director about issues they
care about have concerns about if that's
the case for any person in the community
it's certainly the case for a library
trustee I think this should go without
saying well there was a person
um
on the Town Council who disagreed with
that and he went to the next Library
trustee meeting where the library
director said right at that meeting
that she had made the decision to cancel
the event on her own that was her
decision she was concerned about safety
and he knew that but then at the next
town council meeting he went they went
into non-public session and
my guess is that he may have made
misrepresented the the uh what the
library director said or didn't tell the
other counselors that that's what
happened they voted to open an
investigation and hire a law firm to
spend taxpayer money to do an
investigation about any labor laws being
being uh violated I was out of state on
a on a family emergency when I got a
phone call about that from the law firm
and I said to the man at the law firm
just go watch the town council meeting
where I try to explain things because it
seemed like there was some intentional
misinterpretation of what I was saying
which was not very much really
um
and
I was saying the same thing over again
to the library trustees when they had an
interest in it and I went to that
meeting as well as I was saying the
exact same story over and over again so
I said just go get the minutes from the
library trustee go watch the video from
the town council meeting there were no
labor law violations anyone can talk to
library directors about about that the
the
um events that they plan at the library
so
I knew that not nothing would come of
this I spent time on the on the um
on the Labor Commission prior to my time
on the election law commission where I
serve now
and before that I was working in
Industry I think I from the last time I
talked I told you I was a machinist and
I had worked in Industry so I couldn't
see anything happen coming from this and
nothing did come of it a few months
later I was thinking about how much did
that cost
and I did a a 91a request of the
um
information from Our Town Administrator
and it was about fifty five hundred
dollars one thing he mentioned to me
which I
didn't sit well with me I'll say because
it seemed to be a message he said he
told me what the cost of the legal
investigation was but then he added that
it cost the town fifteen hundred dollars
to comply with the 91a request that I
made to find out how much this cost the
town so in total about fifty five
hundred dollars
and
that I would I would say that was um
something that could have been stopped
immediately if they had said we are
investigating the library trustee and
the library trustee could have come to
that meeting and said
reminded the person who maybe had the
wrong idea you know that's a generous
way to phrase it maybe reminded that man
that the library director canceled the
program on her own and maybe the other
uh Town Council Members did not have
that information because that you know
they're busy they can't go to Every
meeting in town and I don't think that
all any of the other ones were at the or
maybe one was was at the library trustee
uh meeting where that was said where the
director said I have chosen to cancel
the event on my own
she was not bullied she was not forced
there were no labor law violations okay
that so that could have
stopped at that point and we wouldn't
have had to waste the town funds
taxpayer funds on that
and I think it's fair that someone have
the opportunity to be there and say such
important factual things if they are
going to be investigated
and uh
I have some other
things
um well you did get this this paperwork
but I will
um read it for you as well
the current 91a law does not include a
requirement to notify a person who will
be discussed during a non-public session
a 48-hour notification requirement
allows time for the notification to be
delivered to the person so that they
could decide to waive their right to
attend attend with or without counsel or
have the issue go to public meeting
by denying a person's right to attend a
non-public session when they will be the
subject of discussion it does not live
up to the purpose of the 91a law giving
transparency to the person being
discussed especially when minutes are
sealed
it gives a clear law to boards and
committees that they must follow during
their non-public procedures this bill is
fair necessary and reasonable for the
municipalities and more importantly the
person being discussed in non-public
sessions and their right to know costs
would be minimal or may save the
taxpayer money if the result of a
non-public meeting didn't result in
unnecessary investigations
non-public meetings may or may not take
longer to end but the benefit is to the
persons who are notified to attend under
the addition of the 91a law this law
would not affect emergencies because
administrators have the authority to
make immediate decisions during an
emergency in between board meetings I
ask you move uh okay so there's that so
foreign
so if that had been the situation in our
community
that would have saved money there may be
some talk that you may hear some other
talk that this will cost money
it's it's a notification it's a stamp
it's a it's a half hour of work maybe
for an administrative assistant it's the
costs are not too much okay and
I'll answer any questions if I can all
right questions for this Witness
yes representative greeson
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative I'm uh just a little
clarification on the language and the
bill that says that the
the person whose reputation may be
adversely affected shall be notified in
writing at least 48 hours prior to the
non-public session provided that
notifications may be waived upon written
agreement of the parties and I'm I'm
wondering
how do you wave who's waving the
notification and where is this written
agreement of the parties which parties
that's just a little bit confusing to me
and it may just be post
testimony syndrome
okay I think that would apply to the
person who receives the letter that they
if they wanted to waive it they could
just
write in saying I wave my
I don't care to attend
yeah are there other questions for this
week representative Horton
maybe I'll have to go back and
see the YouTube stream because I think I
missed the first couple of minutes here
testimony but what was the nature who's
offended the library what was his whole
underlying controversy about if if
that's a fair question
I'm sorry I sometimes have some a hard
time hearing what was the whole
underlying controversy about and what
was the event in question the
controversy is actually quite secondary
to this issue but it was pretty much the
only controversy that you hear about
with libraries recently and that would
be uh drag performer story times and
that was controversial in my community
other questions for this witness
um I could see potentially if
I can see potentially if there was a
drag queen Story Hour that both the dry
queens and whoever objected the drag
communities can both feel good is there
okay maybe that's not fair but what do
you do in a situation where
both parties in the dispute feel that
their uh reputations are being sullied
because
there was only one
person that was well two people that
would be the library trustee and myself
that would have been discussed during
non-public session I assume because we
were the only ones that got the phone
calls asking us for information about it
is I presume but
sure I suppose but they have the right
to speak publicly on that and discuss it
if they want to but they were not
investigated by the Town Council
other questions for this Witness
yes representative
yep thanks Mr chairman and thanks again
uh presenting
um
I guess I'm wondering rather than just
the notification requirement which is
sort of what I think you had focused on
I guess one of the questions is the
concept of bringing in counsel to
represent the individual in
um what I understand and again excuse me
for not knowing everything about how
non-public session Works
um deliberation of a board you know for
their own decision-making process rather
than sort of a what I wonder might seem
more like you know a trial
sure it's not a trial uh but I I recall
the first time that I was ever asked to
be on National Television I was nervous
and I asked someone who was a lawyer to
to come with me
it just made me more comfortable to be
able to
look at them to communicate with them to
ask questions if necessary as the
process unfolded and that may be the
same for someone else who even though
this is not being being interviewed in
the media this may be something that
makes them it would make them much more
comfortable to have
legal counsel there can ask one quick
follow-up yeah
do you get the sense that that would
perhaps necessitate the town to then
bring in their Town Council
um but in order to be uneven footing if
if there's going to be sort of a legal
component
some Town counselors May interpret it
that way and that's for them to
interpret that's that's for them
are there questions for this Witness
so I guess I have a question um I'm
concerned so suppose that this is the
situation
that the sport of Selectmen is planning
to hold a meeting tonight let's just say
hypothetically the border selectment is
holding a meeting tonight
someone in the planning department
um wants to come in
uh to the board of Selectmen uh because
that person is concerned that
his boss or her boss the head of the
planning department has been stealing
money from the town
uh and the board wants to go into
executive session
to to get some information about that
you would seem to be saying that the
board would have to notify
what arguably would be the target of the
investigation that the person is being
investigated is that because I could see
a lot of problems with doing it
I think if you're the target of such
investigation you either know it or you
want to defend that that's not the case
there are two options to that it's
either true and you're aware of it or
you're being falsely charged with that
and you would like to say something
about that you may have more information
to add at that time that you would like
to do well sure but I mean and certainly
I would agree with you at some point I
mean if the person is going to be
charged or going to be fired or
something like that sure that person I
agree would but this seems to say
anytime so that would I mean that would
mean
that
you could have to disclose information
that would allow
the Target in my hypothetical to do
something to cover up or whatever or uh
you know that so why why would that make
sense
I haven't been involved in a lot of
those sorts of situations but just a few
and when that was the case uh the par
the the target of that investigation
knew
and new because in a small environment
they they know and it was either I don't
recall what the what the outcome was
because I left that board but it was
either true or not true and I I
think that people have a right to say
something about it
okay so let me just give I'm just I'm
because I'm I'm very concerned about
this so let's suppose in my hypothetical
the the planning board employee goes to
the selectman's meeting and says
tomorrow night
I have information that the director of
the planning department is going to meet
with developer X
and developer X is going to give
the the director of the planning
department
fifty thousand dollars in the hopes that
the planning department will approve uh
the development that this developer has
before the planning department
um what do I do Mr selectman about this
under your bill you would say that
they could not have that meeting in
private they would have to they'd have
to notify the planning director by the
way
um we you know there's going to be claim
that you're getting a bribe tomorrow
night uh
obviously what you know that's that's
the end of of any evidence of that
happen so how does that that's what
concerns me okay thank you
yes representative Perez
don't be pretty I'm sorry can you turn
up your
thank you sorry
to clarify I do not believe that that
situation would happen in the fact that
I know it's not part of the process I
know in my town the any complaint like
that needs to first go to the town
manager and then the town manager once
verified or investigated or whatever he
would do would then bring it to the Town
Council so I think a step is missing in
trying to do that
um so that I don't think that type of
thing would happen under these
circumstances I think that's the same
process that you have in your town with
the town manager so
that is not something that I have a
tremendous amount of experience with so
I
I mean I guess thank you for the
question I I guess the thing that I'm
concerned about is this seems to say
that there can be no if you're going to
be
talking about something that adversely
affects someone
under all circumstances you have to let
the person know and it just seems to me
that that's awfully broad because I can
imagine a number of circumstances in
which it would be appropriate for
Boards of various kinds to be talking
about
something that would adversely affect
someone that if you told that person
about it it would undermine important
objectives
that you know that that the board could
pursue okay
one of the things that also happened in
this case
was um
at the Town council meeting when I
explained my my side of the story
and when it was it was quite
controversial
was I explained my side of the story
and after that the town counselor said
that he was going to be exploring legal
ways that the town could address the
issue and I just thought I don't know
what he's talking about what it what
what issue there's nothing that would
need any legal
work to address and I didn't think much
of it beyond that until I got the phone
call from the legal firm investigating
other questions for this Witness
saying none thank you very much next I'm
going to call on Lorraine uh lindenberg
right
uh thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the committee I'm Lorraine
lindenberg from Derry I'm also a member
of right to know New Hampshire
and I am in support of HB
652 FN I believe
the purpose of the 91a law is the to
provide transparency in our government
to the people of New Hampshire
the current 91a law has no mandatory
requirement but notifying an individual
within a period of time
to the of the person who's going to be
discussing in that public session
the 48-hour required notification would
allow the individual or employee enough
time to decide if they want to attend
with or without counsel waive their
right to attend or have their uh
discussion in open public session
if the public body does not notify an
individual or gives a little time to
attend and prepare it denies that
individual their right to attend to hear
what's being discussed about them and to
advocate for themselves
I was not notified to attend a
non-public meeting where I was the
subject of discussion and the reputation
of an employee was falsely used
even though the employee was never the
subject of the discussion
the employee was not notified either
counselors only needed a simple majority
to do a town investigation against me
if I had had the right to attend that
meeting or the employee had been
notified to attend
that child investigation would never
have been approved and the waste of
almost six thousand dollars of taxpayer
money would never have been spent
because there is no law requiring boards
and Company committees to notify people
who will be the topic of discussion
during public meetings my town and I'm
sure other towns Villages and cities
have not notified to individuals who are
subject of the non-public meetings
non-public meetings may take a little
longer
but isn't it worse
the time if a person being discussed has
the right to attend
hear what's being said about them
decisions that are being made about them
and be able to advocate for themselves
the costs to municipalities would be
minimal but the benefits of the public
would be enormous
if this bill is passing to law it might
even save the taxpayers money like it
would have in my case
that
across the taxpayers almost six thousand
dollars for a town investigation that
should never have happened and wouldn't
have happened had I been there to
advocate for myself
HB 652 is fair necessary and reasonable
to the people of New Hampshire for
transparency in their government
HB 652
if passed it's a law will provide a
clear law to our public bodies and
committees pertaining to the
notification requirements and it will
protect the Public's right to hear what
is being discussed about them behind
closed doors and they can advocate for
themselves I ask you to move HB 652 FN
to the Full House and recommend ought to
pass questions for this Witness
yes representative Smith
thank you very much for your testimony
it was quite clear
um there's just one little question I
have are you here speaking for yourself
or for the right to know I can't hear
you are you here speaking for yourself
or for right to know
I am speaking for myself as a victim of
not being notified thank you very much
your testimony was very clear thank you
so much other questions for this Witness
yes representative D Lorenzo
thank you Mr chair
with Miss lindenberry
hi I'm sorry uh thank you Mr Sharon
thank you for taking my question Miss
Lyndon Barry so in what capacity were
you I still can't hear you in what
capacity are you involved with the town
of Derry for you an employee or was it
as um a citizen I was a library trustee
at the time
oh okay thank you
thank you very much other questions for
this Witness
seeing none thank you very much a next
call on Phil Giro
thank you for hearing me
I was prevented from attending a closed
session matter of fact I was arrested
and prevented can you hear me
okay can you hear me that's it thank you
okay so I was arrested and prevented
from uh attending a closed session and I
was told by the chief of police this is
small town politics
okay and after that happened I spent two
years in the law library the New
Hampshire Supreme Court Law Library
studying law meeting Supreme Court
rulings I found a lot of good wisdom in
those things
and in that time I also sat there
and I was able to hear Joseph
or Justice Joseph NATO when he came back
from Iraq helping them write the
Constitution and his remarks there was
the people in Iraq look at judges as
Saints because they are the only thing
between an oppressive government
and the people
and Justin Dugan sat there with his head
proud
and they do deserve that proudness I do
say the same thing for lawmakers
I mean we're not as Extreme as Iraq with
a person has a chance of being killed if
they oppose the dictator
but you are spending a lot of your time
you listen a lot of these testimonies
I've sat here with you by yourself the
last couple days I mean there's a lot of
issues here it affects us
so with that
I want you know that's why I
complimented you Justin Lynn and I'd
like to answer your question also
because it was a good point
in my testimony
supre versus bulldog
the courts had cleared clearly stated
that the zba or the Zoning Board of
adjustments is acting a quasi-judicial
role so in that particular case as you
were presenting your honor that if a
person suspects somebody of accepting a
bribe
well they should be contacting law
enforcement so they can investigate and
catch the person
number two if they have evidence that
this has happened well then they should
be writing a form submitting it to the
person which is regular judicial
procedures then they can present that
complaint to the person and then both
parties can come to the meeting that's
why you would want notice so now he can
defend himself
and so I hope that the economy answers
your question because you're kind of
running into the quasi-judicial area on
which procedural rules you should be
following in those cases
the other thing is I'd like to say is
the people you know or I've been told by
Representatives
that this statue doesn't need to be
clear or clarified it's very
straightforward
while if you believe that the Supreme
Court rulings are based on facts and
wisdom
well then I suggest you read Mobile
versus Town Bridgewater because right in
there just before Johnson after Johnson
versus Nash was decided they did turn
around and say up to that point it
wasn't clear among the miss fidelities
and at this point section c still has
the same rewardings
now I'd also like to say
I've sued in the courts
and I've asked for meetings those
meeting minutes that was about me
and they told the courts because the
town told me oh well we're unprep we
don't know if they're prepared
now that raises the question why didn't
they know they were prepared and I
raised that question in the courts
okay
now the attorney himself
turned around
and he said well no we found him now
here you go you know but we request the
court to seal them and now I'm saying by
doing this it's making clear that we
have a right to attend to defend
ourselves because you don't know how it
feels to be in a court after reading the
Supreme Court rulings and now being
forced to basically defend yourself
against a grand jury indictment that you
can't even read
and then you're being requested by the
Supreme Court to turn around and take
these courts these these meaning minutes
that you cannot see because they're
sealed and you're supposed to submit
them who wants to submit a grand jury
indictment they cannot see to a court so
they can decide a case that you can't
not defend yourself against because this
is what happened and I exploded the
docket number if you want to look it up
because during that time
okay I'll calm down
during that time
just for me to see supposedly I found
them in their public records after I
went to the town hall with a tape
recorder and said well you keep telling
me records are available for me for
inspection well
I want to see him and at that point they
allowed me to see him I looked through
them that's when I found the records and
I asked him for it then what am I
supposed to do with these records
they're supposed to be so dangerous for
me to see
no no answer
I'm not dishing the courts
I I feel they're just trying to go along
with the superior equivalent but this is
the issues that you were presented here
that you're basically standing here the
court seems to be unclear on Whose
reputation because when I raise the
question of well I'm a person here that
the meeting was about
I ask for the meaning minutes isn't that
equivalent to asking for this to be open
and the only answer was no
because we have to protect the people
testifying
okay so the person testifying accusing
you
of wrongdoing has more rights
than the person
being accused
and this is why I think it should be
clarified all right and on top of that
I'd also like to say that it also helps
law enforcement
I've taken a lot of time
and basically putting myself feelings
aside on this because if you read my
last page on my testimony you'll know
what I went through
you don't know how it is to be three
three weeks in your in your jills on
solitary confinement
not eating deceit drinking water and
still have fake charges thrown against
you
because that's what happened to me
I'm saying
how much longer do you have to go sir a
couple more minutes so I'm staying
basically
I'm arrested
your County attorneys never questioned
how come no statements were taken prior
to my arrest
now that raises the question because now
is this closed session being used to
tamper with Witnesses
and collaborate the story with the
police
the other thing is
the chief of police made the arrest
well it was his wife as the chairman of
selectment that hold held that closed
session
it was his cousins that were involved
with the well drilling that I was
insisting being monitored according to
war
so this is a question of maybe it'll
help the prosecutors also along with the
courts
to realize that we have a right gear
so it's not just us it helps the courts
and the states all right all right
questions to this Witness
saying none thank you very much thank
you sir sorry Mr Sheriff
one question do you have any written
testimony for us
uh yes
uh Justin Lynn and he passed it around
matter of fact I emailed it to you
probably like a week or two ago okay
thank you all right uh Catherine
uh Coco Coco yes
just the way it looks
thank you members of the Judiciary
Committee my name is Catherine Coco I am
the President of right to know New
Hampshire a citizen-based organization
that provides advocacy education and
assistance to those that are seeking
access to public information and
increase transparency in government
operations
right to know New Hampshire views HB 654
as an incredibly important piece of
legislation for this year this is the
second of two pieces of legislation that
our members chose to focus on because it
addresses a critical issue that is
raised in many of the inquiries that we
receive from the public that issue is
the extremely broad nature and use of
the reputation exemption as it currently
stands this bill provides clarifying
language that restricts the use of the
reputation exemption only to require
that the individual being discussed have
the right to be notified and involved
when their reputation is up for
discussion and this bill has been
modified from a previous submission to
address major objections that were
raised in Prior legislative years
as people have stated before there
currently is no requirement for those
individuals to be involved
but I will point out and I think this is
an important point of clarification
employees who have contractual rights
are given the right to a meeting and to
request that that meeting happen in
public
when an exemption is claimed under the
Personnel exemption so Mr chair in your
example most likely a municipality that
wants to meet regarding a Personnel
issue like that would claim the
Personnel exemption and if that member
of their staff had a contract or a Union
contract that stated that they had the
right to a meeting that situation would
be covered
but there is no corresponding right for
someone who is simply a member of the
general public and is being discussed
under the reputation exemption
I think this language also provides the
benefit of making it clear exactly what
the objective of this exemption is and
that is the reputation of a non-employee
individual or organization that is the
primary concern here and as I stated
employees have a specific and there's
case law supporting that exemption under
personnel
I'd like to uh preemptively address what
I anticipate to be opposition to this
bill the argument will probably be made
that the requirement of notice will tie
the hands of the public body
I have struggled to find any examples
where that would actually be the case
the public body has a menu of exemptions
to choose from exemptions A and B
frequently referred to as Personnel
would cover the most imminent internal
actions that might be needed on a timely
basis exemptions e and l provide an
ability for the board to respond timely
to threatened or existing lawsuit and to
consider legal advice
exemption D covers most purchasing
scenarios
exemption I covers imminent safety
issues in what situation outside of
those would a non-public negative
discussion of a non-employee be
necessary or likely when opponents of
this bill raise that issue I challenge
you to push back on them ask for
concrete examples that would not fall
under another category of exemption the
reason there is going to be so much
Reliance on this exemption is because it
has served as a catch-all for so long
[Music]
uh there's also a question of a time and
delay in terms of giving appropriate
notice that's been raised and I would
note that my community sets its agenda
for the board of selectman meeting on
the Wednesday prior to the following
Monday they published that on Friday and
they identify their planned non-public
session and the basis for it it should
not prevent a board from going into
during its routine operations a
non-public session that it deems
necessary and has planned ahead for the
idea that non-publics happen off the
cuff is is something that I would
question whether or not that's actually
necessary
others here have already spoken to how
these proposed changes would help
balance the interest of the individual
that's involved in being discussed and
they've provided their own examples I
would like to testify to my personal
experience witnessing the use of this
exemption and discussions that I have
been privy to about its application
in 2022 my local Town Board of Selectmen
held 18 non-public sessions 10 of those
were categorized as Personnel under
exemptions A or B eight were held under
the heading of reputation
while this bill does not change the
reputation exemption that is allowed for
sealing the minutes that is a separate
set of exemptions and I'm not sure that
all of you are aware of that I will
tangentially note that every single set
of sealed minutes related to Personnel
were sealed on the basis of reputation
as a concern
preventing the public from seeing what
was discussed it's not clear to me
whether those Personnel members had the
right to be present or were notified as
a court in accordance with exemption a
that information is simply not captured
in public minutes
but when it comes to those sessions that
were held under the heading of
reputation which is what this bill talks
about I have two concerns that I want to
share
the first is that public bodies are very
aware of the broad nature of the
reputation exemption I don't like to use
examples I can't personally attest to
but I'm a member of the public and I
have to rely on those who have sat
through non-public sessions and the
information they've shared with me one
of the most egregious and concerning
examples I have ever heard from someone
who is very methodical in their approach
to these issues and who consults with
right to know New Hampshire for
clarification Bears repeating to this
body
in conversation with me a member of a
public body without disclosing the
content of the non-public session shared
with me that their public body was not
sure whether the discussion they were
engaged in would truly Merit exemption
under the reputation exemption
to ensure that that exemption would
apply one member of the public body
specifically stated that they found it
necessary to say something bad about an
individual or organization so that the
exemption could credibly be used to
maintain the confidentiality of that
session and so they did and Justified
the exemption
another example of the broad nature of
this exemption is one that happened
fairly recently in my hometown on
December 27 2022 my local Board of
Selectmen went into non-public session
under the reputation exemption to
protect the identity of potential donors
to the town they claimed that because
the donors would not make the donation
without anonymity they needed to discuss
those in non-public session
anonymity and potential conflict of
interest are separate but related
concerns I have with this approach but I
find the idea that making a donation to
The Community could be construed as
potentially having an adverse effect on
someone's reputation absolutely
laughable
the board could have discussed the
donation without identifying the donors
while in public session but the board
proceeded to go into non-public
according to the chairman on the advice
of legal counsel I believe that is
because legal counsel recognizes this
exemption as broad enough to cover
pretty much everything they think it can
justify
I cite these examples to point out how
easy it is to manipulate this exemption
while keeping the public and those
involved in the dark regarding the
discussion I believe that by requiring
public bodies through this bill to put
some forethought and some accountability
into the invocation of this exemption
they will become more conscientious
about its use
there is a second indirect way that I
think these changes would benefit
members of the public and it is not
admittedly the primary intent of this
bill
these changes could impact how public
discussions that impact one's reputation
are managed there is no right of an
individual to protect their own
reputation or even be free to respond
when it is up for public discussion and
this bill does not address public
discussion directly most of the time for
the sake of transparency right to know
New Hampshire would prefer those
conversations happen in the open in
public but if this bill is enacted it is
also more likely that when the
discussion begins to drift into
questionable territory in real time
with this um language in place
it may be possible to reconsider that
conversation for non-public session with
the inclusion of the individual in
question being given appropriate notice
without requiring an individual to be
notified and able to participate a
decision to move into non-public simply
hides the content of that discussion
from the individual Who's involved that
lack of knowledge does not protect them
it merely Shields those who are making
those comments and that is another
reason I think this change in language
is so important
during questions and answers if you want
I can provide a couple of very Vivid
examples where such an approach to a
public discussion was very much desired
by the individuals who are in question
but since the opportunity to participate
in closed session did not exist at the
time and it would under this bill they
had no choice but to listen to very
public accusations and claims
it is not the primary intent of this
bill but I do think it would encourage a
more thoughtful approach again and
provide a more Equitable alternative
rather than closing the doors and not
allowing the individual involved to
respond when public discussions begin to
move dangerously close to slandering
members of the public
right to know New Hampshire strongly
supports HB 652 in hopes that this body
will vote in as ought to pass and I'm
happy to answer any questions at this
time questions for this week
seeing none thank you thank you uh uh
that's great H
thank you Mr thank you Mr chair Nate
Grace for the municipal Association we
do oppose this bill uh I will be brief
because the chair already outlined a
number of concerns that we had
I don't want to be repetitious
especially after you've had such a long
day
um I do want to note a couple other uh
things
um as representative greeson pointed out
um there's no process spelled out for
how that written notifications to occur
as this committee is is aware you've
recommended House Bill 307 as octopass
which uh if a municipality were to pick
the wrong option we'd be we'd be paying
for the legal cost to get that resolved
so I prefer not to do that and I would
like some clarification if possible
um it also appears to me that the uh
numbers one two and three
um where the person has the opportunity
to be present have counsel and speak on
their own behalf is really seems to be
targeted towards a hearing type
situation not a public meeting
um and we're not talking about a hearing
under this section we're talking about
public meetings
um probably the best example I can give
you of a municipal situation where
um
where the body will enter into
non-public session is in the case of
where they are doing an abatement for
someone who is poor or unable to pay
their taxes
um if that person is on Municipal
welfare under uh RSA uh pursuant to RSA
chapter 165. the municipality can't
release information about that person uh
being on welfare there they have that
privacy protection
um and so presumably they're going to
apply for an abatement if they're in
their own home they can't pay for the
taxes and in that case the municipal is
gonna have to figure out how to
structure these type of meetings in a
way that would allow them to
have people come in and be represented
if they want to we'll also not
disclosing that they're receiving that
type of assistance so that could be
problematic that's one thing I hadn't
heard concerns of from the committee and
I just wanted to bring that to your
attention there's certainly many other
scenarios where
um some sort of uh some sort of
Investigation or other or other uh other
thing could be going on there
um
and I'm happy to take any questions that
you may have
questions for this Witness
yes representative Perez
thank you
the term that was used small town
politics is very true I've witnessed it
for the past 40 years here in New
Hampshire but it is getting
more prevalent
um
I see it in the town I live in I see it
in many towns where
um executive the use of executive
session to talk about people is
there's no reeling that in I believe is
it the sixth amendment that gives me the
right to know my Accuser
maybe that applies for
law cases but
I think that small towns small boards
Selectmen or we have Town Council where
I live
are using this executive session to
discuss people discuss things that
you have no right to defend yourself or
even hear
if what's being said is true it's a here
he said she said
and I'm not there to say that that's not
what happened and I don't mean that
personally but I think we do need some
reeling in of a small town or
municipalities so that they people who
are we need to stand up for the people
and
make sure that even though these boards
are elected that it doesn't give them
the power to take away my rights as an
individual to defend myself or defend
against being falsely accused I think
this bill
will make small town or every
municipality think twice before they say
you know you know what I heard about
Christine Perez in executive session
oh my question is is not my right to to
um uh know my accuser and know what's
beyond being accused of
so the U.S Supreme Court has been very
clear that's in the context of a a
Judicial hearing so
if you're
the government's starting some sort of
Investigation because some
information has come to your attention
it wouldn't come into play there
um I don't have a court case to cite you
right now although I do want to mention
on another context I forgot to mention I
gave your researcher a copy of the one
court case I could find in New Hampshire
the New Hampshire Supreme Court about
the reputation exemption because having
heard from this committee previously I
know you like to look at any New
Hampshire Supreme Court case decisions
and I think that's helpful to illustrate
how that functions currently under our
existing law and so she has that for the
committee we do have we do have it thank
you
yes representative yes sorry I I have
some confusion and I don't know if
you're the right person but I'm going to
ask you
um I'm hearing that this can both
protect someone's reputation
um but it's also a non-public session
where someone's reputation could be
discussed in private
and I guess I'm having trouble
reconciling that in my head
um in terms of a non-public session this
is a deliberation between the public
body that is being kept in in private
for the purpose of protecting someone's
reputation so I'm wondering
doesn't does this work in the opposite
direction as well like if somebody had
made an accusation to to save my the
board in my town select board in my town
you know and they wanted to discuss it
in private and decide whether to take
any action or not and they perhaps
decide not to take any action and the
meeting is is done and nobody was ever
notified that that it was brought up
because they decided it wasn't is that a
valid scenario is that part of what
going into non-public session would
would do that this sort of Might then
almost interfere with
yes I think that's very valid
um
you know it's it's obviously the case
that
if someone doesn't like you as I
experience quite frequently
um they may talk about you in public or
they may talk about you in in private
and there are certainly
different factual contexts where Maybe
more impactful on how the legislature
sees me for example
um and whether that's done in private or
public it may be the case that
um there's a discussion that occurs in
private that resolves successfully and
nothing is to be made public and that's
for the best for everyone it may be the
case that that's not the it's not the
case but it's currently uh the local
decision and
uh I believe everyone
hopefully striving towards making the
best decision with the information they
have on hand as to whether to make that
public or not
other questions for this Witness
saying none thank you oh I'm sorry
representative trip sorry
uh
I'm gonna follow up on something uh
representative said uh it seems to me
that uh discussion of uh
uh someone in a non-public session is
more akin to uh you know evaluating a
discussion an investigation or something
would you agree with that
I would I think that and that uh should
they be charged with something
should should the the discussion lead to
a charge that would be public is that
correct correct
so obviously that would go through the
regular court process which is of course
public
so so it's it seems like uh it is
representative tour said uh if you if
you're in between
the investigation and the decision uh
it's
it's worthwhile to make sure it's done
in non-public so that should you decide
not to make an accusation that remains
private is that correct yes all right
thank you
I guess I'm um what do you say one of
the things that that um was raised in I
think in previous in response to my
earlier question was that well in the
example that I gave the ability to have
the matter
conducted uh non-publicly without the
person whose reputation might be
adversely affected uh having to fall
within this proposed section would be
the personnel
the exemption for personnel matters or
something like that and so what do you
say about that you know that this so
under
um RSA 91a3 Roman 2 a if you're an
employee there's already a provision for
allowing investigation and that
sort of kick off could start a
non-public session
um
so I guess to to you to borrow an
example that was brought up earlier
it may be the case that if a library
director decides to do something without
the advice and consent of the trustees
these
that Library director might be
investigated and witnesses to whatever
is occurring might be interviewed as
part of that investigation the witness's
reputation wouldn't be at stake but they
wouldn't necessarily be informed of the
investigation because they just know
whatever part of the event and then the
investigators job is to put it all
together if it's the case that it's
you know a library trustee being accused
of stealing money for example
um then that person is not an employee
of the Town therefore they wouldn't fall
under that first exemption that's
specific to employees
but it might be the case the accusation
was made of course that they're stealing
so maybe the library director comes to
the select board and says hey the one of
the trustees is stealing money
um and at that point the select board
enters non-public session under
reputation to kick off the investigation
of that of that local elected official
and because obviously they're not a
Public Employee so it does get
complicated
all right other questions for this week
seeing none thank you thank you
Douglas uh osterhout
good afternoon thank you Mr chair
Douglas osterhout for oplc uh thank you
to the members of the committee for
letting me speak today
um I was kind of thrown into this bill
at the last minute so I have been
jotting notes but the oplc does not take
a position on this language but we do
have a number of concerns I was having a
little bit of difficulty hearing I think
some of them may have already been
addressed but I there's three key things
that I've identified right away and one
of those again would be individuals who
are subject to the complaint under
statutes multiple places throughout the
statutes complaints under oplc that come
to op LC are confidential and what we
might have here is a situation where a
complaint comes in an investigator at
oplc reviews that complaint thinks it's
without Merit either there's nothing
there's no no claim in that complaint
for which relief could be granted or
that would be a violation of Statute or
Rule and we might bring an investigator
before a board and recommend not to
proceed with this matter the board would
have that discretion they could choose
whether to investigate or not and then
pending the outcome of an investigation
and another recommendation the board
would be able to either proceed with
discipline or not the way the statutes
currently read is until a board decides
to move forward with public discipline
all of that would be confidential after
if a board decides to investigate the
matter an individual who's the subject
of a complaint would typically be
notified there are instances where they
happen far and few between but where at
the perhaps request of law enforcement
and maybe a drug related matter so as
not to tip law enforcement's hand they
might ask us not to proceed immediately
with contacting the subject of the
complaint and if a complaint is
completely without Merit uh the subject
of the complaint may never be aware of
that complaint at all
um so I just want to put that out there
another instance where we might see
non-public situations is 10 licensing
applications may come in for approval by
the board three of those individuals
might have a criminal history uh that
board might go into non-public to
discuss that criminal history mediating
factors it might be as simple as you
know they got caught shoplifting when
they were 18. they haven't had any
problems in 20 years
we don't see a reason not to approve
this individual go back into public
these 10 individuals are all approved uh
in a case like that if abort did need
more information they might call a show
cause hearing give the individual an
opportunity to come in and explain
themselves and and then of course if
there's a denial there's always a right
to appeal in which case they would get
to hear the matter before the board and
the other instance I caught and this is
a very important one from oplc's
perspective I think is that under 541 a
30 Roman numeral three if an agency
finds that public health safety or
welfare requires emergency action and
incorporates a finding to that effect
they can call a meeting have an ex parte
hearing and revoke an individuals and
license without notification to the
other person because it's an emergency
situation and I have seen these happen
where the facts are found in the morning
the board is contact in the afternoon
and there's an extra party hearing the
next morning and in those cases an
individual has a right to a hearing
within 10 days of that process happening
so they still get an opportunity to
defend themselves but those emergency
suspensions can happen very very quickly
so those are sort of the concerns that
jumped in out to me again oplc does not
take a position but we did think we
would come and raise some of those
issues and I am happy to answer any
questions anyone may have questions for
this Witness
yes representative greeson thank you Mr
chair and thank you sir that was very
informative would you please uh if you
it's a convenient provide us with a
written statement of your concerns that
we can then remember when it comes time
to actually discuss the bill in our own
executive session uh it was very
informative thank you absolutely I'll do
that I would have prepared a statement
but as I said um
I wasn't planning on being here today
we understand
other questions for this Witness
thank you very much thank you very much
you know I know I know I think we don't
have any other pink cards but uh
representative O'Brien I wonder if I
could ask you uh one question
representative O'Brien and that's is I'm
uh oh Brian I'm wondering could I we
didn't ask you this and I'm just
wondering could you tell us
are you aware if there are any other
jurisdictions in the country that have
adopted Provisions like this
no I'm not aware of that but I do focus
in very closely on where I live and
where I have all of my activities so
there may be
um other places certainly but I spend so
much time focused on New Hampshire okay
all right I I will add one other thing I
wanted to say was
that episode
felt like
a Witch Hunt it felt like I was being
scapegoated that my friend and the
library trustee from that library was
being scapegoated and that it felt like
an abuse of power and that I think is
something that other people in the state
feel all right thank you very much thank
you
all right um is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on HB 652 fa
being none I'm going to close the
hearing on HB 52 652 and I think uh we
are done
yes
all right well thank you to my fellow uh
committee members for being here and
thank you for everyone who thank you to
everyone who has testified
I know I know that's it we finished
early
foreign